[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous ravis de vous
retrouver pour l'événement phare de la
semaine au sénat les questions au
gouvernement elle commence dans une
heure à 15 heures précises on va à les
décortiquer les analyser et avancer on
va débattre de l'actualité avec de
nombreux invités sur ce plateau et avec
notre équipe de journalistes fidèle au
poste avec nous steve jourdain dans
l'hémicycle du sénat hâtives
un mot sur le programme et les grands
thèmes de la séance qui nous attend on
parlera notamment tam définissent-ils à
la suite de ce drame
dayan gens en moselle ce chiffre il est
glaçante à 1 43 femmes ont déjà été tués
depuis le début de l'année en france
quelle est la réponse de l'exécutif
l'exécutif qui avait fait bien de la
cause des femmes la grande cause du
quinquennat sur ce point le gouvernement
sera interpellé par les sénateurs dans
quelques instants
et merci beaucoup steve à tout à l'heure
également avec nous alexandre poussin
salle de conférence pour toutes les
interviews des ministres des sénateurs
alors qui va t'on entendre votre micro
cet après midi bonjour tu as mais bien
pour parler de cette question urgente
des féminicides à je serai avec la
ministre de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
elisabeth moreno ce sera juste après les
questions d'actualité à 16h15 merci
alexandre dans une demi-heure notre face
à face autour du pass sanitaire d'un
côté le président du groupe les
indépendants le médecin également claude
malhuret qui demande au gouvernement de
mettre en place le pass sanitaire au
plus vite
face à lui le sénateur centriste loïc
hervé il est lui très inquiets et pointe
du doigt un risque de surveillance de
masse le duel s'annonce vif il est à
suivre à 14h30
[Musique]
mais d'abord la justice accusé de
laxisme par les policiers une semaine
après la manifestation des forces de
l'ordre devant l'assemblée nationale la
réforme de la justice a été adoptée hier
par les députés
un texte dont l'examen a été percuté par
l'actualité sécuritaire après la mort
d'un policier à avignon notamment on va
en parler sur ce plateau avec quatre
invités avec étienne blanc bonjour vous
êtes sénateur les républicains du rhône
face à vous esther benbassa vous êtes
dit sénatrice écologiste de paris
et puis également en visio nous sommes
avec alexia jarmon avocate au barreau de
paris et présidente du think tank france
audacieuse et avec jean yves le conte
sénateur socialiste représentant les
français établis hors de france merci à
tous les cadres de participer à ce débat
on va d'abord regarder bien d'un peu
plus près le texte qui a été adopté hier
le texte d'eric dupond-moretti quelles
dispositions précisément ont été
ajoutées au projet de loi en réponse à
la pression policière
on voit cela avec guillaume bertrand
ce sont des amendements sont ses
protégés les policiers et calmer leur
colère après la manifestation policière
de ce week-end le gouvernement a musclé
son projet de loi et ajouté trois
grandes mesures une peine de sûreté de
trente ans à destination des condamnés à
perpétuité pour un crime contre un
policier ou un gendarme
la limitation des réductions de peine
pour tous les agresseurs des membres de
forces de l'ordre et la fin des rappels
à la loi jugée inefficace
il représentait pourtant 2019 plus de
20% de la réponse pénale
dans une lettre ouverte le syndicat des
avocats de france s'inquiète déjà de ces
mesures alors même que la france a été
condamnée par la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme à prendre des mesures
urgentes pour résorber de manière
définitive sa surpopulation carcérale le
législateur propose un dispositif qui
aura nécessairement pour conséquence
l'augmentation du nombre de prisonniers
dans la sphère politique le texte ne
convainc pas non plus pour le sénateur
jérôme durain ces mesures relèvent de
l'amateurisme et ne suffiront pas à
rétablir le dialogue
mais j'ai le sentiment que ce qui nous
est proposé suffisent
réconcilier ces deux institutions ce qui
étend une vraie difficulté pour nous
tous parce qu'on a vraiment besoin
d'avoir une continuer une continuité
pardon entre entre la police la justice
même si le texte a été largement adoptée
à l'assemblée nationale avec 342 voix
pour et 105 voix contre le projet n'a
obtenu ni les voix de la gauche ni celle
de la droite
il sera examiné au sénat en septembre
etienne blanc le texte d'eric
dupond-moretti a donc été modifié
enrichi de plusieurs mesures
sécuritaires ans a été rappelé dans le
sujet notamment la peine de sûreté qui
passe de 22 à 30 ans pour ceux qui
commettent un crime contre un policier
ou un gendarme la fin des rappels à la
loi qui sont jugées inefficaces et la
limitation des réductions de peine pour
les agresseurs des forces de l'ordre on
a entendu à gauche personne n'est
convaincu
pour vous est-ce que ça va dans le bon
sens mais sûr que non c'est une toute
petite évolution mais c'est pas le sujet
le sujet aujourd'hui il est très simple
nous avons une institution judiciaire
qui grosso modo coûte à la république 8
milliards d'euros c'est le budget de la
justice avec tous avec la prison la
rémunération des gardiens de prisons etc
et puis le fonctionnement de la justice
à la fois administrative et judiciaire
et qu'est ce que l'on constate on
constate aujourd'hui que les françaises
et les français n'ont plus confiance
dans cette institution parce qu' elle ne
répond pas a besoin de sécurité et
l'institution judiciaire ne prononce pas
les peines qui sont attendues par les
français donc et on a l'impression d'un
système qui tourne à vide et l'alliance
histoire de la réponse pénale quand même
qu'il ya un abruti durcissement de la
réponse pénale mais par exemple un sujet
qui n'est pas traitée 50% des amendes
qui sont prononcés ne sont pas recouvrée
c'est ça le sujet donc j'avais
aujourd'hui une institution qui
fonctionne qui prononce des peines des
peines d'amendés mais ya pas de
résultats au même titre que le rythme
d'exécution des peines n'est pas mais
n'est pas bon on a 80 % aujourd'hui
des peines qui ne sont pas exécutées
donc la réponse elle devrait
être là comment faire en sorte que quand
la justice prononce une peine elle soit
suivi les faits et comment faire en
sorte quand il ya des faits qui sont des
faits délictuels
il ya une réponse judiciaire esther
benbassa alors cela ne convient pas à
étienne blanc parce que ça ne va pas
assez loin vous quel est votre point de
vue est-ce que ce durcissement pénales à
l'égard des agresseurs de policiers vous
paraît justifiée je rappelle que
d'ailleurs les écologistes à l'exception
de yannick jadot n'étaient pas là la
semaine dernière à la manifestation des
policiers devant l'assemblée vous non
plus non moi je suis pour l'augmentation
des subventions bon jeu recrutement plus
nombreux pour l'amélioration des
conditions
mais enfin écoutez niveau judiciaire ou
des policiers des policiers et en plus
j'étais un peu choqué que les policiers
trouvent que la justice est laxiste
c'était l'un des mots d'ordre a conduit
à rien quand on regarde de près
aujourd'hui il y à 60% de plus de
détenus qu'il y a vingt ans alors on
peut pas aller encore plus loin surtout
quand on n'a même pas assez de place
dans les prisons moi je jeu j'ai
toujours pensé et que la police et la
justice travailler la main dans la main
pour aller de pour régler des problèmes
et aujourd'hui mettre en question la
justice me semblent inadmissibles
il y à une séparation des pouvoirs en
france on ne peut pas comme ça mais la
police ne peut pas elle même dire qu'il
n'ya pas assez de justice et en plus je
vais ajouter que la police a dicté et
quasiment cette ppl sécurité globale et
je crois que aujourd'hui on est dans un
certain populisme et puis monsieur je
lancerai dans le nord avec vous puisque
45% des personnes interrogées le 25
janvier 2021 dès que la faire confiance
à la police
donc il n'y a pas eu un manque de
confiance c'est chez les jeunes qui lie
à un manque de confiance à l'endroit des
policiers et on voit que c'est que soit
tôt avec 2 53%
vous voyez enfin n'ont pas confiance 53%
en la police c'est lié probablement à
toutes ces actions à tout c est à toutes
ces manifestations qui sont terminées
pour vous notamment les manifestations
gilet jaune sécurité globale
oui je me souviens qui est mort et steve
qu'anissa haut à nantes etc etc
allez alexia germans est ce que pour
vous il y as matière a opposé la police
et la justice
la semaine dernière on le rappeler le
nom d'eric dupond-moretti a été hué par
les policiers les forces de l'ordre
réclame des comptes à la justice qu'ils
jugent trop laxistes ont-ils raison
bonjour oui comme ça je crois qu alex et
hajar monde
est-ce que vous m'entendez alexia
germond oui est ce qu'il ya pour vous
matière a opposé la police et la justice
je rappelais la semaine dernière combien
est bien eric dupond moretti avait pu
avoir son nom tu es poser une question
on va leur passer d'abord par jean yves
le conte alors jean yves le conte est ce
que pour vous il ya matière à opposer la
police et la justice puisque je le
rappelais eric dupond moretti a vu son
nom eut et la semaine dernière et la
justice a été jugée trop laxiste par les
policiers n'y a pas matière à opposer
deux institutions qui obéissent à des
logiques qui sont différentes mais ils
ont chacun leur rôle dans la société
elles n'ont pas la même finalité n'ont
pas le même rôle et non pas la même
temporalité et elles doivent être en
plus indépendantes l'une de l'autre dans
un état de droit puisque la police et
laissé cutif et la justice c'est
l'autorité judiciaire donc mettre l'une
sous tutelle de l'autre
serait finalement une contradictoire
avec l'état de droit donc c'est pas
logique c'est pas nouveau cette
dialectique d'une certaine manière la
hougue à quelque chose d'un peu lourd
c'est cédant finalement la confusion des
genres que ministre de l'intérieur
entretien aujourd'hui alors que
réellement on a une réponse pénale qui
est de plus en plus sévères depuis
depuis 15 ans et que finalement quand on
n'entend ce que j'ai entendu de mon
collègue tout à l'heure et républicain
c'est assez irresponsable la réponse
pénale est de plus en plus dur
même si on peut toujours trouver des
contre exemples qui vont heurter notre
émotion mais globalement la réponse
pénale est de plus en plus dur et si il
ya des pseudo responsables politiques
qui passent leur temps à dire qu'il n'ya
pas de responsable finalement c'est une
incitation à l'infraction qui est
totalement irresponsable quand on
regarde ce qu'est aujourd'hui la peña
l'offenseur je ne dis pas que tout est
parfait vous estimez que c'est ce que
dit gérald darmanin aujourd'hui vous
estimez que c'est ce que dit aussi
gérald darmanin aujourd'hui puisque vous
n'avez pas être confusion des genres
donc j'essaie de comprendre exactement
je gérais hermana là où il confond les
gens c'est que il
il est mise de l'intérieur et en tant
que ministre de l'intérieur il doit
répondre et dialoguer avec la police
dont il a la responsabilité
mais aller manifester devant le
parlement en finalement refusant un
diallo pour expliquer finalement quel
est le rôle que la police doit avoir
là pour le coup c'est la confusion des
genres ne peut pas être séduit en même
temps je dirais même que il est au de la
dure-mère temps et les deux j'en suis je
suis pour et même contre ses 7,7 ce site
une confusion qui ne permettra pas de
sortir de deux de ceux de cette
situation l'opposition police justice
c'est pas une opposition c'est une
espèce
c'est une rhétorique qui fait progresser
les choses parce que chacun a sa ça à sa
finalité et et son et son rôle tout soit
c'est que ça ne faut pas que le
comportement actuel de gérald darmanin
et profondément 2
entre dans la confusion de la même
manière que l'opposition droite joue le
même rôle pour moi par exemple ce que
j'entends d'ailleurs le recouvrement des
amendes c'est pas dur de la justice le
budget de la justice que nous avons en
france est l'un des plus faibles
européen par papa par habitant si on
veut avoir pourtant si on veut poser les
ij exigences des élus de la justice
il faut lui donner les moyens de faire
les choses et de les faire rapidement et
ce n'est pas du tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
oui jean yves le conte le gouvernement
en tout cas vous parlez de gérald
darmanin à l'instant répond lui qu'il
n'y a pas matière à opposer la police et
la justice on va écouter justement le
ministre de l'intérieur hier aux
questions d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale il a d'ailleurs répondu à la
place d'eric dupond-moretti à une
question il écoute je vous fait réagir
un permet de suppléer le garde des
sceaux pris au sénat j'espère que vous
les excuserez et le fait que je réponde
montre sans doute qu'il n'y a pas de la
division que vous souhaitez espérer
le texte de loi porté par eric dupond
moretti est non seulement un texte
important pour la justice des français
mais un texte important pour les
policiers pour les gendarmes il ne faut
pas opposer police et justice
le garde des sceaux a proposé un texte
important et c'est grâce à
l'augmentation du budget de la police et
la justice de ce gouvernement que demain
le miz intérieur a sans doute moins de
travail voilà impossible bien sûr pour
le ministre de l'intérieur de critiquer
le garde des sceaux et vice versa
regardez d'ailleurs ce qu'a déclaré eric
dupond moretti dans le journal du
dimanche
il a déclaré dans une interview la
police en la justice et le totalitarisme
la justice en la police c'est
l'impuissance et deux institutions
mérite le respect de tous les
républicains
ce que dit gérald darmanin de la justice
est en phase avec ce que je pense alexia
germond le gouvernement nous dit et bien
qu'il n'y a aucune opposition à voir
entre la police et la justice et en même
temps on a bien entendu à paris entre
les critiques de jean yves le conte sur
la présence de gérald darmanin à une
manifestation où la justice était
pointée du doigt par les policiers oui
bien sûr mais les critiques à ce moment
là sont sont plus formulé dans une
perspective plus politique moi ce que je
trouve vraiment très significative c'est
qu'en fait quand on oppose la police et
la justice
on est justement totalement dans l'eau
dans le contraire de ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le rôle de
la police et nos rôles de la justice
sont complémentaires pour une fin qui
est pour une finalité qui est commune à
la colonne vertébrale que nous devons
protéger pour la nation c'est-à-dire le
régalien
la sécurité d'abord des français bien
sûr et puis aussi le positionnement de
de l'autorité de l'état qui en a bien
besoin en ce moment je crois qu'on est
quand même à un moment vraiment
charnière on voit bien qu on essaye de
rattraper le retard sur la partie
justice évidemment avec 7 se dégage est
en augmentation mais au delà du budget
en augmentation ce qui est intéressant
c'est pas suffisant mais on ne peut pas
mettre sur le compte du gouvernement le
fait de rattraper le la paupérisation de
la justice que l'on a connu pendant
toutes ces années
donc aujourd'hui on est ce qui est
intéressant dans la façon dont ça se ça
ruisselle on va dire à l'intérieur même
de la structuration de la justice ces
convois tient très gros pot le
immobilier qui va face notamment à la
construction des prisons des 15000
places de prisons qui est annoncé sur
est programmée jusqu'en 2027 donc ça ça
prend énormément un coût de 500 millions
d'euros et puis on a toute la partie et
c'est là où je voudrais il venir en
venir on a toute la partie sur le
personnel en fait et là vous voyez que
c'est à la fois ça redevient de
saupoudrage malheureusement parce que
les budgets et les la nécessité tels de
ce budget que on a une petite partie
pour l'administration pénitentiaire
on a les services judiciaires on à la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse qui
ne va avoir que 40 emplois en plus par
exemple
donc on va avoir en fait des renforts
aussi sur les services pénitentiaires
d'insertion et probation c'est une
centaine d'emplois les greffiers bien
entendu évidemment très important donc
dans la réponse pénale
je finirai jeu
des problèmes de moyens mais pas que je
finirais juste sur le fait qu' il y à
une question de temporalité qui
aujourd'hui est un vrai
dysfonctionnements pourquoi on a eu tout
ce débat qui a été assez publics
notamment la semaine dernière sur la
question de de peine à nouveau courte
mais très rapidement poste le jugement
parce que en fait en ne vous avez c'est
toute la problématique que il avait ne
serait-ce qu'avec la suppression des
rappels à la loi
dire que c'était 20% de la réponse
pénale ça montre bien qu'il va falloir
trouver une alternative à ces à ses
rappels à la loi qui ont été supprimés
et là il faudrait je pansse mettre en
place très rapidement une contraction de
l'échelle temps pour pouvoir avoir un
effet bien évidemment dissuasif et
pédagogique au travers des pannes qui
sont eux qui sont prononcés esther
benbassa gel soit exécuté esther
benbassa c'est moi j'ai réagi aussi
insisté sur l'aspect politique de la
question aujourd'hui la droite
veut chasser sur les terres du rl est
les policiers ont droit à tout on les
met en avant bien sûr tous nous
respectons la police nous une vie et
bien sûr et la république en marche vous
seulement la droite là où la droite
aussi les maquereaux nice on voit avec
monsieur da manha parce que c'est vrai
que si on regarde les sondages de vote
c'est très inquiétant 44% des policiers
et militaires envisage désormais de
voter pour marine le pen au premier tour
et ensuite 60% choisir au second tour
deux duels entre macron et marine le pen
de voter pour marine le pen et chez les
policiers actifs ce chiffre pourrait
atteindre 74 % lors du second tour il
faut voir donc les policiers et choyé vu
que c'est quand même un 10 ans
présentera deux votes pour et rennes
pour le rl non mais attendez il faut pas
aujourd'hui mais empiéter notre
démocratie
en mettant la justice et la police est
l'une contre l'autre
la justice c'est le socle de la
démocratie et les policiers de la
prévention de la protection etc
mais là on est à un moment où tout le
monde joue la carte sécuritaire et on va
pas s'en sortir on va jamais corrigée
est ce que font aussi les policiers
parce qu'il ya des violences policières
il faudrait changer de discours de
formation et tisser ce lien entre les
citoyens et les policiers et un aigle en
question très importante qu'il ya
derrière tout cela bien sûr est bien ce
fond d'élection on
à quelques semaines des régionales à
moins d'un an d'élections
présidentielles la sécurité on a vu
c'est un thème qui est devenu
extrêmement important et esther benbassa
le disais les policiers peuvent être
très tenté par le rassemblement des deux
choses d'abord opposé police et justice
and absolument aucun sens ces deux
institutions différentes et un garde des
sceaux il y analyse l'intérieur le rôle
de mise intérieur c'est quand il ya une
infraction de constituer les éléments
probants et puis ensuite la justice juge
elle nous aimons la justice aussi c'est
de surveiller les conditions dans
lesquelles la police exerce ses
activités
ce qui est parfaitement normal non moi
je veux bien que l'on dise c'est
politique
mais la politique elle répond un état de
l'opinion un besoin des français quand
les français se rendre dans l'isoloir
ils vont dire si oui ou non ils sont
satisfaits de des conditions dans
lesquelles le gouvernement assurent leur
sécurité bien le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les français ne
l'acceptent plus est majoritairement
quand ils vont aller voter c'est en
fonction de leur protection et de la
sécurité qui vont faire un choix
déterminant et je trouve là dessus que
les textes que nous venons d'adopter
ils ne sont pas à la hauteur les
français aujourd'hui n'ont plus
confiance dans le système public pour
assurer la tranquillité et la sécurité
publique
voilà donc on va dire que ce politique à
des élections pas du tout c'est un état
de l'opinion aujourd'hui qui est
particulièrement alarmant à ce propos on
va justement rejoindre alexandre poussin
salle des conférences un toujours autour
et bien de ce climat de ce contexte
sécuritaire exacerbée aujourd'hui votre
micro dominique verrien sénatrice
centriste
oui dominique veryant qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce débat actuel sur la
sécurité sur les relations police
justice avec ces mesures prises un peu
en dernière minute pour satisfaire les
policiers par le gouvernement est ce
qu'il ya aussi quand même un contexte
électoraliste derrière tout ça il ya
très clairement un contexte
électoraliste ou en marche a envie de
montrer que c'est aussi être fort et
soutenir ces policiers on l'a vu avec
gérald darmanin qui va défiler aux côtés
des policiers alors qu'ils auraient
plutôt être dû plutôt dû être aux côtés
du ministre de la justice pour montrer
que le gouv
moment évidemment les entendais mais
faisait bloc pour pouvoir avoir une
réponse coordonnée et ensemble donc oui
c'est beaucoup de communication
est ce que m finalement au coeur du
débat exacerbé le thème de la sécurité
des violences c'est ne pas faire
finalement le jeu du rassemblement
national qui est très populaire sur ce
thème vous voulez dire faire le jeu de
en marche finalement puisque ça lui
permettra de n'avoir qu'un ennemi le
front national et plus il le fera monter
et plus il a l'impression que il sera le
seul à pouvoir lutter contre je crains
que ce soit un jeu très dangereux et
qu'il risque de se faire dépasser par ce
genre de combines et c'est dommage
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'hyper
présence du ministre de l'intérieur
charles dharmanand vous le disais était
aux côtés des policiers la semaine
dernière ce week-end il a porté plainte
contre audrey pulvar candidate aux
régionales avant finalement de l'inviter
à échanger au ministère c'est un excès
de zèle
c'est pas un excès de zèle là pour le
coup c'était une communication manquer
autant le président de la république
fait du marketing réussie avec avec des
youtuber autant là il a essayé aussi de
communiquer gérald darmanin mais ça a
ses petites puisque justement on savait
bien que cette plainte ne pouvait de
toute façon pas abouti donc il fallait
bien qu'ils se récupère aux branches en
invitant andré pulvar en disant je note
qu'elle a dit que la police n'était pas
raciste
si beaucoup de gesticulations qui nuit à
mon avis à l'efficacité de la justice je
ne suis pas sûr de la justice et de la
police et je suis pas sûr que ça
ramènera les policiers dans le giron de
en marche comme il souhaite le faire
alors la loi justice va arriver au sénat
en septembre
est ce que justement comme vous le dites
aller trop vite gesticuler sur réagir ça
peut entraîner le fait qu'on fait mal la
loi alors ça peut l'entraîner évidemment
et de parts et d'autres jeux venir en
marche n'a pas non plus que ce enfin
n'est pas le seul à pouvoir avoir ce
défaut pour autant nous chez nous ça
arrivera cette loi justice au mois de
septembre donc nous aurons le temps d'y
travailler sérieusement
en ayant passé déjà le cap des
régionales et départementales qui à mon
avis hystérise le débat gérald darmanin
qui sait pas trop où il habite au niveau
de hauts de france malgré tout besoin
d'exister nationalement puisque pour
essayer de gagner quelques voix là bas
je pense qu'on aura passé sa en
septembre on pourra regarder plus
calmement et je crois que la commission
des lois fera un travail sérieux parce
qu'il ya des choses intéressantes dans
ce projet de loi or il n'ya pas c'est
pas le grand soir de la justice non plus
mais si on peut y rajouter des choses
qui permettent de mieux fonctionner et
d'avoir un meilleur lien justement entre
police et justice ça pourrait être très
intéressant merci beaucoup de musiques
variées et vous le voyez tam le débat
sera peut-être un petit peu plus serein
en septembre au sénat
avec ce projet de loi sur la justice
merci alexandre et dominique bianchi en
attendons en tout cas ne mâche pas ses
mots en vis-à-vis de ce que fait le
gouvernement qui estime qu'il ya
beaucoup de gesticulations de la part de
gérald darmanin jean yves le conte
on est dans un climat sécuritaire en
tout cas à s'exacerber à quelques
semaines des élections est ce que vous
voyez aussi cela dans ce début de
polémique à laquelle est bien on a pu
faire référence 1 2001 a fait référence
au tour d'audrey pulvar qui avait
qualifié de glaçante la manifestation
des polices et contre qui gérald
darmanin voulu porter plainte avant de
finalement reculé ces derniers jours
oui je pourrais reprendre beaucoup de ce
qu'a dit ma collègue dominique derrière
de ce point de vue là c'est clair que
c'est de la gestion sig des
gesticulations pour exister qui n'a pas
beaucoup apporté au débat mais c'est
vrai que le gouvernement dans cette
affaire par exemple sur les questions de
réduction de peine
on pourrait se dire à robert plus
sévères ça va être bien
bon on a bien des bailleurs sur la
question du terrorisme et on s'est rendu
compte que finalement en étant menés en
supprimer un certain nombre de
possibilités de réduction de peine au
juge d'application des peines des
condamnés pour terrorisme
on augmentait la dangerosité des gens
puisqu'en fait finalement au provoque
des sorties sèches son suivi socio
judiciaire
si c'est la même chose qu'on veut faire
pour pour d'autres types de condamner on
va près la même chose c'est à dire que
on va faire semblant d'être plus sévère
pour finalement construire une société
où la réponse pénale sera plus dur mais
la société sera plus fragiles parce
qu'on a voulu on
a voulu simplement durcir en pensant que
simplement durcir ce sera mieux
ensuite il yad'autres ya d'autres sujets
moi je je suis assez étonné de voir la
manière dont on aborde la question de la
sécurité aujourd'hui du rôle de la
justice et de la police par exemple en
matière de lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants
je crois que l'équipe que nous avons
aujourd'hui dans ce pays et le rôle
qu'on donne à la justice et à la police
dans un pays où il ya 10% pouces 10 %
des français qui sont des consommateurs
des ratios occasionnels pose un vrai
problème parce que finalement il ya 10%
de la population qui dans ses actes dans
ces actes ne n'est pas en harmonie avec
leurs hôtes condamne à la fois à la
police et à la justice sur cette
politique là et donc à partir de là bien
entendu on va vers de grandes
difficultés
si on ne clarifie pas sur un certain
nombre de grands objectifs le rôle qu'on
veut donner à la police à l'exécutif et
les noix qu'on demandait la justice
d'appliquer et ça c'est le rôle du
législateur et et je crois que une des
difficultés que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est cette espèce de schizophrénie
qu'on a entre le comportement individuel
de 10% des français et est les
politiques publiques qui doivent être
mises en oeuvre tant qu'on n'aura pas
trouvé un consensus pour que finalement
le comportement des 98 % des français qu
on soit en harmonie avec ce qu'on
demande aux autorités judiciaires et et
à la police on aura une difficulté et ça
ne pourra que s'aggraver
pour conclure je voudrais que on aborde
un effectivement la dimension politique
à laquelle vous faisiez référence aussi
esther benbassa en parlant notamment de
cet édito de françoise fressoz dans le
monde
elle a pointé hier du doigt le fait que
pour elle
et bien c'est un jeu qui est dangereux
qui fournit du carburant à marine le pen
qui voit la droite républicaine tous
courants confondus courir derrière ces
deux thèmes de prédilection la sécurité
l'immigration
lippert compétition sécuritaire est un
poison pour la démocratie conclut-elle
alexia germes ou qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette vie de françoise fressoz
ce pur qui est bien le climat actuel est
dangereux et peut vraiment aider le
rassemblement national
en fait je pense pas que ça soit le
climat est effectivement très dangereux
aujourd'hui mais je pense que la
meilleure façon de combattre les
réponses que souhaite donner le fn à ce
climat c'est encore de ne pas nier la
réalité et en cela je rejoins les propos
du sénateur
etienne blanc tout à l'heure que je
trouvais très très juste parce que en
fait il ne faut pas penser que tout est
politique dire que tout est politique ça
veut donc dire nier la réalité et en
niant la réalité vous refusez d'apt de
das comptait finalement les sujets qui
ont émergé aujourd'hui oui il y à une
montée aujourd'hui dans notre pays des
violences faites aux personnes
voilà ces objectifs on peut on peut
essayer de donner des explications qui
peuvent qui peuvent être différentes
selon le prisme politique qu'on peut
avoir
mais aujourd'hui par rapport à 2010 est
vous avez plus 35% de violence politique
de violences faites aux personnes pardon
donc aujourd'hui on est vraiment sur des
sujets sur lesquels je crois que il faut
combattre avec force et vigueur les
solutions qui sont proposées par le fnl
parce que par le rn pardon parce qu'on
voit bien que c'est un poison mortifère
qui vise à fracasser finalement l'unité
de la société
mais ce n'est pas en niant les
problématiques auxquelles nous avons à
faire face et qui sont bien devant nous
que on arrivera à faire baisser le fn
oui st denis en les stigmatisant
il ne faut pas il ne faut pas nier ce
problème la gauche doit aussi accepter
de voir en face à ces problèmes
sécuritaires qui sont aujourd'hui
présents dans la société
qu'est ce qui vous a dit qu'on les voit
pas enfin vous savez les questions
régaliennes intéresse les écologistes
quand on on les a jamais nié mais je ne
suis pas d'accord avec madame
comme quoi c'est pas
il n'y a pas que des problèmes
politiques oui il y à des violences les
violences je ne connais pas le taux de
montée des violences par rapport aux
années précédentes il y à des violences
de la part aussi des policiers et moi
des gendarmes
mais moi que je dirais que cette
compétition avec le fn est mortifère
parce que c'est politique
et ce n'est pas ce n'est pas pour
combattre les violences qu'on doit opter
pour les l'idéologie du et rennes qui
n'a pas de programme économique a
présenté mais qui a fait de
l'immigration et de la sécurité des
points principaux de son programme
et ça ne suffit pas pour gérer la france
et ses dents nous sommes dans le
populisme et je rejette ce populisme
parce que c'est ce populisme qui est
dangereux mais on l'a vu dans l'histoire
un devis risques dangereux etienne ou
blanc votre réponse et le mot de la fin
sur ce débat il ya deux choses qui tue
une démocratie est la première chose
c'est de venir et réalité le peuple
français aujourd'hui y constate qu'un
déferlement de violence et la deuxième
chose qui nuit aux démocraties c'est
l'illusion faire croire que par des lois
par une politique publique
on va apporter une réponse sur
l'inquiétude du peuple français mais je
crois que le gouvernement actuel il est
dans trop mesures sur les questions de
sécurité et dans les textes qui vient de
présenter
il est dans l'illusion et on sait y
commettre deux fautes majeures bien
merci merci à tous les quatre avant de
participer à ce débat nous sommes
maintenant à moins d'une demi-heure du
début des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
nos journalistes sont toujours à leur
poste alexandre pouchard salle des
conférences type jourdain dans
l'hémicycle du sénat
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus ce style sur le programme
qui nous attend à 15 heures je peux bien
sur dame on en parlera c'est d'après on
parlera cet après-midi et bien du fait
des féminicides dans ce contexte
dramatique dans ce contexte est bien dû
féminicide en moselle avec un seul
chiffre
tam que je peux vous donner ce chiffre
il est glaçant 43,43 comme le nombre de
femmes qui ont déjà été tués depuis le
début de l'année en france on s'en
rappelle le gouvernement avait fait et
bien de la cause des femmes la grande
conche du quinquennat où en est-on de
cette grande cause que compte faire le
gouvernement pour mettre un coup d'arrêt
à ces féminicide le gouvernement sera
interpellé sur ce sujet dans quelques
instants et puis dans quelques instants
parlera aussi des suites de la sphère
dit sarah halimi cette affaire qui a
suscité beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion en
france tellement d'émotion qu'elle avait
bien incité emmanuel macron à promettre
une réforme du code pénal
où en est on est bien de cette réforme
quelles sont les grandes pistes les
grandes lignes du futur texte du
gouvernement on en parlera dans quelques
instants dans cet hémicycle table merci
beaucoup steve et en attendant on va
parler du pass sanitaires qui se précise
chaque jour un peu plus on va en parler
dans notre face à face dans un instant
mais d'abord on va voir on sommes là
quoi va ressembler ce pas sanitaire avec
jordan klein il se présentera sous forme
numérique sur l'application tout senti
qu vide ou sous forme papier à partir du
9 juin prochain le pass sanitaire sera
déployée partout en france et contiendra
toute une série d'informations
la preuve d'un test pcr ou antigénique
négatif ou un certificat de
rétablissement du coc vie 19 ou alors la
preuve de votre vaccination
il sera obligatoire dans des lieux qui
accueilleront plus de 1000 personnes
installées de manière statique comme les
stades les théâtres où les concerts dans
les espaces où le public circule il ne
sera en revanche pas demander comme la
tour eiffel ou le château de versailles
pour vérifier les organisateurs
d'événements devront télécharger
l'application tout senti qu vite vérif
qui permettra de scanner votre qr code
ils n'auront alors accès qu'à quelques
informations votre nom prénom date de
naissance ils verront ensuite apparaître
là
couleur verte rouge pour valider ou non
l'accès le 20 mai dernier les sénateurs
réunis en commission mixte paritaire ont
adopté certaines limites à ce pas
sanitaires seules des personnes
habilitées pour le contrôler les
organisateurs ne pourront pas conserver
les données et en aucun cas il ne
pourrait être la condition d'entrer dans
un lieu privé la fin de l'utilisation du
passani terre est fixée au 30 septembre
prochain est avec nous pour débattre
autour de 7 passes sanitaire loïc hervé
bonjour vous êtes un sénateur centriste
de la haute savoie vous êtes plutôt
inquiet vous pointez du doigt les
risques de surveillance de masse autour
du pass sanitaires et puis avec nous
claude malhuret
bonjour président du groupe les
indépendances nateur de l'allier et
médecins elle rencontra vous avez
demandé d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
au gouvernement d'aller au plus vite de
mettre en place le pass sanitaire au
plus vite
on va parler de tout cela avec vous loïc
hervé le passé ni terre on l'a entendu
dans le sujet ce n'est pas ça un pass
vaccinale on peut simplement avoir un
test négatif la preuve qu'on a des
anticorps après avoir été infectés
est-ce que c'est pourquoi ça ne suffit
pas à vous rassurer parce que c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de notre
pays que nous allons mettre en place
pour des actes de la vie courante certes
de gros rassemblements dans un premier
temps mais un contrôle qui corrèle rats
l'état de santé est un docu et le
contrôle des documents d'identité ça
n'existe pas et c'est pour moi quelque
chose qui est attentatoire aux libertés
publiques et qui représente en lui-même
un risque de généralisation
le jour où un variant un mutant
nécessitera qu'on leur confie pas le
pays que écran 10
voilà ce pass sanitaires on le met en
place dans des actes de la vie encore
plus courantes comme à des jours encore
de 30 septembre
oui limitée au grand rassemblement mais
vous dites sait-on jamais s'il y avait
en moi je ne combat pas le pass vert
européen c'est à dire celui qui permet
de voyager des vols internationaux mais
sur le sur le territoire national je
pense qu'il ya un vrai risque à mettre
en place ce type d'outil parce que c'est
un précédent et qu'on ne l'a jamais fait
et que je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
nécessaire d'innover en la matière alors
il ya un certain nombre de garanties un
camp été adopté par le sénat conforme
aux exigences de la cnil où vous
j'ai d'ailleurs loïc hervé le pass ne
peut être mis en oeuvre que dans les
lieux ne permettant pas d'assurer le
respect des gestes barrières il peut
être présenté sous forme papier ou
numérique va y avoir des personnes
habilitées au contrôle les informations
et bien contenus seront restreintes à ne
pourront pas les personnes habilitées ne
pourront pas avoir toutes les
informations et pas de conservation des
données par les organisateurs
claude malhuret est ce que pour vous et
bien se passe du coup non avec toutes
ces précautions est suffisant et puis
quand même votre réponse à ce que dit
loïc hervé on dit pour l'instant ça
s'arrête le 30 septembre
mais ensuite qu'est ce qui pourrait se
passer je crois que la première réponse
que je voudrais faire à loïc hervé je
comprends c'est préoccupation mais la
première réponse est que ce pass
sanitaires il est facultatif
donc si vous voulez pas que au nom
d'autres le problème de la carte
d'identité je passais facultatif
si vous voulez pas de passer bien vous
vous présenter lors des grands
rassemblements aux frontières avec un
certificat de vaccination gens comme
vous faites pour la pour la fièvre jaune
quand vous allez en afrique ou autre
donc le premier point je comprends son
argent si c'était obligatoire ça
poserait un problème mais on peut
présenter l'un des trois documents à la
donc ce n'est pas obligatoire
deuxièmement la carte d'identité
c'est peut-être un précédent en matière
sanitaire
mais la carte d'identité vous la
présenter tous les jours quand vous avez
moins de 25 ans au cinéma et que vous
voulez une réduction vous présentez
votre carry entier quand vous allez chez
carrefour évoluer la carte du magasin
que la caissière vous pour vos cartes de
réduction elle vous fait remplir avec la
carte d'identité
quand vous prenez le train le billet de
train si vous le prenez pas sûr sur
internet si vous prenez audition ou
demande de tiens donc lagarde est une
matière on nous demande souvent c'est
pas quelque chose de donc sur sur ce
point je pense que ce n'est pas un
problème majeur est que le précédent
n'est pas majeur loin de là ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que y'a que deux
situations aujourd'hui où on va vous
demander parce sanitaires c'est le
franchissement des frontières et ça de
toute façon on sait déjà qu'à vous
passez pas une frontière sans 500 là
sans l'eau de l'humaniser et les grands
rassemblements de plus de 1000
probablement à partir d'une option de
5000 perçoit c'est-à-dire festival
culturel ou match de foot franchement
comme acteur doit alors que ça va nous
permettre évidemment de retrouver toutes
les libertés qu'on avait supprimé de
retrouver les matchs de foot retrouver
leur dit sans le pass annie terre ça
n'existerait pas ce type de grands
événements ont fait pas le pass
sanitaires ont vérifié on rouvre tous là
j'en dit on
on va pas prendre la précaution de ne
pas recevoir des gens de vérifier si les
gens sont pas contagieux ou non qu'est
ce qu'on fait on trouvera tous les
stades et on se retrouve dans la
situation du deuxième confinement ou du
premier coin de mots c'est à dire qu'on
est obligé de du point de vue du jem
déconfinement on est obligé de
recombiner ou bien on les laisse faire
mais oui oui le mode majorité atteinte
aux libertés
c'est bien entendu tout le tous les
acteurs de la culture tous les sportifs
tout le monde le dit aujourd'hui mais
quand est ce qu'on va rouvrir bain dans
ces circonstances là qu'ils ont quand
même un très très peu fréquentes dans la
vie quotidienne
je pense que le gain en matière de
liberté est supérieur aux problèmes que
ça vous l'envoie en matière de liberté
liée à notre sujet aussi loïc hervé
c'est le fait que ces données sont
enregistrées numériquement disponible
dans nos smartphone est ce que ça pour
vous c'est un sujet d'inquiétude
voici vous savez vous l'avez rappelé que
je siège à la commission nationale
informatique et libertés cnil et que une
de nos préoccupations qui est aussi une
préoccupation du législateur parce que
toutes les mesures prises par le sénat
et les garanties posées par le senasa
travail énorme de la commission des lois
que que je salue notre crainte c'est de
devoir se mettre en place une seule une
société du solutio nisme technologique
c'est à dire qu'on va trouver dans cet
appareil que nous avons tous sur nous
tout le temps bah la solution et on va
mettre pouvoir mettre un certain nombre
de données et rendre cet appareil
totalement indispensable il y a des
avantages à cela mais il ya aussi des
risques et donc il faut toujours avoir
une mesure entre les deux et bénéfice et
le risque comme mais comme pour les vins
avec claude mais l'ol sait pas c'est pas
un scoop on est assez proches sur un
plan politique
lui estime que c'est un autre monument
raisonnable que de mettre en place à
cesser ces outils-là mois des stocks
covit devenu tout syndicaux vide j'ai
dit que ça peut représenter pour moi des
risques importants et que ce que nous
mettons en place aujourd'hui quoi les
risques exactement concrètement pour
vous c'est le fait que c'est un peu
comme la dynamite le dynamite quand elle
est inventé elle sert à faire des choses
utiles et puis elle s'est inventé des
bombes et donc ce type de dispositif une
fois qu'il est créé une fois qu'il est
inventé
il peut être utilisé à d'autres fins et
demain d'autres crises sanitaires
politiques économiques justifieront
peut-être que nous disons mais on l'a
déjà fait et vous savez on est à un an
de l'élection présidentielle je voudrais
pas que d'une part les parties les plus
extrêmes y soient ceux qui proposent aux
français d'être affranchi des
contraintes d'élite des libertés
apparaissait que cela qui crée une fois
qu'ils auraient osant ont pris le
pouvoir
utiliserons tous deux le corpus
juridique que nous aurons nouveauté pour
mettre en place d'autres systèmes bien
plus attentatoire aux libertés publiques
claude malgré oui oui problème que celui
qui avait existé mais est il nous montre
son smartphone le problème et pas dans
le smartphone le problème est dans
l'exploitation des données est d'être
dans les fichiers or les fichiers ils
ont déjà des soucis de santé il a
déclaré vous avez deux fichiers depuis
vous en avez beaucoup d'autres jeunes
étant les 24 maladie à déclaration
obligatoire tout le monde personne ne
nuit rien ça fait un siècle que ça
existe et maintenant c'est sous
informatique bien entendu mais
aujourd'hui vous avez le fichier des
personnes atteintes du coït et vous avez
le fichier des personnes vaccinées quand
on vous donne un sens du but ce
certificat de vaccination avec un qr
code
donc ces deux fichiers ini ça nous
permet de les exploiter à titre
individuel pour faciliter nos
déplacements
mais à ce moment là il fallait critiquer
il fallait dire je veux pas les fichiers
mais s'il faudrait refuser tous les
fichiers sécurité sociale et nous avons
autorisé au sénat pour trois mois et qui
viennent d'être portées un délai de
vingt ans et en parlant de fichiers
d'ailleurs le groupe centriste va poser
une question là dessus il y à cette
question de certaines données collectées
par l'entreprise américaine
yg il ya dans des milliers de pharmacies
françaises sans que les clients en soit
informée il ya eu un reportage qui a
fait beaucoup de bruit est là dessus le
groupe centriste me posais une question
sur ce sujet donc on le voit ce problème
là il peut déjà exister par exemple à
travers les pharmacies mais il existe
c'est une question de du curseur comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure comme
comme le jury j'ai tout à l'heure c'est
il existe aujourd'hui partout dire l'air
gp délai qui a été inventé par l'europe
la rgpp dei s'attaque au problème majeur
est bien plus mature que celui-là de
google de facebook et sert à
l'exploitation de vos données donc on
sait qu'on est dans un monde aujourd'hui
où il faut réguler l'exploitation des
données
on l'a fait avec le rg on le fait
aujourd'hui avec la cnil qui a donné
l'accord pour le pass sanitaires et on
aura tout le temps désormais à se poser
la question la question éthique ou
est-ce qu'il faut mettre le curseur - en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est urgent sur le plan psychologique des
gens sur le bois santé sur le plan
économique de retrouver très rapidement
toutes les libertés qu'on attrape qu'on
a perdu à travers le coc vide et que par
conséquent les lélés les inquiétudes
qu'il peut y avoir sur sur ce sursaut
vaste sanitaires elles sont largement
inférieurs à tous les avantages qu'on va
pouvoir avoir dans une question urgente
qui est retrouvons notre vie retrouvons
notre croissante au développement
retrouvant nos libertés on est en tout
cas aujourd'hui dans un débat qui s'est
de plus en plus radicalisés autour de la
pandémie autour du port du masque autour
du pass and i ter loïc hervé votre
collègue vincent de l'est a assisté et
s'est exprimé lors d'une manifestation
anti masse quand ils passent sanitaires
ça fait tous l'objet d'une polémique ce
week end
écoutez ce qu'il disait d'ailleurs
samedi dernier lors de cette
manifestation la prorogation de données
bonjour sert depuis moi j'ai toujours
peur du provisoire qui dure bon vincent
delahaye qui expose son point de vue
sans excès on l'entend à la tribune mais
ce qui c'est qui était dans une
manifestation qui a aussi insulté les
ministres de la santé
une manifestation qui a fait des
rapprochements avec le nazisme
l'holocauste et qui a également insulté
des journalistes et depuis vincent de
l'est a fait acte de contrition ans dans
un tweet il a indiqué à l'invitation du
collectif d'artistes ami entends-tu je
suis intervenu lors d'un rassemblement
contre le pass sanitaire après mon
départ des propos inacceptables ont été
tenus je les condamne avec la plus
extrême fermeté
rien de ce qui a été dit ne me ressemble
je précise que nous avions proposé
d'ailleurs à vincent de l'est de réagir
un mot quand même déjà sur cet événement
qui réunit enfin je veux dire
le tweet de vincent de l'est exprime
clairement sa position il n'est pas
responsable des propos de jean-marie
bigard et de je ne sais quel allumés qui
soit qui sont intervenus après lui il
est allé dans ce rassemblement il a
répondu une invitation qu'il s'est
exprimé d'autres sont exprimés avec des
propos qu'ils ne sont pas acceptables si
on est inqualifiable qui ont même
peut-être qualifiable sur un plan pénal
mais vincent dallet n'est pas
responsable des délires de monsieur
bigard et donc voilà il a fait son tweet
le tweet est très clair je les ai pu
échanger avec lui
très récemment et donc mais pour moi ce
affaire est classée en dehors du cas de
vincent de lait ça montre aussi et bien
aujourd'hui la radicalité indue du débat
dans ce contexte le fait que aujourd'hui
bien sûr on peut être contre le pass
annie terre sans être complotistes mais
le problème c'est qu'on est vite
assimilé et qui a en tout cas toute une
frange très très radicale de personnes
qui sont contre le masque de vaccins le
comme vous avez aujourd'hui mais comme
vous avez une radicalisation aussi des
personnes qui tenant d'un juge
10 maps ollu vous explique qu' il faudra
comporte encore pendants sentant le mas
partout moi je suis très très surpris
par exemple sur une des choses
qu'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on n'aborde pas
la question du port du masque dans la
rue oui donc tout le monde imagine
extérieur bah oui en tout le monde dit
que sur un plan scientifique
ça n'est pas la mesure qui permet
vraiment d'endiguer ou l'épidémie sauf
dans des lieux où la distanciation
social ne peut pas être tenu mais
franchement diallo moi j'ai publié
dimanche
je suis allé au marché à annecy dans mon
département j'ai publié une photo
tout le monde est masquée oui tout le
monde est masqué la police municipale
est présente
il ya des élus qui sont présents on est
là on voit ce qui se passe concrètement
les gens respectent très bien les règles
eh bien vous avez des sur les réseaux
sociaux des délires de gens qui explique
qu'on est trop près qu'on est trop
proche qu'il y aura un troisième et 3 4e
confinement et a donc vraiment vous
parler de ce qu'est la légalisation des
deux côtés vous le savez un modéré
émoussé attend l'union centriste ce qui
m'importe c'est trouver une voie médiane
une voix de raison et qu'on remette de
la rationalité là dedans parce que si
c'est pour écouter tous ceux qui ont des
des propos complotistes de part et
d'autre ça m'intéresse pas claude
malhuret
vous vous êtes indigne à la semaine
dernière contre ce que vous avez appelé
les offusqués professionnel vous parlez
bien dd désigné nist excessifs certains
font leur beurre dans leurs crises
sanitaires des deux côtés pour vous oui
et puis font leur beurre politique
parce que quand loïc 10 c sur les
réseaux sociaux ça c'est essentiellement
sur les réseaux antisociaux
effectivement est là après tout qui
délire entre eux que les complotistes d
entre eux c'est pas nouveau et ça
continuera
mais il ya quand même des responsables
politiques que regarder de plus qui est
qui
cette vaccination depuis la fin de
l'année dernière vous avez des
responsables politiques d'extrême droite
d'extrême gauche et des dupont aignan
des bardes et là des mélenchon qui
pendant trois mois nous ont dit oh lola
le vaccin ça me rassure pas enfin je
suis pas les mots exacts c'était il y en
a quatre et et dupont aignan à traiter
les français de souris de laboratoire si
on allait se faire vacciner ce qui a
forcé le gouvernement à prendre beaucoup
de précautions et à retarder la
vaccination affaire qu'elle allait moins
vite et ça c'est grave
et puis maintenant il attaque le
gouvernement en disant ça va pas sa vie
on met des bâtons dans les roues de la
charrette pour se plaindre après que la
charrette n'avance plus et ça c'est
assez des gens qui font leur beurre
politique et il faut les dénoncer ces
gens là seront candidats à la présidence
de la république
et voilà le genre d'argument qu'ils
emploient je crois que oui moi je suis
là pour les déranger
pour conclure je voudrais puisque vous
parlez aussi de la question des vaccins
est votre avis sur ce que recommande
l'académie de médecine ce matin loïc
hervé recommande désormais la
vaccination obligatoire pour de
nombreuses professions et la vaccination
des enfants et des adolescents seul
moyen selon elles d'atteindre je la cite
une immunité collective suffisante pour
contrôler l'épidémie qu'en pensez vous
alors moi qu'on soit clair je suis pro
vaccination j'ai reçu ma première dose
ya quelques jours maintenant et je suis
un favorable et j'encourage tous ceux
qui le peuvent qui le veulent à être
vaccinés le plus tôt possible
ce sera le mieux et plus on atteindra
vite la limite et collectives mieux ce
sera j'ai je suis préoccupé par la ville
de l'académie nationale de médecine
parce que elle arrive dans un timing
politique suite à houla quelques jours à
quelques heures de l'adoption définitive
par le parlement
de la loi de prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est que comme par
hasard on est presque déjà dans l'étape
d'après dont j'aimerais que le
gouvernement s'explique en disant parce
qu'après le morbihan n'a jamais parlé il
a toujours dit qu'il n'y aurait ni
vaccination obligatoire ni contrepartie
à la vaccination
donc il faut que le gouvernement
s'explique si jamais il changé d'avis et
qu'il souhaitait désormais la
vaccination si c'est le cas vous y
seriez opposé use his wife a vraiment je
suis peu je je je crois énormément ont
la responsabilité individuelle et donc
les systèmes de vaccination obligatoire
s'ils ne sont pas accompagnés de de
coercition ça ne veut strictement rien
dire en gros ça veut dire quoi dans la
vaccination obligatoire
là ça aujourd'hui dans la vie courante
sauf si vous faites mais une main métier
comme militaire là la seule seulement au
contrôle de votre carnet de vaccination
ce à quoi vous pour vous inscrire à
l'école
donc c'est pas le quotidien des français
claude malhuret le mot de la fin là
dessus oui c'est un ado question la
première c'est que décidé avec simply
gator quand ya pas encore de doses de
vaccins pour tout le monde
c'est le bon moment sa sortie sinon
c'est une vraie question
là je réponds en tant que médecin la
vaccination enfin pour l'hépatite b pour
les personnels de santé est obligatoire
et par conséquent c'est qu'a eue c'est
une vraie question
j'ai pas de réponse je sais pas si il
est vrai qu'on est dans un temps où tout
ce qui est obligatoire et est
immédiatement contesté et c'est
peut-être pas la bonne mais je pense que
l'académie de médecine pose une vraie
question est ce que dans certaines
professions pour leur propre protection
et pour surtout pour la protection de
ceux dont il s'occupe mais la question
se pose je vais pas dg pas de réponse
mais c'est pas une question scandaleuse
elle et merci messieurs rester avec nous
on va tout de suite rejoindre la salle
des conférences se trouve alexandre
poussin avec le sénateur communiste
fabien gay pourparlers mis un petit peu
de l'offensive médiatique des manuels
macron cette semaine et notamment d'un
entretien dans la revue zadig qui a été
publié aujourd'hui witam on va parler de
cette très longue interview à plus de 20
pages qu'a donnée le président de la
république emmanuel macron trimestriel à
zadig pour parler notamment des
territoires ddt et gilet jaune de la
mémoire de la colonisation pour parler
des territoires et notamment d'un
département la seine saint denis
emmanuel macron qui fait une sorte de
déclaration d'amour à votre département
fabien gay est la seine-saint-denis il
dit un département plein de talent c'est
celui qu'il crée le plus de start up en
france qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
mots du président la république
c'est une très belle déclaration d'amour
mais maintenant il faut des preuves
d'amour et c'est à dire que la seine
saint denis elle recèle de talents plus
grand département avec une jeunesse
extrêmement forte
un département où on crée beaucoup de
solidarité beaucoup d'associations
beaucoup aussi de start-up un
département qui a lourdement contribué
lors du premier confinement à tenir le
pays et la nation avec ce qu'on a appelé
celles et ceux qui sont en première
ligne les essentiels de la nation sous
qui ont été au travail que ça soit les
caissières les caissiers les livreurs et
les livreuse ou dans le personnel
hospitalier mais c'est aussi un
département qui souffrent d'inégalités
puissante élan longtemps pas le
président de la république il ya un
rapport parlementaire qui a porté que
sur les services publics essentiels
police justice éducation nous étions
moins bien doté que les départements
franciliens les autres départements que
nous souffrions notamment sur la
question de l'école il ya eu l'échec
scolaire mais pourquoi parce qu'il ya
des graves inégalités et donc ce que
nous demande plus qu'une déclaration
d'amour c'est maintenant des moyens non
pas pour avoir plus que les autres
départements
mais pour être à égalité avoir les mêmes
moyens pour avoir les mêmes chances de
réussite et vous verrez la seine saint
denis elle sera comme les autres elle
recèlera talents qui pourront s'exprimer
mais ça il faut des politiques publiques
qui les met est pour l'instant l'état
n'est pas au rendez vous vous parlez de
la question de l'école justement dans
cette interview emmanuel macron dit
pendant la crise sanitaire vient du
premier confinement c'est en me
déplaçant en seine saint denis que j'ai
là pour noble chez mon ami j'ai le pix
voilà que président a compris
l'importance de laisser les écoles
ouvertes pendant la crise sanitaire
c'est une prise de conscience sociale
importante de la part du président
pendant cette crise
ben je crois pas parce qu'il n'a pas il
n'a pas encore donné les moyens la
seine-saint-denis de réussir et jupe ou
que savaient les autres élus du
département qui sont communistes ou
d'ailleurs disait il faut ré ouvrir les
écoles parce que c'est vecteur d'égalité
républicaine souvent le seul repas
équilibré de la journée notamment dans
les familles populaires selon repas pris
à l'école donc c'est extrêmement
important
c'est aussi un lieu de savoir et il est
extrêmement important sauf que la
seine-saint-denis encore une fois pâti
de graves inégalités
vous savez que un élève perd en moyenne
en seine saint denis un an sa scolarité
du fait du non remplacement des
professeurs absents un an
c'est insupportable et ça c'est vecteur
d'inégalités donc très bien belle
déclaration d'amour mais est ce que par
exemple on embauche du personnel
supplémentaire pour répondre je dirais à
l égalité républicaine est une éducation
qui doit être sur tous les territoires
en seine saint denis mais dans tous les
quartiers populaires dans les
territoires ruraux comme dans nos
territoires ultramarins une égalité
républicaine et que chacun où qu'il
habite aient les mêmes chances et les
mêmes chances de réussir merci beaucoup
fabien gay d'avoir répondu à mes
questions merci jérôme items c'est cette
question des territoires qui a un peut
monopoliser cet entretien du président
d'un public aux au magazine zadig merci
merci beaucoup alexandre une double
foncier va donc des mêmes
elle macron entre et bien ce grand
entretien de vingt pages dans la digue
est pas du tout le même format le
week-end dernier avec mc fly et carlito
pour une vidéo qui a fait le buzz
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire aujourd'hui est loïc hervé cette
façon cette offensive médiatique du
président de la république
écoutez je pense que dans une période de
la vie démocratique de notre pays dans
laquelle il faut quand même qu'on aille
chercher les gens qui sont aux franges
de cette vie démocratique précisément et
que notamment en direction des jeunes ne
savent où chaque pas à pas du tout pas
du tout après je trouve que j'ai pas
j'ai pas eu le temps de regarder
complètement l'émission mais je pense
que la question d'un rapport direct
notamment avait avec les jeunes via les
codes des restes des réseaux sociaux et
du tout me paraît pas pas pas idiot et
leurs réactions de mon fils de dix ans
démontre que c'est aussi une manière
pour le président de s'adresser à des
grands enfants à des adolescents et des
jeunes adultes et que ce faisant aux au
prix de ne pas mettre en cause
complètement la fonction présidentielle
je pense que c'est bien un bon geste en
un mot claude malhuret vous et que j'en
avais souvent après les réseaux anti
sociaux fait la même chose moi je je je
confesse je ne suis pas un spectateur
acharné de mcfly et carlito ni de zadig
je n'ai pas vu cette séquence parfois
c'est peut-être une question de
génération est plus proche de ces
générations s'y hisser sur les enfants
de 10 ans où les adolescents au moins on
peut pas lui reprocher la légère d'aller
faire de l'électoralisme plus qu'ils ne
votent pas voilà mes chronos
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat on va rejoindre une
dernière fois la salle à des conférences
alexandre vous êtes à présent avec le
sénateur les républicains du territoire
de belfort
cédric perrin également vice président
de la commission de la défense et des
affaires étrangères pour revenir et bien
sûr la biélorussie grands sujets de
préoccupation notamment pour l'union
européenne aujourd'hui et l'union
européenne qui a annoncé des sanctions
envers la biélorussie après le
détournement d'un avion ce week-end pour
et bien au final arrêtées un opposant
politique donc dans cette danse et
sanctions cédric terrain il ya surtout
eu le boycott de l'espace aérien
biélorusse et de la compagnie nationale
aérienne
le biélorusse est ce que ça suffit ce
type de sanction je ne sais pas si ça
suffira
mais en tout cas
ce qu'on peut prendre en considération
cette fête que l'union européenne très
rapidement réagi et se soient entendus
ce qui est relativement rare pour être
souligné et donc c'est important que
nous puissions aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
le dire après est-ce que ça suffira face
à un dictateur sanguinaire comme nouveau
single je ne suis pas sûr mais les
moyens dont nous disposons pour le
manceau cela et je pense que c'est
important que le métier les mettions en
oeuvre parce que c'est quand même un
acte de piraterie aérienne incroyable
environ n'a jamais on n'a jamais vu ça
ça met en cause quand même très
largement les traités que nous avons que
nous ayons mis en oeuvre post deuxième
guerre mondiale pour la libre
circulation dans les espaces aériens
si demain
ce type de deux fautes j'ai un
gravissime devait se reproduire ça
mettrait en cause une heure la
circulation et la libre circulation
aérienne sur la planète donc il ya
évidemment beaucoup de choses à retirer
de tout ça sans doute une grande
fébrilité du pouvoir du pouvoir
biélorusse
et puis et puis la question se pose
c'est quel est ce que le jeu en valait
la chandelle ce qu'il fallait prendre
autant de risques pour un opposant qui
n'est pas un opposant politique je le
rappelle sa journaliste et activiste
certes mais qui ne mettait que tout de
même pas en danger
là le pouvoir le pouvoir biélorusse
banks ya beaucoup d'interrogations
autour de tout ça et j'espère que les
sanctions seront de plus en plus
nombreuses pour faire en sorte de faire
comprendre à ceux à ceux à ce dictature
kelly bochenko de que c'est pas comme ça
que les choses fonctionnent mais je suis
relativement pessimiste et sur ces
sanctions en tout cas le président la
république à merrimack rond est
également pessimiste il dit au final
elles ne servent pas à grand chose et il
faudra qu'on change notre politique
vis-à-vis de la biélorussie mais surtout
de la russie qui est derrière moi je
suis je suis assez dubitatif sur la
question russe je crois qu'il faut aussi
raison garder et vis-à-vis de la russie
je crois qu'il faut arrêter en
permanence de repousser la russie dans
les bras des chinois comme on le fait
depuis maintenant cinq ans j'ai vu que
le président république avait changé
d'opinion sur le sujet que maintenant il
pensait effectivement qu'il fallait
essayer d'avoir un dialogue constructif
avec la russie on n'est pas naïfs avec
la russie en a parfaitement conscience
de ce qu'ils font de la manière de
paysagisme et je crois qu'il est
important pour la france notamment de
rester en tout cas à la table du
dialogue avec avec poutine c'est qu'on
veut c'est absolument pour moi
fondamental et le dialogue ça veut dire
éviter que de faire en sorte que l'on ne
précipite poutine dans les bras des
chinois je crois que on n'a pas besoin
de ça en ce moment il ya suffisamment de
difficultés
donc il faut aussi de ce point de vue là
à mon avis chalmé raison garder bien
qu'il faut apaiser nos relations avec la
russie ne faut pas montrer les muscles
façon qu'on montre les muscles à poutine
ou pas ça ne change pas fondamentalement
les choses l'objectif c'est d'essayer
d'arriver à discuter avec eux
essayez de petit à petit de dimanche à
un dialogue constructif mais l'avancé
sur assure tant le sujet est le cera le
fait la commission de la castre en gère
le fait d'ailleurs je sais que président
de la commission au sort la semaine
prochaine à sa hauteur d'eau pour
discuter ces points là c'est important
qu'il y ait du dialogue merci beaucoup
cédric perrin on va tout de suite allé
dans la tribune de presse de l'hémicycle
du sénat où des questions d'actualité
vont commencer steve tait les programmes
beaucoup de choses au programme on
parlera notamment et bien alex des
féminicides dans ce contexte du drame
dayan en moselle un seul chiffre il est
glaçant 43 43 comme le nombre de femmes
qui ont déjà été tués en france depuis
le début de l'année alors on s'en
rappelle le gouvernement avait fait de
la cause des femmes la grande cause du
quinquennat où en est on sur ce point là
comment est bien le gouvernement compte
s'y prendre pour mettre un coup d'arrêt
à ces faits min 6 sur ce point le
gouvernement va devoir répondre
il sera interpellé dans quelques
instants par les sénateurs et puis on
parlera aussi des suites de la sphère
sara lee mis cette affaire qui a suscité
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion en france
dans l'opinion publique puisque le
meurtrier de cette sexagénaire juive a
été considérée comme irresponsable
pénalement
emmanuel macron a promis une réforme du
code pénal peut être que jean castex va
nous donner quelques détails de cette
réforme la séance a débuté on se
retrouve juste après pour le débrief a
tout de suite
le procès verbal est adoptée sous les
réserves d'usagé
messieurs le premier ministre mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nombre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmis sur public
sénat et sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif à observer au cours
de nos échanges les valeurs essentielles
et c'est là le respect et le temps de
parole je donne la présente
immédiatement la parole à madame la
présidente eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes vous avez la parole de la
présidente monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues se teinter date qui devait en
révolutionner la politique s'abîme
semaine après semaine dans des débats
hystériser pour faire oublier le
fondement des injustices des riches
toujours plus riches et des pauvres
toujours plus pauvres alors qu'en dix
ans le patrimoine des milliardaires a
augmenté de 400 39% dans d'autres pays
à ce rythme le smic serait à environ
4805 euros par mois alors que le nombre
de pauvres explose
plus de 10 millions en france et que la
précarité fait des ravages en
particulier dans la jeunesse alors que
l'hôpital attend toujours son vaste plan
et que le pays de pasteur attend
toujours son vaccin
vous répondez depuis des mois par une
pirouette démagogique qui masque mal des
objectifs violemment anti sociaux depuis
des décennies le thème de la sécurité la
menace de l'immigration sont ajoutés en
permanence sont agités en permanence
pour écarter la population du vrai débat
qui décide de son destin collectif avec
quels moyens
monsieur le premier ministre après la
loi sur le séparatisme après la loi sur
la sécurité globale qui confondait le
respect du droit à vivre en sécurité et
la remise en cause systématique des
libertés publiques nous découvrons
chaque jour des projets de loi en
réaction à tel ou tel drame
ce dont vous ne parlez pas c'est la mise
en cause des chômeurs c'est la menace
persistante de la réforme des retraites
c'est la case continue du droit du
travail monsieur le premier ministre la
france est inquiète
non pas de l'autre du voisin de ceux qui
viennent mourir sur les plages d'europe
elle s'inquiète pour l'avenir que
certains de ces enfants de cette
profonde insécurité sociale car le
libéralisme détruit la solidarité
l'égalité
la crise a montré une chose la france et
l'europe sont riches et peuvent disposer
de moyens considérables pour agir
les centaines de milliards monsieur le
premier ministre vous disposez pour
faire face à cette crise fruit de
l'activité humaine cirque verront-ils au
statu quo au statu quo ou pire à achever
notre modèle social
où vont ils servir à re bâtir une
société plus juste et plus respectueuse
de l'environnement pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur le premier ministre
la parole monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
présidente à ça si je ne suis pas
certain d'avoir compris qu'il s'agissait
vraiment d'une question plutôt un
extrait de déclaration de politique
générale et globale
vous nous avez fait pas même la présence
j'ai bien compris de votre inquiétude
s'est dit la france est inquiète
bien sûr elle traverse comme vous le
savez pas quel une crise d'une ampleur
inédite extrêmement forte sanitaire
d'abord avec toutes les conséquences
économiques et sociales que subissent
effectivement nombre de nos concitoyens
ça c'est une réalité ce qu'il est aussi
chère madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est que nous
agissons le gouvernement de la
république
à j-2 azimuts pour faire face à cette
crise
et sans vouloir en quoi que ce soit
diminuer les difficultés du temps
présent de nos compatriotes et j'ai
souvent dit dans cette même enceinte la
grande humilité qui devait être
collectivement la nôtre je voudrais
quand même vous dire quelques éléments
en réponse à votre question
madame la présidente d'abord rappelé aux
sénatrice aux sénateurs que notre
situation sanitaire globale globalement
s'améliore je le dis parce que le
l'oublié pas vous le savez parfaitement
dans les motifs d'inquiétude de nos
concitoyens il ya d'abord ça je renvoie
pas tout ce qu'on nous a dit sur notre
stratégie l'évolution les oiseaux de
mauvaise augure
oui oui non nominé mieux ne vous sentez
pas visé je parle en général mes dames
et chez sa tante général voilà bon que
ce soit dit bien sûr jamais nous n'avons
fait dans cet hémicycle objets ou le
procès de mauvaise intention se présente
jamais bon enfin écoutez donc en étant
tombé à 11 mille cas par jour
vous le savez les services d'animation
de kort recharge et vous avez raison
main présentement fait on est tombé là
aussi à moins de 3500 patients
hospitalisés hier on tangente j'espère
qu'on va les dépasser ce soir les 24
millions de français ayant bénéficié
d'une première injection les variants
sont stabilisés ces dernières semaines
bref grâce à noah fort effort collectif
et on va tout s'en réjouir
la situation sanitaire s'améliore
surtout madame le pen au plan économique
et social puisque j'ai bien compris que
c'était votre question mais vous savez
bien que la situation économique et
sociale découlent en grande part de la
crise sanitaire
car au début de la crise sanitaire la
france ne se portait pas mal de points
de vue économique et social dans le
concert des nations les chiffres sont
clairs
d'abord je vous rappelle vous parliez
d'action vous dis l'europe a de l'argent
la france agit pour accompagner son
économie tout
les sénatrices et sénateurs ici
présentes quand ils vont au contact des
acteurs du pays qui ont été très touchés
par cette crise de commerçants acteurs
de la culture on va pas tous les citer
ils disent tous malgré tout la vérité ya
sûrement des imperfections mais grosso
modo l'état français ne nous a pas
laissé tomber il à assurer notre survie
en 2020 j'ai pas les chiffres de 2021
on est le pays d'europe où le pouvoir
d'achat plus 0,6 pour ça malgré
l'effondrement de l'économie
madame la présidente a été le mieux
préservé et si et si et la france la
france monsieur le président est
désormais le grand pays de la zone euro
qui a le moins perdu d'activité depuis
le début de la crise chiffres eurostat
est bonne de france nous avons
collectivement résister on peut dire
s'est passé on peut dire ya lieu de
continuer à être mobilisés de débrancher
comment va le faire très progressivement
nos dispositifs d'accompagnement de
relancer vigoureusement notre économie
c'est ce que nous faisons d'avoir une
attention de l'est pour les plus
précaires et pour les plus pauvres et là
aussi madame la présidente
les comparaisons sont extrêmement nette
est en faveur de notre pays et nous
devons en être collectivement fier et
vous le savez j'ajoute et je termine par
ça parce que la reprise c'est la
psychologie oui je m'excuse je fais une
réponse non pardon monsieur présent au
sénat
le sujet est très important oui vous
avez raison c'est le respect de la
présidente
les indicateurs dont nous disposons sur
le moral des français sur les intentions
d'investir de rebondir de repartir ces
indicateurs sont favorables nous devons
nous en réjouir il faut que nous
sachions gérer collectivement cette
transition entre la crise qui est
toujours là avec ses morsures et le de
redémarrage de notre pays et de notre
économie tout le gouvernement
tout le gouvernement est mobilisé à
cette tâche merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue andré gattolin
pour le groupe du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
vous avez la parole
oui merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur jean yves
le drian ministe de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères inimaginable
et pourtant il l'a fait non je ne parle
pas ici mes chers collègues d'un exploit
sportif ou d'un geste héroïque hors
norme
il ya malheureusement longtemps que le
das n'est plus l'apanage des seuls héros
non je parle ici de l'incroyable actes
de piraterie aérienne d'état a ordonné
dimanche dernier par monsieur lukashenko
l'inaltérable présidents autocrates du
bélarus en apprenant la nouvelle
j'ai un instant cru à un canular
aujourd'hui encore je me demande quel
degré de folie peut expliquer une telle
violation du droit international dans
l'unique but de procéder à l'arrestation
d'un jeune journaliste je ne suis
visiblement pas le seul à avoir été
sidérée si l'on juge monsieur le
ministre
pas la fermeté de votre réaction que je
souligne dès dimanche après midi
avant-hier des sanctions européennes
inédites ont été prises
face à cet acte d'une gravité encore
plus inédites
mais comme le reconnaissait hier le
président macron à l'issue du conseil
européen
je cite à politique des sanctions
progressives sur des situations gelé
n'est plus une politique efficace et de
s'interroger sur les limites actuelles
des sanctions sans tomber dans
l'engrenage d'un possible conflit armé
alors ma question monsieur le ministre
est donc simple sommes nous vraiment au
bout des sanctions applicables au
bélarus ne peut-on pas élargir les
sanctions ciblées à quelques centaines
voire milliers d'autres responsables
biélorusses
car nous le savons ce régime ne repose
plus que sur quelques 10000 cadre qui on
tire directement bénéfices par ailleurs
il faut absolument veiller à ce que cet
acte de piraterie nous fallait voie à
des actes similaires dans d'autres
espaces aériens sensible aussi je
voudrais savoir si la france est prête à
demander l'activation de l'article 88 de
la convention de chicago afin de
suspendre les droits du bélarus au sein
de l'assemblée de l'organisation de
l'aviation civile internationale je vous
remercie pour vos réponses la parole est
aux ministres que l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur le drian jeu à
paroles de monsieur le sénateur gattolin
mesdames les sénatrices et dessinateur
le gouvernement partage votre
indignation
c'est vrai c'est un acte de piraterie
d'état
c'est vrai que c'est une prise d'otage
par l'air et c'est vrai que les régimes
autoritaires et singulièrement celui de
monsieur loukachenko n'a plus non plus
aucune limite dans leur comportement des
stabilisateurs et et répressif et vous
avez souligné avec raison que le conseil
européen de lundi soir a réagi avec une
très grande fermeté une très grande
unité les mesures prises lundi soir sont
applicables dès aujourd'hui je passe à
particulier à mesures prises dans le
domaine aérien avec l'interdiction de
d'utiliser l'espace aérien européen et
de se poser dans les aéroports européens
pour toutes les compagnies de belarus je
pense aussi à l'interdiction pour les
compagnies européennes de survoler
bélarus et puis on me dit est ce qu'on
va aller plus loin oui on va aller plus
loin puisque dans les décisions du
conseil de lundi soir il a été demandé à
la commission de préparer une panoplie
de sanctions supplémentaires
supplémentaires par rapport aux 88
sanctions déjà prises au moment des
élections truquées 2 août dernier je me
suis entretenu à ce sujet avec madame
chicanos callas avant-hier soir nous
allons prendre des mesures des sanctions
supplémentaires non seulement sur des
personnes il ya déjà le cas de monsieur
loukachenko lui-même de sa famille
s'étaient déjà faits nous allons
largement ouvrir l'ensemble des
sanctions et y compris avec des
sanctions envers les entités étatiques
proches du pouvoir pour les empêcher de
bouger en europe de venir en europe de
commercer avec l'europe
il faut s'appuyer sur la force que
représente le 450 millions deux du
marché intérieur européen pour agir
et puis vous me proposez de réunir le
l'organisation pour l'aviation civile
internationale se sera fait demain
puisque la réunion aura lieu à montréal
et que nous serons amenés avec d'autres
européens à faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une enquête de cette organisation sur la
manière dont tout cela s'est déroulé
plus j'espère qu'elle sera autorisée
mais en tout cas soyez sûr nous serons
très fermes par rapport à l'eau chaude
le cash and co et en aucun cas ne
reconnaîtront ni son des rythmes
élections irrégulières ni sa politique
aveugle de répression merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est heureux
collègue david assouline pour le groupe
socialiste écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur vous êtes aussi
le ministe de l'organisation des
élections donc de leur bon déroulement
démocratique et de leur impartialité
pensez vous que votre annonce de
poursuites pénales contre une candidate
à une élection qui avait simplement émis
une opinion sur votre action soit
compatible avec vos fonctions
confirmez-vous cette annonce pour vous
répondre la parole et à ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur norman vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président la
question du sénateur à 6 me permets de
redire ici puisque vous n'avez pas fait
monsieur le sénateur tout le soutien que
j'ai pour la police républicaine pour la
gendarmerie est ma grande fierté d'être
à la tête de ce ministère où
malheureusement la police de la
république a été endeuillée par deux
fois dans deux assassinats
particulièrement ignoble et il me semble
qu'à chaque fois chaque moment tout
républicain et tout démocrate qui aiment
la république la démocratie se plairait
à le rappeler je voudrais leur dire à
quel point je trouvais très particulier
des propos de certaines personnes dont
madame pulvar j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
le dire et je le redis notamment vers la
police de la république j'ai proposé à
madame pulvar après avoir vu qu'elle
avait effectivement corrigé une partie
de ses propos sur la chaîne lci de la
rencontre et je lui proposais de rendez
vous pour la semaine prochaine j'espère
qu'elle pourra se rendre disponible si
j'en proposerai d'autres davantage et je
serai très heureux d'échanger avec elle
pour redire à quel point publiquement
oui la police est belle oui la prise de
la république est forte
et oui tout le monde devrait la soutenir
sans réserve seul sénateur
je vous ai écouté avec attention mais
sur le fond vous n'avez pas répondu à ma
question
oui nous devons protéger avec force les
policiers qui nous protège nous devons
les protéger
nous l'avons dit nous le pensons et nous
avons même agi pour cela quand nous
étions au pouvoir
je vous ai demandé solennellement de
nous dire ce qui vous a autorisé à
tenter d'intimider une candidate vous
qui au contraire avait la charge de
protéger la parole libre et démocratique
de madame pulvar comme de toutes celles
et de tous ceux qui concourent aux
élections pourquoi avoir créé une
polémique de plus alors que votre rôle
est de garantir le débat apaisé dans
notre démocratie a besoin plus que
jamais
pourquoi dans ce moment de monter de
toutes les violences et tensions
préférez-vous créer de l'agitation et du
désordre par des opérations de
communication et de saturation
médiatique alors que les citoyens
attendent de vous de l'action efficace
de la stabilité de la cohésion
ce que nous demandons nous
parlementaires c'est que vous commenciez
vous pas respecté notre état de droit et
la séparation des pouvoirs exécutif
législatif et judiciaire mais aussi la
sérénité que votre fonction exil pour
protéger nos concitoyens
je vais donner la parole notre contrat
la ganterie guillaume pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole merci président
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre intérieur gérald
darmanin
dans un tout autre registre comme chaque
année dans le var al'approche de la
saison estivale la même question revient
y aura-t-il un dragon 83 affecté à notre
département cette année
il s'agit de détacher un hélicoptère de
la sécurité civile sur la base du luc en
provence
il semblerait que cette année en plus du
manque global d'appareils de ce type se
pose le problème de leur maintenance et
de la disponibilité de leurs équipages
d'où l'angoissé des varoises et varois
mais aussi celle des habitants du
département de la gironde qui voit le
dragon 33 surchargé par le non
déploiement de l'hélicoptère de la
gendarmerie
la question sera donc monsieur le
ministre quelles décisions comptez vous
prendre pour mieux préparer la saison
2021 termes de moyens aériens en général
jeudi un général plein car ma question
cache un besoin bien plus vaste qui
relève de l'insuffisance du nombre
d'appareils volants destinés à la lutte
contre les incendies de forêts je veux
parler du manque d'avions bombardiers
d'eau amphibie alias les fameux canadair
capable dé copé en mer ou sur tout autre
étendue d'eau ces appareils sont d'une
grande efficacité en tout cas
complémentaire aux avions qui devront
qui doivent atterrir pour faire le plein
à chaque langage ils sont aussi d'un
appui indispensable à l'action que mène
aux cff et à l'accès engagement
courageux que livrent nos sapeurs
pompiers sur le terrain chacun est
confronté à des chaleurs caniculaires
les forêts du sud de la france mais
aussi celle du portugal de l'espagne et
tout récemment de la grèce et j'en
oublie flambe occasionnant des dégâts
irréversibles sur l'environnement sur la
biodiversité et sur le dérèglement
climatique
aussi lors de la prochaine proposition
de loi sur la sécurité intérieure dite
loi matras et dans le cadre du plan de
relance ne pourrait-on pas envisager une
véritable stratégie d'acquisition ou de
fabrication de ce type d'appareils à
l'échelle européenne
la période est opportune pour que non
l'industrie que l'on puisse relocaliser
pour l'emploi en général et enfin pour
mieux protéger nos concitoyens et notre
patrimoine naturel je vous remercie pour
vous répondre
la parole au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur madame merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur merci de
votre question qui me permet à quelques
jours du début de la saison des feux
comme on le dit malheureusement de
redire à quel point nos sapeurs pompiers
qu'ils soient professionnels ou
volontaires tous ceux qui concourent à
la sécurité civile notre pays sont
indispensables sont courageux et mérite
d'être soutenue je sais que c'est votre
cas d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans quelques
heures j'aurai l'honneur de pouvoir
représenter le gouvernement lors de
l'étude à la semaine nationale qui
viendra bientôt au sénat de la
proposition de loi de monsieur matra qui
va renforcer de manière considérable le
système de volontariat de sécurité
civile de notre pays vous évoquez plus
précisément la question du matériel
depuis sept huit ans on est passé de 38
hélicoptères que l'on appelle dragon à
34 parce qu'il ya eu des accidents parce
que des défauts matériel et cela
handicape beaucoup notre système de
sécurité civile ils ont été
particulièrement sollicités vous le
savez dans vos territoires mais de plus
en plus au nord de la loire aussi c'est
aussi le le cas du réchauffement
climatique qui impacte évidemment les
feux de forêt et nous avons constaté par
ailleurs que ces 34 hélicoptères dragon
ont été particulièrement mobilisé plus
de 600 interventions sanitaires pour la
solide 19 grâce à la demande du premier
ministre et du plan de relance deux
hélicoptères supplémentaires ont été
achetés donc mon ton notre flotte ainsi
à 36 et nous avons proposé avec le
premier ministre que puisse monter à 2
supplémentaires d'ici 2023 afin de
revenir à l'étiage qui sont des 38
hélicoptères qui nous permette
effectivement d'intervenir dans des
conditions de sécurisation des
populations
par ailleurs il ya les avions
bombardiers d'eau dont vous savez que
nous renouvelons la flotte
c'était le cas lorsque j'étais au
mystère des comptes publics nous avons
engagé avec gérard collomb des moyens
supplémentaires pour pouvoir refuserait
salue avec une bourreau qui s'est occupé
de ce sujet évidemment précédemment des
moyens supplémentaires et comme vous le
dites
aujourd'hui la commission européenne
nous aident fortement puisque 90% des
financements de ces avions sont faits
par la commission européenne
la france vous le savez portera des
demandes d'avions supplémentaires pour
aider nos pompiers et pour aider tous
les territoires
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue joël labbé pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoires vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresser au ministre de
l'agriculture que je regrette qu'il ne
soit pas là mais chacun a ses
obligations et ses activités il vient de
nous présenter la semaine dernière le
maire agriculture son plan stratégique
national en vue de la pac 2023 2027
j'aurais voulu dire ont voulu lui dire
en direct notre immense déception à la
lecture de ces orientations
malgré un débat public sur l'impact qui
a clairement montré les attentes en
matière de transition agricoles et
alimentaires malgré les alertes fait
part des organisations agricoles et
environnementales dont pourri notre pack
relayée par des parlementaires
malgré l'ensemble des signaux pointent
dans l'urgence écologique
le ministre a choisi d'opter pour une
pac du quasi statu quo pour une pac qui
fige à la fois les inégalités existantes
est un modèle dont on sait aujourd'hui
pertinemment qu'il n'est ni durable ni
créateurs d'emplois ni rémunérateur ni
conforme aux attentes des citoyens
ainsi la transition agro écologiques ne
bénéficiera d'aucun moyen supplémentaire
pourtant monsieur le premier ministre le
l'organisme france stratégie chargé de
conseiller le premier ministre avait
dans son rapport faire de la pac à
levier de la transition ego
agroécologiques avait conclu que
l'agriculture biologique était la plus
performante en termes tant économique
qu'environnemental
alors à présent à supprimer le
financement national de l'aide au
maintien
vous avez donc décidé de baisser on a
vérifié les chiffres de 66% les aides
pac pour le maintien en bio et de les
aligner sur la h20 eux qui est un
système inopérantes
alors monsieur le ministre le gouvernent
comment va-t-il revoir sa copie et
proposer un plan stratégique national à
la hauteur des enjeux
pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre porte-parole du gouvernement
monsieur attal vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur joël labbé joue pris d'abord de
bien vouloir excuser l'absence de mon
collègue julien de normandie qui est
actuellement à bruxelles pour le conseil
européen
il aurait aimé à monsieur le sénateur
pouvoir tordre le cou à une rumeur un
bruit qui circule depuis quelques jours
non le soutien à l'agriculture
biologique ne diminue pas au contraire
les aides augmentent et elles augmentent
fort ainsi nous allons passer de 250
millions d'euros de soutien à
l'agriculture biologique à 340 millions
par an soit une hausse de 30% dans votre
département
le morbihan ce sont 2 9 millions d'euros
d' aides à l'agriculture bio qui a été
attribué en 2019
avec la hausse des moyens le morbihan
pourrait bénéficier par exemple d'un
million d'euros en plus par an c'est une
hausse forte c'est un investissement
majeur et c'est un investissement à la
hauteur de notre objectif qui est de
doubler les surfaces d'agriculture bio
d'ici à 2027
oui monsieur le sénateur nous assumons
totalement de vouloir faire du bio une
filière agricole française d'excellence
avec toujours plus d'agriculteurs qui
s'y consacrent ne voyons pas les choses
en petit en nous focalisant sur les
seules aides au maintien et lyon au
contraire une logique conquérante pour
le bio en favorisant les aides à la
conversion
n'ayons pas peur d'être ambitieux pour
les 400 mille agriculteurs français
n'ayons pas peur d'accompagner d'inciter
et de convaincre des bienfaits de l'agro
écologie c'est le sens même de
l'investissement de 1,2 milliard d'euros
pour la transition agricole dans le plan
de relance
notre conviction est intacte nous
préférons embarqué plutôt qu'imposer
nous préférons réussir plutôt que brille
mais nous construisons la transition
agricole avec les agriculteurs nous
menons de front la bataille du bio avec
eux et avec des moyens exceptionnels
pour reprendre vos mots dans un
quotidien il
nous forgeons une agriculture
respectueuse des hommes des animaux et
de la terre et nous faisons avec les
agriculteurs et pas contre eux merci
dans la parole notre collègue denis n'a
pas ou dégageait pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'économie
sociale solidaire et responsable
récemment vous le savez innotech
informatique à paralyser un oléoduc
majeur de la côte est des états unis les
infrastructures d'énergie sont des
cibles privilégiées des cyberattaques au
regard des graves effets que cous leur
mise à la reine afin de moderniser ses
infrastructures
le président va y donne a annoncé un
plan de deux milliards de dollars 20
milliards de dollars seront dédiés à la
cyber modernisation des réseaux
électriques et un nouveau crédit d'impôt
financera les cyber technologies dédiées
à ces réseaux la france n'est
malheureusement pas à l'abri de ces
menaces qui prolifèrent tous azimuts
après les scandales cambridge analytica
visant à influencer le référendum sur le
bric site l'élection donald trump notre
pays a été le théâtre de manoeuvres de
déstabilisation
lors des dernières élections
présidentielles ces actions perturbe
notre vie démocratique
notre vie sociale et économique des
hôpitaux ainsi que des médias français
ont subi des cyberattaques plusieurs en
ont été réduits à revenir au mode papier
stylo dans le même objectif de
déstabilisation certains influenceurs
ont récemment été approché afin de
participer à une campagne de
désinformation sur le vaccin pfizer les
commanditaires probable blanc russes
cherchent à perturber la vaccination est
donc la reprise de l'activité dans notre
pays en utilisant la défiance à l'égard
des scientifiques pour faire face à ces
attaques la france n'est pas démuni
landecy veiller à la sécurité des
systèmes d'information notamment à celle
des opérateurs d'importance vitale et
notre pays s'est doté depuis 2010 est
d'un commandement de la cyberdéfense
néanmoins restant lucide le nombre de
cyber attaques visant notre pays a été
multiplié par quatre
un an entre 2019 et 2020 dans un
contexte international troublé notamment
aux frontières de l'union
al'approche des élections de 2022 la
france est elle prête
madame la ministre à faire face à
l'intensification de ces attaques
quelles mesures sont prises notamment en
matière de recherche et de formation
pour renforcer la résilience de notre
pays aux cyberattaques suivre merci pour
vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'économie sociale solidaire
responsables aimeraient y voir vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice paoli gajan vous l'avez très
clairement souligné la france n'est pas
à l'abri des cyber menaces et
aujourd'hui le cyberespace est un espace
de conflictuelle it est de plus en plus
important dans lequel les menaces
augmentent effectivement chaque jour
entre 2019 et 2020 le nombre de victimes
de cyberattaque a été multiplié par
quatre selon lan si je crois que le
chiffre parle de lui même si la
sécurisation des systèmes d'information
doit être évidemment une priorité toutes
les organisations doivent aussi intégrer
la possibilité de subir une chimère
attaque et donc se mettre en capacité
d'être en mesure d'y répondre c'est la
définition même de la résilience dans le
cyberespace
cette nécessité est totalement identifié
dans le cadre de la stratégie
d'accélération cyber qui a été annoncée
le 18 février dernier par le président
de la république est financé à hauteur
de 1,4 milliard d'euros
cette stratégie s'articule très
clairement selon six axes qui sont
chacun déployés par le secrétaire d'état
cdh rico qui en a la charge le
développement de solutions souveraine et
innovante de cyber sécurité mais aussi
le renforcement des liens et des
synergies entre les acteurs de la
filière le soutien à la demande le
renforcement de l'offre de formation des
jeunes et des professionnels à ces
métiers émergent de la cybersécurité
le soutien en fonds propre développement
des entreprises de la filière un effort
spécifique porté à la cyber sécurisation
des établissements de santé
plusieurs actions concrètes madame la
sénatrice ont déjà été mises en oeuvre
premièrement sans attendre cette
augmentation des cyber attaques nous
avons en permanence augmenter les moyens
humains de là
si depuis 2010 est un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt a par ailleurs
été lancés en direction des
collectivités des établissements de
santé et des ports afin de mettre en
place des démonstrateurs de cyber
sécurité qui soit adaptée aux besoins de
ces structures spécifiques et enfin
l'ansi a commencé à mettre en oeuvre un
plan de sécurisation des administrations
et a bénéficié pour cela de 136 millions
d'euros dans le cadre de la stratégie
d'accélération cyber enfin je termine
l'ouverture du campus cyber à partir de
2021 pour qu'on me tue les mutualistes
tout ce qui peut l'être en la matière
votre question se pose le gouvernement
en est conscient
le plan se déroule et nous sommes très
attentifs à ce sujet des cyber attaques
je vous remercie shory pour le groupe
l'est républicain
j'avais la parole monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur un jeune homme de 20 ans
mort un enfant de 5 ans grièvement
blessé alors qu'il traversait à vélo sur
un passage protégé et plus récemment à
lyon une femme fauchée par deux jeunes à
scooter
pas une semaine ne passe sans que les
agissements aux conséquences parfois
tragiques des hauteurs de rodéo
motorisés ne fasse la une des médias les
victimes se multiplient les nuisances
pour les riverains s'accumulent et
instaure un climat de violence malgré la
loi du 3 août 2010 8 qui fait de cette
pratique un délit puni d'une peine
d'emprisonnement d'emprisonnement allant
de 1 à 5 ans le phénomène perdure et
s'amplifie en cause une application qui
se heurte à plusieurs limites
d'abord les directives données aux
policiers la consigne et ne pas aller au
contact des contrevenants par peur de
provoquer des accidents ou bien encore
des émeutes urbaines l'affichage de
fermeté du gouvernement se confrontent
ici à la réalité des faits si l'on
comprend bien les difficultés que
représente ce type d'intervention cela
n'en demeure pas moins un redoutable
aveu d'impuissance
conséquence majeure est regrettable le
sentiment que certains individus ne sont
pas tenus de respecter les lois de la
république
ensuite le type de sanctions appliquées
la confiscation des véhicules incarne
aujourd'hui la mesure la plus efficace
pour lutter contre cette pratique
dangereuse
pourtant sa mise en oeuvre n'est pas
systématique et semble même marginale
cela pose de sérieuses questions quant à
la capacité des autorités à lutter
contre les récidives en particulier
lorsque les angevins saisies sont
ensuite restituée aux fauteurs de
troubles enfin récemment l'état a été
condamné pour son inaction à faire
cesser ces rodéos motorisés preuve s'il
en était besoin que la loi n'est pas
exécutée comme il faudrait l'ensemble de
ces observations et les à la fois la
persistance de ces pratiques et à la
faiblesse de l'état pour faire respecter
la loi crée un sentiment de totale
impunité qui est incompatible avec la
légitime attente de sécurité de nos
concitoyens
monsieur le ministre face à ce constat
d'échec quatre actions visage et vous de
mener pour lutter contre ce fléau
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole qu'aux ministres au garde des
sceaux
pardonnez moi monsieur dupont moretti
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur x avery d'abord une petite
précision qui me paraît devoir s'imposer
la condamnation
c'est une condamnation qui est arrivé
bien plus tard que les événements et
elle ne couvre pas des faits qui nous
seraient imputables
voilà pour la précision elle est
toujours utile par ailleurs depuis la
loi du 3 août 2010 8 qui permet de
considérer les rodéos urbains comme des
délits nous avons considérablement
progressé je vous donnerai dans un
instant les chiffres ils viennent d'être
stabilisé nous avons de notre côté fait
voter la loi justice de proximité que
vous avez voté je crois qui grâce au
budget substantiel accordé à la justice
permet la mise en oeuvre de saisie
immédiate de scooter je vous indique
d'ailleurs que j'ai adressé à l'ensemble
des maires de notre pays une demande
pour qu'il puisse garder les véhicules
saisis car vous le savez ça coûte 50
millions d'euros à la justice
j'attends un certain nombre de réponses
en font pour que vous puissiez
considérer que nous avons
considérablement progressé et non pas
régresser comme vous le dites
qu'il me soit permis de vous dire qu'en
2018 c92 condamnation qui sont tombés
qu'en 2019 c'est 697 condamnation qui
sont qui ont été prononcées et qu'en
2020 7 991 condamnation prononcée soit
une multiplication par 10 des
condamnations intervenu pour les rodéos
urbains
j'ajoute et j'en ai le temps que j'ai
pris une circulaire reprenant les 350
qu'infraction dit de basse intensité
j'exclus bien sûr les homicides
involontaires dont vous avez parlé mais
pour le rodéo urbain pour un certain
nombre d'infractions au nombre de 350
j'ai demandé aux parquets qu'ils
appliquent avec une grande fermeté les
textes qui nous permette de réprimer
voilà la réponse que je souhaitais vous
faire monsieur le sénateur merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
stéphane demi pour le rôle de l'union
centriste
madame la ministre chargée de
l'insertion dans un rapport publié mardi
dernier la cour des comptes certifie les
comptes 2020 de plusieurs branches du
régime général de la sécurité sociale
moyennant je la cite un nombre accru de
réserve et c'est tout particulièrement
la caisse nationale d'assurance
vieillesse qui est la cible de critiques
du fait d'erreurs toujours plus
nombreuses dans le calcul des
prestations de retraite
une prestation sur six nouvellement
attribuées ou réviser en 2020 à
comporter au moins une erreur financière
et cheveux et ce dans la grande majorité
des cas au détriment des retraités
pour être concret l'impact cumulé dans
le temps de ces erreurs est estimé à 1,6
milliard d'euros et selon la caisse
nationale elle même la moitié des
retraités les et ont subi un préjudice
égal ou supérieur à 123 euros par an ces
sommes sont loin d'être négligeables
surtout quand on sait que la pension
moyenne versées aux retraités en 2019 en
france était de 1393 euros nets mensuels
certains aiment la ministre ces erreurs
ne sont pas nouvelles mais la situation
se dégrade
année après année d'une erreur sur neuf
dossiers il ya cinq ans nous en sommes
dorénavant à une erreur sur six dossiers
il y à deux mois des retraités
manifester pour une revalorisation de
leurs pensions
on comprend donc que la révélation de
ces erreurs de la caisse de retraite
soit mal vécu d'autant qu'elle concerne
prioritairement les personnes les plus
modestes
la cour des comptes relève que ce sont
en effet les pensions les plus faibles
qui sont touchés avec un taux d'erreur
de près de 23% pour l'allocation de
solidarité aux personnes âgées
madame la ministre la question est
extrêmement simple
comment redonner confiance à nos
concitoyens et améliorer la fiabilité du
système pour vous répondre la parole
madame brigitte klinkert ministre
délégué chargé de l'insertion
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur demi en effet la cour des
comptes rappelle que les erreurs de
calcul des pensions de retraite sont une
réalité les erreurs de calcul ont
augmenté ces dernières années vous
l'avais dit en 2020 elle concerne une
pension sur 6 contre eux une pension sur
neuf en 2016 cela n'est en effet pas
négligeable l'erreur médiane quant à
elle est en défaveur des assurés elle
est de l'ordre de 10 euros par mois
je rappelle d'abord que le calcul des
pensions est un exercice extrêmement
complexe d'autant plus avec 42 régime
dépendant des statuts professionnels
pour calculer une pension de retraite à
l'euro près il ne faut oublier aucun
élément de la vie professionnelle et
intégrer les données et règles
d'interaction avec les autres régimes de
retraite et avec la complexification des
carrières cette mission devient de plus
en plus exigeante
l'assurance retraite fait déjà un
travail considérable pour qui ces
erreurs soient détecter et corriger
c'est d'ailleurs l'une de ses activités
principales et grâce à cela au moins 40%
des années au mali sont corrigés dans
les semaines et mois qui suivent leur
identification
selon l'assurance retraite il est donc
essentiel que ce travail du quotidien
sera encore renforcée et traité plus en
amont et c'est pour cela que l'assurance
retraite a mis en place un plan d'action
global qui doit permettre à court terme
mais aussi à moyen long terme de mieux
comprendre les sources des anomalies
pour les identifier et à porter des
traitements adaptés de renforcer la
supervision et la formation interne de
développer de nouveaux outils
informatiques les services de
l'assurance retraite sont pleinement
mobilisées soyez en assuré élisabeth
bornes et laurent pietra chefs qui sont
très attentifs à ce que ce plan est des
effets concrets dès cette année je vous
remercie monsieur demi
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
bruno rejoint pour le groupe l'est
républicain avait la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre il n'y a
pas si longtemps nous vivions la crise
des gilets jaunes
ces manifestations ont révélé les
tensions et les fractures à la fois
sociales économiques et territoriales
qui minent notre société
l'aco vider les confinements successifs
ont mis un frein à l'ensemble des
mouvements sociaux en faisant rentrer à
la maison toutes les contestations
cependant les reproches à l'égard de
votre politique sont toujours présents
et se sont amplifiées alors que nous
sortons progressivement de la crise
sanitaire
il faut regarder les choses en face
depuis que votre gouvernement est en
place le quotidien des classes
populaires ne s'est pas améliorée dans
nos territoires
on constate chaque jour un éloignement
grandissant est très inquiétant entre
les français ruraux modeste et la
politique menée vous leur demander de
prendre le vélo et les transports en
commun de bazarder le diesel pour
l'électrique d'abandonner les chaudières
au fioul
même si ce sont de bonnes intentions
ces mesures sont éloignés des
préoccupations et du quotidien de
nombreux français attention au choc en
retour car vous les sommer de s'adapter
malgré le couac il en coûte qui draine
en masse l'argent public
la france populaire n'y trouve pas son
compte
nos concitoyens les plus modestes ont
toujours l'impression de travailler
durement sans gagner leur vie dignement
monsieur le premier ministre avez vous
conscience de cette france là qui gronde
qui peinent et ronge son frein et que la
plus petite décision malvenue au mauvais
moment peut raviver la violente
contestation que ni vous ni nous ne
souhaitons en conclusion ma question est
simple
que comptez vous faire
réduire cette fracture sociale et
territoriale
si évidente pour répondre la parole à la
secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'économie sociale vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rejoint on vous l'avait dit et
nous le savons effectivement par de
nombreux aspects la crise coville a
affecté plus durement et continue
d'affecter plus durement les ménages en
bas de l'échelle des revenus
je ne vais pas en deux minutes pouvoir
être assez exhaustive sur toutes les
aides transverse et sectorielles qui ont
permis depuis plus d'un an à notre
économie de tenir mais il est évident
qu'en faisant tenir l'économie c'est les
ménages et la société que nous avons
fait tenir notamment les plus fragiles
le gouvernement n'a passé que soutenir
l'économie je pense aux différentes
aides exceptionnelles et légitimes qui
ont été déployés en faveur des plus
fragiles et qui sont déjà mises en
oeuvre pour quasiment un milliard
d'euros en novembre 2020
vous vous en souvenez très certainement
c'est l'aide exceptionnelle de
solidarité aux bénéficiaires du rsa
complété par une aide de 100 euros par
enfant qui a été étendue également aux
familles bénéficiaires des aides aux
logements soit près de 4 1 millions de
bénéficiaires par ailleurs les aides à
destination des étudiants en difficulté
et des jeunes précaires pour plus 560
mille d'entre eux l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire le renfort du à des
places en hébergement d'urgence je
voulais dit je n'aurai pas le temps de
toutes les citer au delà de leur ampleur
il est important de dire que ces aides
atteignent leur cible
une étude du trésor fin 2020 démontre
clairement que les deux tiers des
bénéficiaires des aides débloquées pour
les ménages sont parmi les français les
moins riches parmi les 20 % des français
les moins riches ajoute une étude du
conseil d'analysé économique qui est
assez récente début 2000 21 qui démontre
aussi clairement que le niveau de vie
des bénéficiaires ne se détériore pas
durant cette période je parle là aussi
des catégories les plus populaires et
les plus fragiles
les catégories populaires nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles sont au
coeur
monsieur le sénateur de nos
préoccupations depuis le début de ce
quinquennat depuis 2010 est non nous
n'avons pas attendu la crise pour
supprimer la taxe d'habitation nous
alléger de 5 milliards d'euros l'impôt
sur le revenu faut-il le rappeler
face à une crise sans pouvoir conclure
je conclurai monsieur le président en
rappelant juste que le cap ne change pas
la route est la même ça fait quatre ans
que nous travaillons à l'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat des plus fragiles et
nous avons bien l'intention de continuer
je remercie la parole et qu'un autre
collègue bernard geôliers pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
premier nice pardon mesdames et laisser
miss mes chers collègues la question des
déserts médicaux est toujours
d'actualité dans notre pays des millions
de personnes éprouvent des difficultés à
consulter un médecin généraliste ou un
professionnel de santé de premier
recours
les collectivités territoriales beaucoup
de collectivités territoriales ont pris
et prennent des initiatives en ce
domaine pour résoudre cette injustice
territoriales ici au sénat il y a deux
ans nous avons proposé un dispositif qui
affecterait pour six mois des internes
en fin de cursus en zones sous denses en
ville ce dispositif a été inscrit dans
la loi du 24 juillet 2019 et depuis deux
ans vous n'avez pas pris textes
d'application quand monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur ministre appliquerez
vous cette loi quand prendrez-vous les
textes d'application je remercie pour
vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur avery attaqué
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'enfance
et de la famille
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices si les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bernard jomier vous vous
référez sauf erreur disposition qui
avait été proposée à l'époque par la
sénatrice corinne imbert je crois la
question la question du défi
démographique de la désertification
médicale ne datent pas de cette semaine
vous l'avez rappelé le date pas non plus
de ce quinquennat
elle trouve ses racines bien bien avant
elle ne concerne pas que les territoires
ruraux elle concerne également les
territoires urbains et vous qui êtes
sénateur de paris mais que vous
connaissez qui connaissait bien le nord
de ce département et de cette région
vous savez qu'elle concerne aussi les
zones les zones urbaines le défi est
grand le nombre de médecins généralistes
spécialistes en accès direct a
effectivement baissé depuis de
nombreuses années et ce gouvernement n'a
fait une de ses priorités puisqu'un
certain nombre de mesures ont été
adoptées depuis le début de ce
quinquennat je ne vais pas toutes les
énumérer ici rappeler peut-être juste
avant d'essayer
dray de répondre à votre question
monsieur le monsieur le sénateur
rappeler tout de même les communautés
professionnelles territorial de santé
laisser pts qui au plus près des
réalités du territoire vous et vous
évoquez cette exigence d'être au plus
près des besoins des concitoyens et des
collectivités locales fonctionnent
permettent effectivement à l'ensemble
des professionnels de santé de
s'organiser et la crise que vide a été
un révélateur de l'efficacité de ces
dynamiques territoriales
en parallèle en parallèle de ces cette
disposition vous rappeler que nous avons
également pris des dispositions avec un
impact attendu à plus brève échéance et
qui s'inscrivent un peu dans la lignée
du dispositif que vous évoquez la
création de 4000 postes d'assistants
médicaux pour secondes et est appuyé les
médecins dans leurs tâches
administratives et et soignante le
déploiement de sites sans médecins
généralistes dans des territoires
prioritaires dont 200 priorité prioriser
pardon sur les territoires ruraux en
exercice partagé entre une structure
hospitalière une structure en
ambulatoire ou salariés et s'agissant
ces fonds conclure du décret pour
conclure je reviendrai vers vous dans
les meilleurs délais pour vous dire quel
sera le délai d'application de prise de
ce décret monsieur j'ai oublié alors
monsieur le ministre merci pour toutes
vos considérations mais je peux
peut-être je mes oreilles entendent mal
mais je n'ai pas entendu quand ce décret
serait publié et je trouve tout de même
problématique que quand la loi est votée
elle l'a été
après on sait sur cette question un
échange entre les deux chambres
une solution qui fait consensus et qui
apporterait réellement du temps médical
au bénéfice des populations de ce
territoire et vous n'appliquez pas la
loi
la latitude qu'on vous a laissée dans la
rédaction était normal c'est celle de
l'adaptation intelligente du dispositif
mais là vous refusez de mettre en oeuvre
le dispositif est ce un véritable
problème démocratique et moi je vous
appelle
comme la loi 3d va arriver l'énumération
vous avez fait 4 3 7 euros
mais quand la loi va arriver c'est très
bientôt vous avez parlé des dispositifs
territoriaux de santé et bien inscrivons
dans cette fois la reconnaissance du
rôle des collectivités territoriales
dans cette organisation au moins
travaillant intelligemment là dessus et
respecter notre rôle merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue valérie
boyer pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre stéphanie jeune maman
est abattu lâchement en pleine rue par
son compagnon fraîchement de sortie de
prison réfugier dans l'essonne une
famille tué à plusieurs coups de marteau
sur la tête devant son fils de 11 ans
chahinez et brûlée vive par son
compagnon en pleine rue à mérignac 3
drame inacceptable trois de trop aussi
ma question est simple que comptez vous
faire pour corriger ces failles éviter à
tout prix que de tels drames se
reproduisent
pour vous répondre la parole et lui
disent déléguée chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes changer
de la diversité l'égalité des chances
devant la mort et dont je vous remercie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs des sénateurs madame la
sénatrice voyez je sais combien le sujet
des violences conjugales est un sujet
cher pour vous sur lequel vous vous êtes
longtemps investi et je vous remercie
pour votre question parce que longtemps
en en trop longtemps notre société a été
sourde aux cris des larmes elle a été
aveugle aux souffrances et muette face
aux violences qui étaient faites aux
femmes et aux filles
et comme vous le savez le gouvernement
et la majorité se sont mobilisés depuis
2010 est pour enrayer ce fléau effet
proville isation général s'est traduite
par le vôtre de quatre lois en quatre
ans ainsi que 46 mesures qui sont issus
du grenelle des violences conjugales
parmi lesquels les ordonnances de
protection qui ont été démultipliés
l'etrat les téléphones grave danger
les bracelets anti rapprochement qui ont
été mis en place mais aussi
l'augmentation de 60% des places
d'hébergement pour accueillir les femmes
qui étaient victimes de violences
et hier j'ai annoncé la mise en oeuvre
d'une autre de ces mesures du grenelle
qui est l'extension des erreurs des
horaires du 39 19 pour pouvoir répondre
à toutes les femmes qui sont victimes de
violence dans notre pays qu'elle se
trouve sur les territoires ultramarins
dans l'hexagone et qu'elle soit mal
entendantes sourdes ou aphasiques et dès
la fin du mois d'août
et bien cette ligne sera accessible 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 pour
permettre à ces femmes d'avoir une
écoute et un accompagnement lorsque cela
est nécessaire et je crois madame la
sénatrice parce que vous avez
particulièrement suivi les travaux qui
ont eu lieu ces dernières années que
vous avez pu constater que ce combat
nous le menons de manière totalement
déterminés chaque féminicide dans notre
pays est un drame absolu et c'est pour
cela que nous n'avons pas le droit de
faiblir et que c'est ensemble
état collectivités locales collectivités
territoriales et société civile que nous
arriverons à enrayer ce fléau soir merci
merci madame valérie boyer merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
des choses ont été faites certes mais je
crois que c'est drame aurait pu être
évité si vous ne vous étiez donner les
moyens d'appliquer des lois que nous
avons voté à l'unanimité pourtant les
bracelets anti-rapprochement
actuellement seuls 76 sont prescrits et
45 hommes en sont équipés nous demandons
d'augmenter le budget des bracelets vous
vous y opposez vous demandons de la
fermeté pour libérer les conjoints
violents faute de places de prison 15000
places promises seulement 1700
aujourd'hui construites la non exécution
des peines se font au détriment des
français et des françaises
vous voulez redorer la grande cause du
quinquennat l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes s redorer cette grande
cause que de s'opposer aux mesures
adaptées aux réalités actuelles et
innovante que nous proposons nous avons
demandé que des réfugiés soient déchus
de leur statut lorsqu'ils commettent des
crimes et délits notamment des violences
conjugales rejetée nous proposons le
rétablissement des peines planchers pour
les violences conjugales notamment
rejeté de créer un système de name and
shame pour les violences conjugales
rejeté hier nous avons reconnu le
syndrome de la femme battue mais vous
étiez est proposé dans l'hémicycle est
ce au nom des valeurs du sport et de la
république que votre collègue ministre
du sport ne s'oppose pas loin de là à ce
que des signes d' interdit de liberté
d'interdire d'égalité n'interdit de
fraternité comme le hidjab du sport soit
promu il y a quelques jours cette même
ministre ne voyait pas d'inconvénient à
ce qu'un chanteur représente l'équipe de
france de football et chante notamment
des agressions sexuelles
à l'encontre de personnalités politiques
quelle est la cohérence au sein de votre
gouvernement
alors il y a beaucoup de paroles il y a
beaucoup de communication mais la grande
cause du quinquennat en cours loin
d'être redorée se perd dans les méandres
du en même temps et parfois même du
séparatisme
c'est vraiment regrettable la parole est
à notre collègue nathalie goulet pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
oui monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues depuis 18 mois la commission
des lois la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat travaille sur les
questions de d'irresponsabilité pénale
et sur toutes les questions liées à l
expertise psychiatrique nous avons
adopté un texte hier des réflexions du
gouvernement celle de l'assemblée
nationale sur cette question des
responsabilités sont des réflexions pour
l'avenir moi je voudrais pas vous parler
de la situation présente en 2018
derniers chiffres publiés 326 auteurs
jugées irresponsables ont fait l'objet
d'un non lieu
treize 1495 classement sans suite sans
que l'on sache avec précision
de quelle mesure de soi ou
d'accompagnement il bénéficie ni
d'ailleurs s'il en bénéficient qui ils
sont et où il demeure comment entendez
vous assurez le suivi des auteurs
irresponsable alors que vous avez
supprimé la collecte de ces données
par dépêche du 18 juin 2019 la direction
des affaires criminelles et des grâces a
informé les juridictions de sa décision
de supprimer le dispositif de
recensement des décisions
d'irresponsabilité pénale pour cause de
trouble mental
par souci d'alléger leur travail la
dernière étude épidémiologique générale
réalisée en france sur la santé mentale
dans les prisons remonte quant à elle à
donc monsieur le ministre la question
que je vous pose c'est mon et vous de la
mise en place du système de remplacement
de la collecte et du suivi des personnes
irresponsables
comment comptez-vous censé donner
assurer la sécurité des français on va
vendre la parole est au garde des sceaux
visage si ce monsieur dupont moretti
si monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les
sénateur madame la sénatrice goulet vous
souhaitez prolonger le débat que nous
avons eu hier mais vous ne souhaitez pas
le circonscrire à la discussion que nous
avions vous souhaitez savoir quel est le
sort qui est réservé à ceux qui sont
déclarées irresponsables mais nous avons
effleuré cette question hier vous
devriez poser la question au ministre de
la santé pardonnez moi de le dire car à
compter du moment où un homme est
déclarée irresponsable
il n'est pas détenu madame il est soigné
alors si vous souhaitez que l'on remette
en place un outil permettant d'avoir le
nombre
j'y travaille avec vous très volontiers
ma porte est ouverte nous le remettrons
en place et les excuses auxquelles vous
faites allusion selon laquelle
s'adonnant être travail n'est pas pour
moi une excuse pertinente
on venait me voir la chancellerie je
suis tout à fait d'accord pour qu'on
puisse recenser le nombre de ceux qui
ont bénéficié d'un non lieu pour qu'on
connaisse leur suivi pour le reste pour
le reste la décision du 14 avril nous a
beaucoup émus certains de nos
compatriotes n'ont pas compris cette
décision c'est une décision qui a été
rendue en droit et les juges ont pris
soin de préciser en réalité qu'il ne
pouvait pas distinguer là où la loi ne
le permettait pas vous avez tenté de
remédier à cela j'ai moi-même à la
demande du président de la république
qui ont travaillé sur un texte
j'ai reçu les cultes et magistrats des
avocats des psychiatres j'ai souhaité
soumettre ce texte à l'avis du conseil
d'état est très prochainement bien sûr
il sera porté à votre connaissance et
j'espère comme je les ai toujours fait
ici nous pouvons travailler ensemble sur
ces questions si la goulue oui monsieur
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie de
votre réponse mais
j'ai quand même un léger souci parce que
voyez-vous le rapport de la mission ou
lyon et un bord qui fait maintenant
l'alpha et l'oméga de la politique de la
chancellerie explique mais explique
quand même que la direction des affaires
criminelles et des grâces je crois bien
que c'est votre ministère a supprimé la
collecte des données est d'ailleurs en
page 38 des 39 concernant ces sujets la
recommandation 13 du fameux rapport qui
est donc il relève de votre ministère
demande d'organiser le lancement des
décisions donc il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble sur ces sujets il n'empêche que
ces recensements sont nécessaires merci
la parole est à notre collègue jean
raymond hugonnet pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre le projet de pass culture opère
une rupture radicale dans le cadre des
politiques publiques de la culture il
inverse les termes de la politique de
l'offre et de la demande et ils
positionnent les acteurs du service
public de la culture dans une
concurrence directe et frontale avec les
grands opérateurs du privé et avec les
industries culturelles des loisirs le
projet passe culture part d'un principe
jamais débattu que la question de
l'accès à la culture des jeunes est
d'abord un problème économique et
technologique
avant d'être un sujet éminemment
symbolique et politique dont l'exclusion
sociale et territoriale sont les
marqueurs principaux le projet pass
culture ignore l'engagement quotidien
des équipes de médiation et de
transition culturel dont je rappelle ici
qu'il est financé très majoritairement
par les collectivités territoriales
le projet passe culture enfin draine sur
lui un budget intarissable quoi qu'il en
coûte qui constitue une véritable
gabegie dont il ne fait nul doute que la
cour des comptes en dénoncera les
errements le moment venu après françoise
nyssen et franck riester roselyne
bachelot et la troisième ministre à
récupérer ce mistigri présidentielle
madame la ministre
à l'heure où la généralisation du pass
culture vient d'être décidée par le
président de la république lui-même son
ce mac fly des carlito qui vont assurer
le service après vente
ou bien ne pensez vous pas plutôt qu'il
est grand temps d'arrêter les frais pour
vous répondre la parole et de la
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
jeunesse et de l'engagement merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean
raymond hugonnet monsieur le sénateur
vous savez à quel point puisque vous
avez suivi les expérimentant les
expérimentations en présidant le groupe
qui a participé et qui a accompagné le
développement du pass culture à quel
point ce pass culture permet deux choses
la première c'est évidemment
l'émancipation de notre jeunesse
l'accès à la culture l'émancipation en
permettant à une jeunesse qui pour le
coup un réel frein d'accès et bien
accédez à des concerts des festivals
accéder à l'achat d'instruments de
musique ou encore de livres et
d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur il se
trouve que les premiers résultats du
déploiement et de la généralisation du
pass culture portée par le président de
la république et ma collègue roselyne
bachelot dès vendredi à ont permis à
plus de 650 mille jeunes de télécharger
cette application elle est le premier
applications téléchargées aujourd'hui
sur les plateformes gratuites permettant
aux jeunes de 18 ans aux jeunes de notre
pays est bien de retrouver de l'air de
retrouver cette culture qui nous a tant
manqué et monsieur le sénateur 80%
d'ailleurs des dépenses déjà utilisé il
se trouve que ce sont des livres des
livres c'est les jeunes ont acheté des
livres
donc ces jeunes de 18 ans monsieur le
sénateur je crois que c'est une chance
pour notre pays je crois que leur ouvrir
l'accès leur permettent le retour
aujourd'hui à la culture est une chance
et ça vient évidemment avec
l'accompagnement de l'enseignement et
d'éducation à la pratique artistique et
culturelle et avec jean michel blanquer
renoue le faisons dès la 4e avec cette
volonté de déployer encore plus
largement ce pass culture la quatrième
avec plutôt des projets collectifs et
pédagogique sur les territoires et un
peu plus tard vers la terminale avec des
projets individuels
l'idée est simple c'est accompagnés
chacun de nos enfants sur le chemin de
l'accès à une culture pour tous et plus
jamais que le frein en réalité financier
ne soit une barrière
je remercie ces zones et j'entends votre
réponse madame la ministre mais elle ne
convainc pas grand monde ici en tous
points du pays c'est la puissance du
réseau de la culture décentralisée qui
assure la relation au public jeune en
particulier
c'est une action durable constante dont
les artistes sont les premiers acteurs
la priorité à accorder à la jeunesse ne
saurait passer par des gadgets décidé
verticalement depuis paris au mépris des
réalités de nos territoires
merci de donner la parole maintenant
madame la présidente laurence rien pour
le groupe socialiste et écologistes et
républicains
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président je souhaite d'abord associé à
cette question bien sûr mes collègues
les plus proches qui sont là est
également mon ami olivier léonard
sénateur de l'essonne qui vous avait
déjà monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères interrogé sur la situation de
l'algérie il y a deux ans est né en
algérie un mouvement citoyen pacifique
mixte qui constitue un immense espoir
pour la jeunesse algérienne
ce mouvement que demande-t-il un pouvoir
civil des libertés démocratiques
un meilleur partage des richesses et la
fin de la corruption
bref un avenir depuis quelques mois à la
faveur de la crise sanitaire la
répression s'est abattue sur ce
mouvement
on ne compte plus les citoyens les
militants les journalistes arrêtés
emprisonnés condamnés
le but du pouvoir et par la peur et la
domination de cassis mouvement les
libertés fondamentales liberté d'opinion
liberté de manifester liberté
d'information droit à un procès
équitable toutes ces libertés garantis
par la déclaration universelle des
droits humains sont bafoués
monsieur le ministre que pouvons nous
faire pour les garantir en algérie vous
répondre la parole et au finish de
l'europe les affaires étrangères ce
genre le rie anglais parole ou et madame
la présidente
comme vous le savez nos deux pays sont
unis par des liens humains ancrées dans
l'histoire des liens tout à fait
essentielle et notre volonté est de
renforcer notre relation
cette volonté s'exprime au plus haut
niveau puisque le président est bonne et
le prg et jean mach on se parle
régulièrement le premier ministre se
rendra bientôt à alger pour un comité
interministériel de haut niveau qui
devait avoir lieu il ya quelques jours
mais qui a été repoussée en raison de la
pandémie
nous entretenons des relations
régulières sur au niveau des ministres
des affaires étrangères
et les autorités algériennes ont exprimé
l'ambition de réformer l'algérie en
profondeur dans un esprit de dialogue et
d'ouverture qui corresponde aux attentes
qui ont été exprimées dans le irak de
manière pacifique et avec dignité par
les algériens
notre seul souhait c'est la réussite des
réformes au bénéfice de l'algérie et des
algériens parce que madame la présidente
c'est aux algériens et à eux seuls de
déterminer la voie de ce chemin c'était
aux algériens et à eux seuls de fixer
les modalités de ce destin dans le
respect des libertés publiques dans
libres et le respect liberté
d'expression dans le respect la liberté
de la presse auquel la france est
attachée partout dans le monde et je
trouve le moment de votre question
singulière puisque il y à des élections
législatives dans quinze jours en
algérie et que la campagne est ouverte
depuis quinze jours et vous permettrait
madame la présidente que par respect
pour la souveraineté du peuple algérien
je ne fasse pas de commentaires
supplémentaires
la présidente monsieur le ministre nous
respectons tous la souveraineté du
peuple algérien
mais il y actuellement 137 personnes
emprisonnées pour délit d'opinion
alors voyez vous ce processus que vous
décrivez de la réforme en profondeur de
l'algérie par la démocratie c'est un
processus idéal c'est celui dont nous
rêvons tous mais il n'a pas lieu ce qui
se passe actuellement en algérie celle
inverse d'un processus de réformes et
vous savez bien que les atteintes
quotidiennes aux libertés dans un pays
comme l'algérie sont extrêmement
dangereuses pour l'avenir de ce pays
la jeunesse algérienne aujourd'hui et
sans avenir
elle le sait elle leur sang etc et se
passe-t-il
elles fuient massivement savez vous que
depuis l'année dernière c'est 50% de
plus de jeunes algériens qui ont quitté
l'algérie pour rejoindre les côtes de
l'europe ce qui se passe en algérie
c'est notre coeur qu'il ressent
merci la parole maintenant notre
collègue laurence muller brawn pour le
groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame sarah elle lit harry
secrétaire d'état chargée de la jeunesse
et de l'engagement
je regrette bien sûr l'absence de
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
monsieur blanc caire pour répondre à
cette question
madame la secrétaire d'état le 8 avril
dernier les langues régionales ont
obtenu une reconnaissance et une
victoire historique à l'assemblée
nationale la loi proposée par notre
collègue député paul molac a en effet
été adopté à une très large majorité
d'abord au sénat puis à l'assemblée avec
276 voix pour et seulement 76 voix
contre ce vote est le résultat d'un
processus démocratique et trans partisan
pour la promotion des langues régionales
notamment grâce à l'article 4 qui
inscrit dans la loi
l'enseignement immersif pourtant le
gouvernement a décidé de s'y opposer en
un site en inde en initiant un recours
au conseil constitutionnel contre sa
propre majorité
et faut-il y voir un message symbolique
c'est le 21 mai date de la journée
mondiale de la diversité culturelle que
celui ci a rendu sa décision et signer
ce qui ressemble à l'arrêt de mort des
langues de france
en censurant l'essentiel de la loi no
lac dans des conditions on ne peut plus
trouble en effet plusieurs députés en
marche ont publiquement affirmé que
leurs signatures pour ce recours
laurent avait été arraché et on écrit au
conseil constitutionnel pour la retirer
en même temps
monsieur le premier ministre et hier et
le président emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
déclare que les langues régionales sont
une chance pour la république pour
minimiser l'effet de cette censure on
annonce la création d'une énième mission
confiée à deux députés
qu'attendez vous concrètement de cette
mission ma question est simple
quel est l'avenir des écoles publiques
et associatives basque bretonne
alsacienne occitane et autres sous
contrat avec l'état
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
secrétaire bis
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice la
proposition de loi no look puisque tel
est son nom adopté dans les conditions
que vous avez rappelé n'a pas fait
l'objet de la part du gouvernement du
premier ministre j'en ai la possibilité
d'un recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel et en toute hypothèse
je rappelle au sénat que la principale
censure prononcée par le conseil
constitutionnel l'a été
suite à la procédure de soulèvements
d'office ce qui montre que la question
est réelle puisque le sujet aurait bu du
coup être exposé à n'importe quelle
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité le sénat s'est
parfaitement cela ça c'est sur l'aspect
juridique et procédural
je vais donc maintenant vous faire une
réponse politique le gouvernement
le présent la république vous l'avez dit
vous-même être extrêmement attachés aux
langues régionales
vous êtes
dieu alors
vous êtes madame la sénatrice élus
d'alsace
je suis moi même élu d'une région où les
langues régionales sont très développés
et renseignez vous je les ai toujours
soutenu et encouragé
renseignez vous renseignez vous il nous
appartient d'en dans le respect de
l'état de droit républicain que
l'ensemble des membres de cette haute
assemblée
respekt de tenir compte et de tirer tous
les enseignements de cette décision mais
nous le ferons avec la volonté de
préserver et de maintenir le rôle des
langues régionales à l'école dans le
cadre de l'unité de la république et je
veux je me suis exprimé hier vous l'avez
rappelé mme la sénatrice à l'assemblée
nationale sur la méthode
je veux aller devant le sénat un pas
plus loin se profile la rentrée pour ces
établissements en particulier parce que
c'est une des questions posées ceux qui
sont sous contrat d'association avec
l'état et qui ont exprimé je les ai vus
comme vous des inquiétudes suite à cette
décision
je veux dire ici au sénat déjà que cette
rentrée s'effectuera tout à fait
normalement pour ces établissements
je voulais dit vous l'avez rappelé et
m'a menacée à trish nous allons c'est
une initiative parlementaire d'un député
après ce serait une mission courte vous
inquiétiez après que les deux députés
mais rendu leurs conclusions j'ai dit
que je recevrai l'ensemble des
associations concernées pour que
sereinement pour que sereinement nous en
tirions toutes les conséquences qui joue
lundi qu'au sénat seront marquées par la
volonté politique du gouvernement de
préserver la richesse que constitue dans
le cadre de l'unité de la république les
langues régionales
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue christine herzog pour le groupe
de l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre m
haies dames et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur cédric au
secrétaire d'état chargé de la
transition numérique
l'émission cash investigations du
mercredi 19 mai dernier a révélé ce qui
pourrait bien être considéré comme un
scandale d'état
le 12 septembre 2018 la cnil avait
autorisé les pharmaciens à collecter les
données de santé des français au profit
d'iss via filiale française du plus gros
data broker américain contre une
imprimante gratuite de 6 euros par mois
et par pharmacie toutes les données
médicales de nos concitoyens sont
automatiquement transmises numéro de
sécurité sociale prénom âge sexe
infections traitement et c'est un plat
de lentilles à l'échelle des profits
général par ces données qui sont ensuite
revendus à toutes sortes de sociétés via
les usa qui peuvent ainsi faire du
ciblage publicitaire de plus en plus
précis en justifiant un pseudo intérêt
d'ordre public qui ne peut être contrôlé
à ce jour la moitié des pharmacies
pratiquerait cette collecte soit 10 mai
l'officine 40 millions de français
seraient ainsi concernés et cela entités
en toute illégalité puisque la
réglementation générale sur la
protection des données
la rgpp des impose une information
préalable est l'expression d'un accord
explicite avant toute collecte de
données
or en pratique la formation n'a jamais
été affichés et le consentement jamais
donné plus grave encore cette pratique
serait connue dé presse du président de
la république est couverte au plus haut
sommet de l'état
monsieur le ministre que pouvez vous
nous dire de ces méthodes confirmé
confirmez-vous son illégalité
et si oui quel et vous faire pour mettre
fin à la marchandisation de la santé des
français qui ignorent cette pratique
pour vous répondre par an dès que ceux
pesant d'état en charge de l'enfance et
de la famille monsieur le ministre
merci merci merci monsieur le président
madame mesdames messieurs driss
sénateurs madame la sénatrice merci de
poser cette question qui se réfère à une
émission vous l'avez évoqué du 20 mai
dernier qui suscite un certain nombre
d'interrogations
vous avez relayé auxquelles il est
important d'apporter des réponses
précises tant les sujets sont évidemment
importants pour nos concitoyens pour nos
pour de liberté questions qui portent
sur l'accès aux données de santé des
citoyens par les pharmaciens sur l'usagé
qui en sera fait notamment par la
société high ku via et qui récupère
auprès des 14000 officines dont elle est
partenaire héberge sur ses serveurs un
certain nombre de données entièrement
pseudo mise ceux de nos mises et premier
point l'entreprise n'a bien sûr jamais
se donner aux mises et ceux de nos mises
et se donnent au musée
ceux de mise et on a compris a poursuivi
monsieur le président ce que ceux de
mise et se dominer bon seydoux misé bon
vous m'aviez compris
alors sur les sujets sérieux donc on va
reprendre notre sérieux l'entreprise n'a
pas la médiatrice jamais accès jamais
accès à l'identité du patient ces
données permettent de mener des études
d'intérêt public qui vise par exemple
l'évaluation de la bonne utilisation du
médicament
l'analyse scientifique et statistiques
des phénomènes liés à la persistance la
conformité le respect des prescriptions
et des contrées des indications liste
précise de ces études que vous pouvez
consulter en ligne de façon transparente
faut noter autre point important ces
données ne sont pas vendus c'était
effectivement interdit mais que c'est
bien la prestation des analyses à partir
de ces données qui est indemnisé aux
pharmaciens
cette nuance est importante vous
l'évoquiez dans votre question ce
processus et notamment son niveau de
sécurité est parfaitement conforme très
rarement à ce que vous laissiez entendre
à la déclaration faite à la cnil qui
prévoit que ces données sont traitées en
interne ne sont pas transmises à des
tiers
et la cnil avait souligné dans son art
est 2018 l'intérêt public majeur que
représentaient les études menées sur la
base de ces données
à titre d'exemple certaines de ces
données sont en open data et participe à
la gestion de la crise par exemple
chaque jour le nombre de vaccins le
nombre de tests antigénique le nombre
d'autos tests vendus chaque jour
motorisé un petit peu plus de temps
merci monsieur le président ce sujet
important n jeu j'essaie de conclure en
retour de l'envoi de ces données la
société high ku via aimé pour chaque
officine partenaires à cahier de bord
pour lui permettre une meilleure gestion
de son officine
les données servent aussi pour les
négociations conventionnelles du réseau
officinal avec la cnam
le dossier pharmaceutique dont le
conseil national de l'ordre des
pharmaciens et responsables et le
dossier médical partagé sont totalement
indépendants là aussi de la relation
entre le pharmacien et la société il n'y
a aucun n'accède de cette société à la
carte vitale n'y a aucun de ces dossiers
enfin oui pour conclure vraiment dire
que l'intérêt de ce reportage était
effectivement de rappeler l'importance
de la transparence en ces matières et la
société que que j'évoquais a pris un
certain nombre de mesures que je n'ai
pas le temps de développer qui vont dans
ce sens
mais la verge vous avez quelques
secondes si vous voulez des précision
sémantique non
bien je donne la parole à notre collègue
stéphane ravier qu'hier sur la liste de
cadre aux petits bouts plus merci
monsieur le président monsieur président
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre y
at il un pilote dans l'avion
c'est la question c'est la question que
se posent des millions de français
appréhendent aura pris que 15 membres de
votre gouvernement était candidat aux
élections régionales ou départementales
alors que la france est plongée dans une
crise sanitaire économique et
sécuritaire inédite dans l'histoire vaut
ministres n'ont manifestement rien de
mieux à faire que d'aller distribuer des
tracts ou coller des affiches avec rolex
ou breguet et boutons de manchette au
poignet
c'est rien de moins c'est rien de moins
que le ministre de l'intérieur et celui
de la justice qui sont candidats il y a
également le ministre des petites et
moyennes entreprises et celles de
l'industrie des secteurs en grande
souffrance à cause de votre politique
madame schiappa est aussi candidate mais
comme ça sur l'activité sait le faire
des tweets personne ne verra la
différence
le ministre de la santé a même affirmé
qu'il irait coller des affiches de
renaud muselier dans la région en
provence alpes côte d'azur avec un tel
adversaire thierry mariani n'a plus
besoin de soutien il est assuré de sa
victoire le 27 juin prochain
le premier ministre lui même a annoncé
l'alliance entre la république en marché
à l'air dans ma région il n'est plus le
chef d'une majorité est le directeur
d'une campagne du diane du dynamitage du
parti la république m et pendant ce
temps des français souffrent sont au
chômage dorment dans la rue ou dans leur
voiture se font violemment agressé y
compris les maires de petites communes
pendant que vous faites campagne que
vous découvrez le pays c'est déjà ça des
restaurateurs des hôteliers des
cafetiers se bat tous les jours pour
survivre
et pendant ce temps les jardins de
l'elysée se transforme en théâtre de
guignol ce n'est plus le jamel
les manuels comedy club charles françois
réveillez vous ils sont devenus fous car
j'ai honte pour la france mes chers
collègues que j'ai même honte pour vous
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mais ont tout d'abord à
ceux qui participent ou soutiennent
cette mascarade ses pitreries plus
préoccupé
ils seront le déshonneur et la défaite
comme l'a prédit eric ciotti la question
monsieur le président est donc la
suivante monsieur le premier ministre
est-ce que vous ne vous sentez pas trop
seul à la table d'un conseil que trop de
ministres ont déserté pour aller se
promener en campagne électorale pour
vous répondre
la parole était aux milices de
l'intérieur vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur est un
ravier ton ministre en charge des
élections je crois que c'est pour cela
qu'on m'a désigné afin de répondre à
votre inventaire à la prévert qui
ressemblait plus manifestement à des
jeunes ou relevant de la mana vermot
mais monsieur le sénateur pourquoi tel
mépris envers les tracts envers les
campagnes électorales envers les
élections j'ai pu me présenter aux
élections municipales comme vous êtes
ministre et moi être élu et pas vous
dans votre mairie donc avant monsieur le
sénateur de donner des leçons de
démocratie
présentez-vous gagne les élections et ne
reprochez pas aux autres les mauvaises
expériences que les électeurs vous ont
donné mais c'est
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
ou gouvernement les prochaines auront
lieu le mercredi 2 juin à 15 heures
merci monsieur communiste mesdames et
messieurs les ministres la séance ait
suspendu lé repris à 16h35 pour l'examen
de la proposition de loi d'urgence ils
ont apporté une réponse solidaire régis
face à la crise la réponse est sus d'un
séance est suspendue la réponse est
donnée
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette séance de
questions au gouvernement que vous avez
pu suivre en direct et en intégralité
sur public sénat on va débriefer jusqu'à
17 heures cette séance
et pour commencer on va rejoindre
l'hémicycle du sénat et steve jourdain
steve plusieurs temps forts dans cette
séance
lequel retenez-vous tout d'abord cette
question sociale qui s'est invitée dans
l'hémicycle c'est d'après midi la
question sociale ou l'augmentation de la
pauvreté de la précarité en france
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
alors il faut dire qu'un rapport sur ce
thème a été remis au gouvernement il ya
de cela trois semaines
ce rapport il pointe une hausse
alarmante de la pauvreté en france une
hausse une augmentation qui serait dû
précisément la crise sanitaire et à
gauche les communistes ont reproché
aujourd'hui au gouvernement de ne pas
avoir fait assez pour précisément lutter
contre l'augmentation des inégalités en
france écoutez eliane assassi
monsieur le premier ministre la france
est inquiète non pas de l'autre du
voisin de ce qu'il y ait de mourir sur
les plages d'europe
elle s'inquiète pour l'avenir incertain
de ses enfants de cette profonde
insécurité sociale car le libéralisme
détruit la solidarité l'égalité
les centaines de milliards monsieur le
premier ministre vous disposez pour
faire face à cette crise fruit de
l'activité humaine serviront-ils au
statu quo au statu quo ou pire à achever
notre modèle social
où vont ils servir à rebâtir une société
plus juste et plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et du côté du
gouvernement on ne nie pas un l'ampleur
de cette crise de cette crise sociale
née de cette crise sanitaire mais jean
castex refuse de porter le chapeau
écoutez le au début de la crise
sanitaire
la france ne se portait pas mal de
points de vue économique et social dans
le concert des nations
la france agit pour accompagner son
économie en 2020 j'ai pas les chiffres
de 2021
on est le pays d'europe où le pouvoir
d'achat +0 6% malgré l'effondrement de
l'économie
madame la présidente a été le mieux
préservé si la france monsieur le
président est désormais le grand pays de
la zone euro qui a le moins perdu
d'activité depuis le début de la crise
nous avons collectivement résister voilà
on l'aura compris le gouvernement qui
dans cette situation inédite et demandez
bien d'être jugé d'abord et avant tout
sur la gestion de la crise sanitaire tam
merci beaucoup et steve pour toutes ces
explications
autre temps fort lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement ce
moment qui a été consacrée à la question
des femmes initiées d'après ce nouveau
féminicide qui s'est produit à hayange
en moselle alexandre vous êtes
d'ailleurs avec elisabeth moreno la
ministre déléguée chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes de la
diversité et de l'égalité des chances et
qu'on a entendu tout à l'heure
s'exprimer à ce sujet dans l'hémicycle
effectivement elisabeth moreno un
nouveau féminicide s'est produite à
hayange en moselle
où est bien un homme a tué sa femme de
cinq coups couteau alors qu'il avait une
peine aménagée il avait une peine de
prison pour délits routiers il portait
un bracelet électronique
sa femme avait déposé une main courante
quelques mois avant et il s'est passé ce
drame comment c'est possible
alors d'abord ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que ce drame la mort de stéphanie
comme la mort de chanaz il ya quelque
temps à créer un vent d'émotion
important dans notre pays parce qu'ils
sont aussi odieux et aussi barbare l'un
que l'autre
ensuite il faut savoir et le procureur
l'a dit ce monsieur n'était pas connu
pour des crimes ou des violences
conjugales
mais vous savez j'ai pas envie en ce
moment là tout de suite j'ai pas envie
d'analyser ce qui a été dit ce qui a été
constaté
ce que je sais c'est que encore une fois
une femme est morte sous les coups de
son conjoint parce qu'il refusait
qu'elle ne veuille plus de lui qu'elle
ne veuille plus vivre avec lui qu'elle
ne veuille plus partager sa vie avec lui
parce qu'elle en avait marre de subir
les violences et il ya une chose qu'il
faut reconnaître c'est que depuis 2010
est depuis que nous avons mis la lumière
sur un fléau qui pendant très longtemps
a été tu as été cachés a été banalisé et
bien aujourd'hui enfin tout le monde se
saisit de cette question tout le monde
en parle et il faut colonne lensois
heureux d'en parler parce que c'est la
meilleure manière de désert visibiliser
cette question et de faire en sorte que
toute la société s'en saisisse pour
qu'enfin ensemble nous luttions contre
ce fléau
alors il ya quand même des questions qui
se pose malgré l'émotion car il ya eu le
drame de mérignac où là aussi des
dysfonctionnements ont déjà été pointée
il y à ce drame
d'ailleurs il y à des dysfonctionnements
dans la police dans la justice pour
appliquer toutes les mesures que vous
avez prises avec les différentes lois
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
c'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement en quatre ans votre quatre
lois pour protéger les femmes victimes
de violence c'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement multiplie par 60 %
augmentent de 60 %
nombre de places d'hébergement pour
accueillir ces femmes lorsqu'elles sont
victimes et qu'elles ont besoin de
quitter le foyer
c'est la première fois que nous mettons
les bracelets anti-rapprochement en
place depuis la fin de l'année 2020
c'est la première fois que nous
démultiplions les téléphones grave
danger c'est la première fois que nous
mettons en place des centres de prise en
charge des auteurs de violences jamais
nous n'avons autant fait maintenant deux
triomphes meilhon on part de loin
il faut savoir que culturellement c'est
la première fois que nous formons des
policiers et des gendarmes à la prise de
plainte des victimes de violence c'est
la première fois que nous formons des
procureurs et c'est la première fois que
tout
tous les ministères que ce soit
l'éducation que ce soit à l'intérieur la
justice etc
nous travaillons sur ce sujet ça fait
quatre mois que ces bracelets anti
rapprochement a été mis en place
j'ai parlé avec mon homologue espagnol
pour savoir comment le sujet s'est
développé en espagne
ils ont commencé en 2003 nous avons
commencé en 2010 est donc évidemment ça
prend trop de temps
chaque féminicide est une horreur et
c'est intolérable
mais il faut aussi accepter d'où nous
partons la volonté et la mobilisation de
ce gouvernement et je suis convaincu
qu'avec le travail important qui doit
être fait au ministère de l'intérieur
je rappelle quand même que les forces de
l'ordre sont les premiers remparts à ces
violences le travail que font les
magistrats et eric dupond moretti a
relancé
une demande aux magistrats et aux
parquets pour se saisir de ces questions
de manière prioritaire
eh bien je suis convaincu que nous
allons continuer de progresser mais pour
l'instant il ne faut pas relâcher les
efforts armand rapidement pour finir sur
les propositions vous a fait la
sénatrice les républicains valérie boyer
dans sa question
elle propose de déchoir du statut de
réfugié à toute personne qui serait
condamné pour violence conjugale est ce
que vous êtes pour
est ce que vous êtes pour également les
peines planchers pour le coude et des
délits de violence conjugale je ne peux
pas vous faire de réponse là dessus
parce que cesser ces demandes il
faudrait que je puisse les étudier ce
que je peux vous dire c'est qu'aucun
gouvernement n'a augmenté le budget du
ministère des femmes à hauteur de 40%
pour lutter contre ce fléau
donc il ya bien longtemps que nous avons
commencé à travailler dessus et nous
allons poursuivre nos efforts merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à mes questions
c'est à gotham merci beaucoup alexandre
pour cette première réaction est sur ce
plateau pour ceux des bribes des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir patrick
hannais re bonjour sénateur du nord et
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
face avoue valérie boyer dont on vient
de voir les sénatrices les républicains
des bouches-du-rhône et c'est vous qui
avait d'ailleurs interpellé tout à
l'heure la ministre à propos bien de ce
nouveau féminicide et c'est loin d'être
le premier qui a eu lieu donc à hayange
en moselle
quelle est votre réaction est bien à ce
que dit la ministre elisabeth moreno qui
fait un peu l'inventaire de tout ce qui
a été fait sous ce quinquennat mais elle
ne répond pas directement à ce que vous
demandez leur de votre question non
effectivement des choses ont été faites
et heureusement mais je rappelle que les
choses qui ont été faites
elle existe depuis très longtemps et si
on s'en tient au bracelet anti
rapprochement
sur les 76 prescrit donc à un budget de
1000 pour 1000 bracelet anti
rapprochement il y en a 76 par des
prescrits et seulement 44 hommes qui en
sont équipés donc c'est très beau être
des femmes aussi parce que les violences
conjugales
moi je préfère le terme violence
conjugale à féminicide parce que quand
on sait que c'est un conjoint qui tue
son conjoint et ça qu'on peut concerner
ça concerne majoritairement des femmes
qui sont agressés par des hommes mais ça
peut concerner des femmes avec des
femmes des amériques des hommes et des
femmes contre des hommes également cessé
chose à existe aussi et ça fait partie
des violences aussi
donc aujourd'hui bon madame la ministre
ne répond pas et je voudrais dire que
les deux jeunes femmes stéphanie et
shahinez serait encore en vie si leur
conjoint avait purgé leur peine
donc là la vraie difficulté c'est que
les peines qui sont prescrites
elles ne sont pas exécutés jusqu'au bout
y compris pour des hommes qui sont
violents en l'occurrence le meurtrier de
stéphane bohli c'est quand même un
réfugié qui sortait fraîchement de
prison de façon anticipée et qu'il y
avait déjà un très très très lourd
casier
donc à un moment donné voter des lois
c'est très bien même si je pense qu'il
faut aller plus loin
mais il faut aussi les appliquer or
aujourd'hui on n'applique pas les lois
que l'on vote
patrick kanner est ce que pour vous il
ya eu un dysfonctionnement des services
judiciaires
le procureur de metz le nid pour
l'instant mais je précise que les
ministres darmanin dupond moretti et
marine chapa annonce une inspection
autour de cette affaire et notamment que
les problèmes que soulève valérie boyer
une inspection de fera revenir les
femmes qui ont été tuées voir massacrer
je crois qu'il faut employer les mots
tels qu'ils existent moi j'en suis j'en
suis désolé c'est une situation qui est
insupportable 43 femmes sont mortes
depuis le début l'année malheureusement
d'autres des dizaines d'autres vont
malheureusement subir le même sort c'est
un problème de société moi je le place
pas sur un débat politicien
j'ai entendu mal à moreno dire qu'il ya
eu beaucoup de choses mises en place
mais le résultat c'est qu'il y a encore
dit
des féminicides et que donc s'attaquer
vie lire et à la fin d'un processus de
violence bien évidemment et et après on
peut diverger sur les solutions en la
matière mais ce que j'aimerais c'est
qu'on s'attaque aussi aux raisons y
compris culturelles peuvent amener un
homme a considéré que sa femme c'est un
objet dont il peut se séparer voire même
massacrer comme je l ai dit tout à
l'heure
donc la question de l'école de l'est du
respect de la femme à l'école
l'éducation finit finalement le vivre
ensemble en tant que tel se pose en
permanence et donc quelles que soient
les méthodes répressives qu'on pourrait
imaginer il faut savoir être fort et
savoir réprimer autant que de besoin des
hommes
violent ce que c'est essentiellement des
hommes on le sait bien le travail de
fond peut-être aussi menée et ça
là-dessus il n'y a pas de réflexion un
tout dernièrement il ajouté et on jette
cette fois ci la cohérence dans les
messages on peut pas à la fois dire que
c'est la grande cause du quinquennat et
supporté que pour représenter l'équipe
de france de foot on choisisse une
personne un artiste paraît-il qui chante
des appels aux agressions sexuelles de
deux personnalités politiques et qui
aussi clame son désamour de la france
un moment donné je pense qu'il faut être
cohérent d'un côté on nous fait voter la
loi sur le séparatisme et de l'autre
côté en même temps pour reprendre
malheureusement cet aphorisme et bien en
même temps et bien on met en avant
quelqu'un qui prône le non au racisme
donc il n'ya pas de cohérence au sein de
ce gouvernement et quant à la ministre
des sports quand elle fait aussi la
promotion du budget de running c'est
contre les valeurs de liberté d'égalité
de fraternité donc il faut il faut
savoir jusqu'où on va dans ce
gouvernement et on ne le serait pas la
fatalité c'est aussi la tolérance mais
oui mais pas la différenciation entre
les hommes et les femmes allez on va
tout de suite parti la revalorisation
elle des conséquences et vous mais voilà
on va pas réussir salle des conférences
rejoindra les que ça alexandre pousse à
vous êtes avec sale rat est lahiri
secrétaire d'état chargée de la jeunesse
et de l'engagement qui on va notamment
parlé mais un petit peu de l'offensive
politique des manuels macro à tous ces
messages qui ont été adressés aussi aux
jeunes
ces derniers jours on va en parler tam
on va parler de mcfly et carlito mais
avant cela je voudrais aborder un sujet
un petit peu plus grave on évoquait les
violences faites aux femmes
je voudrais aborder la question des
violences entre jeunes puisque sa ré
l'aeri les règlements de comptes entre
jeunes se multiplient avec des drames
dans les journaux avec des faits divers
chaque semaine comment on fait pour
lutter contre cette banalisation de la
violence chez les jeunes que peut faire
le gouvernement
déjà il ne faut pas accepter cette
banalisation de la
violence il y a aujourd'hui une
situation de dix paires violence dans
notre société et elle touche des jeunes
et même des très très jeune voir des
enfants
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
créer un bouclier un bouclier qui ans
qui engagés qui en a qui accompagnent
les parents d'abord le premier lieu de
l'éducation c'est le foyer familial
ensuite bien sûr plus de travail avec la
police la justice bien sûr mais
également l'éducation nationale c'est
pour ça que nos ministères travaillent
ensemble dans le cadre diplômant par
exemple de contrats de sécurité
intérieure ou encore recteur recteurs et
préfets qui se réunissent aujourd'hui
pour apporter des réponses spécifiques
mais attention il est nécessaire
d'accompagner aussi les jeunes sur les
nouvelles plateformes sur les réseaux
sociaux est engagée pour moi je crois un
travail beaucoup plus intense intense
avec les associations qui accompagnent à
l'apprentissage de ces nouveaux outils
est également un engagement plus fort
aujourd'hui des réseaux sociaux nous
parler des réseaux sociaux c'est
compliqué de lutter contre une forme de
culture de la violence qui peut se
développer sur les réseaux sociaux
je crois que il faut déjà donné les
moyens aux jeunes et là c'est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui au sein de l'école avec
la mobilisation des associations et des
enseignants pour expliquer à quel point
c'est important et à quel point par
exemple le cyber harcèlement a des
conséquences dans la vraie vie
à quel point qu'en mai une information
elle a des conséquences dans la vie
réelle
mais aujourd'hui les plateformes les
réseaux sociaux moi je crois doivent
s'engager plus fortement encore une
mobilisation avec des modérateurs
avec plus d'action directe et rapide un
mot sur le pass culture ça fait l'objet
d'une question d'actualité une question
d'actualité cet après midi de janvier
mon hugonnet alors concrètement le pass
culture pour l'instant va être
généralisée à tous les jeunes de 18 ans
avec un chèque de 300 euros pour accéder
aux contenus culturels
mais vous avez hockey et bien une
ouverture aux jeunes aux collégiens à
partir de la quatrième en quoi ça va
consister très concrètement c'est un
succès ce pass culture ça permet à tous
les jeunes de 18 ans d'avoir 300 euros
simplement téléchargeant une application
gratuite sur leur téléphone portable ou
sur leurs tablettes ou sur leur
smartphone
ça a été lancé par le président de la
république est juste depuis que ça a été
téléchargée c'est devenu la première
application la plus téléchargée en
france très simple du tout senti que mes
premières applications téléchargées en
france et d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'on a
tous envie évidemment de retrouver
les concerts les cinémas les terrasses
et 80% des dépenses qui ont été déjà été
engagés c'est pour l'achat par exemple
d'un livre on peut acheter un livre ont
une place de cinéma une place de concert
mais aussi un instrument de musique
franchement c'est une chance pour notre
jeunesse aujourd'hui là où il faut
reprendre parce que c'est accompagné par
le ministère de la culture
roselyne bachelot et par également
l'engagement fort de mon ministère
avec jean michel blanquer nous
souhaitons accompagner ces pass culture
dès le plus jeune âge pour une sorte
d'éducation aux activités culturelles et
artistiques et donc dès la 4e il y aura
entre la 4e et la terminale
un budget supplémentaire de 200 euros
qui sera disponible sur cette
application permettant des projets
collectifs d'abord et ensuite plus
individuelle à la terminale l'idée est
simple c'est qu'un jeune entre la 4ème
et ses dix huit ans se retrouve avec 500
euros 2 500 euros de dépenses
culturelles lui permettant d'accéder à
ce qui permet de plus d'émanciper ont
fini par évoquer à la fameuse vidéo
entre le prix dans la république
emmanuel macron et les youtuber à succès
mcfly et carlito une vidéo qui s'est
tournée à l'elysée avec le concours
d'anecdotes c'est le jeu de ses tubes
heures donc le président la république a
pu parler foot musicale africaine il a
pu parler de métal c'est un exercice de
communication certains disent que ça
désacralise un peu la fonction
présidentielle
le président de la république c'est le
président de tous les français et
aujourd'hui
mais comme depuis 2010 est le présence
d'un public parle évidemment aux jeunes
et à tous les jeunes là où ils sont on
sait très bien que les jeunes ne regarde
non de moins en moins voire plus du tout
les canaux traditionnels les médias
traditionnels
parce que c'est le présent de la
république et qu'il parano jeunesse est
bien et il parle à hugo travers à brut à
tik tok mais également à may cry carlito
je crois que le plus important c'est
évidemment de parler à l'ensemble des
français là où ils sont aux jeunes bien
sûr parce que c'est la force et la
richesse de notre pays
il n'y a aucune des sacralités la
réalité c'est que le président de la
république regarde tous les français et
parle à tous les français là où ils sont
et aux jeunes par le biais d'une
promesse fait écho à une promesse est
faite elle est tenu et c'est d'autant
plus utile de parler aux jeunes à un an
de l'élection présidentielle merci
beaucoup
sarr et les rides avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci merci beaucoup alexandre oui
effectivement patrick canac est ce que
ça vous inspire cette offensive
vis-à-vis des jeunes des manuels macro
outre cette vidéo qui a tant fait parler
ce week-end il leur a donné la priorité
dans des déplacements et notamment en
annonçant le pass culture vous l'ancien
ministre de la ville de la jeunesse et
des sports la ministre vient de faire un
aveu terrible la prison de république
parle aux jeunes j'aimerais mieux qu'ils
agissent à ce qu'aujourd'hui notre
jeunesse est en grande difficulté je
voudrais quand même vous rappeler les
chiffres
donc on a un jeune sur six qui a arrêté
ses études depuis la crise sanitaire 22
% des jeunes sont aujourd'hui au chômage
une augmentation de 16 % en un an
vous savez que beaucoup de jeunes
fréquentent malheureusement ce que moi
j'appelle jetez pas péjoratif les soupes
populaires oui et je remercie monde
caritatif qui sont un peu beaucoup de
cette population donc la situation de la
jeunesse c'est quand même assez
dramatique aujourd'hui nous avons
proposé des solutions
on partage pas ma collègue valérie boyer
mais très concrètement pendant cette
période de crise qu'on a proposé que les
jeunes puissent avoir accès à haut
niveau des adultes mais en tout cas
quand on a 18 ans à 25 ans aujourd'hui
on ne doit pas être amenés à les
fréquenter les actions caritatives c'est
un vrai problème pour notre société
alors qu'il était bien pour vous si avec
ce qu'il annonce le passé à des clubs de
sport je prends naturellement mais c'est
pas l'essentiel aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui excusez moi il ya des jeunes
qui crèvent de faim qui crèvent
d'isolement et la réponse n'est pas à la
hauteur et donc les les éléments de
langage de la ministre sont sympathiques
elle les a bien ressasser manifestement
mais la détresse des jeunes ne sera pas
traitée l'axé la culture bien évidemment
c'est un c'est un plus mais c'est
souvent un plus pour ceux qui sont déjà
sauvés de la faire et moi je pense à ces
millions de jeunes qui aujourd'hui sont
les premières victimes de la crise
sanitaire
lr et boye on sent qu emmanuel macron il
veut aussi capitaliser sur ce moment on
on souffle un peu houleux terrasse se
rouvrent où les français pour y gagner
en optimisme on sent que c'est un
président en campagne dans dans cette
séquence oui peut-être
moi ce qui me ce qui me gêne je partage
le constat de mon collègue
keller monsieur le ministre ce qui me
gêne c'est que au moment
oui regardez des roulades sur l'herbe de
l'elysée et qui le relever des défis
fait référence à la vidéo
le défi de la pauvreté
le défi de l'isolément le défi des
études le défi de l'avenir
est ce qu'ils les relève est tout
simplement le défi de la vie parce qu'au
même moment il revient quand même
marjorie qui était assassiné à ivry et
matteo à champigny moi ce qui m'a choqué
aussi c'est le pari de mettre une photo
de youtube heures comme s'ils le
j'allais dire l'objectif du président de
la république c'était de faire 10 view
des likes et quand même tragique
j'aurais préféré que il met pour le 14
juillet des photos des héros que nous
avons de nos forces de l'ordre des
militaires qui sont engagés jaurès à
sains vrai défi celui de la sécurité des
français
j'aurais préféré qu'ils relèvent le défi
aussi des victimes
tout à l'heure on a parlé des violences
conjugales ces femmes qui sont mortes
alors que leurs conjoints devraient être
en prison encore et qu'ils sont sortis
prématurément ça ce sont des défis le
défi c'est pas de faire des vues sur
youtube et ce n'est pas non plus de
réduire la jeunesse à ça surtout pour un
homme qui a tout eu en termes
d'éducation il a fait les meilleures
écoles eu les leçons de piano il a fait
du théâtre nous at-on dit etc
et c'est ça qui trouve comme des filles
c'est ça le père de la nation en tout
cas ce qu'il relève
je trouve ça triste et sa caricature les
jeunes les attentes des jeunes ce sont
celles que monsieur kaner à l'écrit ce
sont aussi celles ce sont aussi celles
là il faut pas non plus caricaturer la
jeunesse sur cette vidéo sans vie 10
rebonds les communications changent avec
le temps je me souviens du de branches
et de 2,2 mitterrand mais c'était devant
le cab h de mémoire et oui c'est
mitterrand et ses militants mais en là
il s'est prêté à un jeu
bon moi qui me choque pas outre mesure
mais qui me paraît tellement décalé par
sl aux préoccupations qu'on évoque c'est
inadapté pour vous vu le
le contexte une offensive tous azimuts
aussi le grand entretien aujourd'hui
dans la revue zadig d' emmanuel macron
qui pour le coup et c'est de se montrer
comme aussi un homme ancré dans les
territoires quand on l'a beaucoup de
technique mais ça a été dit il est en
campagne
oui donc voilà il a toujours vous dira
jamais cessé de l'être il faut des faits
voilà il faut dire les choses telles
telles qu'elles sont simplement je pense
qu'il faut pas prendre en otage toute
une partie de la population qui
aujourd'hui est en grande souffrance et
je crois que le sérieux de la réponse
aurait été plus adapté que finalement le
fun liés à cette vidéo même si je savais
que pour regarder c'est déjà chaud je
respecte mais le regarder cette vidéo ne
ramènera pas à manger excusez moi dans
l'assiette
elle amènera pas à manger dans
l'assiette c'est donc inadapté pour vous
un mot est bien sûr aussi la violence
dont on a pu parler tout à l'heure qui
est de plus en plus présente chez les
jeunes est notamment lié bien aux
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui notre
société devient de plus en plus violent
pas que la jeunesse qui ait pas de
malentendus et aujourd'hui on voit bien
que le manque de repères et je reviens
la question l'éducation fait que au
travers des réseaux que d'autres
collègues appellent à sociaux et a
parfois à juste titre est bien la
violence d'une ya une forme de réponse
sociétale et faisons très attention à
cette évolution qui lui je crois peut
nous inquiéter tous collectivement
valeria père et c'est vrai qu'il ya à la
fois un manque de repères mais on peut
pas donner quand même comme horizon des
roulades dans la pelouse de l'elysée je
crois qu'après notre république doit
incarner autre chose et c'est pour ça
que c'est à la fois décalé et
inapproprié et puis je pense que ces cas
le
le rôle des parents qu'il faut remettre
au centre du dispositif dans tous les
défis qu'on a relevé pour les jeunes en
les aidant plus mal et respect en les
responsabilisant plus également elle est
une autre thématique est largement
marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement est bien la
polémique autour de gérald darmanin et
de audrey pulvar avec cette plainte que
gérald darmanin voulait déposer
vis-à-vis d'audrey pulvar à cause de ce
qu'elle avait pu dire des policiers je
vous propose d'écouter dans la réplique
ce qu'a pu dire david assouline qui a
interpellé le gouvernement à ce sujet je
vous ai demandé solennellement de nous
dire ce qui vous a autorisé à tenter
d'intimider une candidate vous qui au
contraire a mené la charge de protéger
la parole libre et démocratique de
madame pulvar comme de toutes celles et
de tous ceux qui concourent aux
élections pourquoi avoir créé une
polémique de plus alors que votre rôle
est de garantir le débat apaisé dont
notre démocratie a besoin plus que
jamais ce que nous demandons nous
parlementaires c'est que vous commenciez
vous pas respecté notre état de droit et
la séparation des pouvoirs exécutif
législatif et judiciaire je pense qu'il
a raté si on va te suit rejoindre la
salle des conférences pour une réaction
celle de françois patriat et il est à
votre micro alexandre c'est le président
du groupe r des pays le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle ici au sénat
effectivement thamond précise que gérald
darmanin n'approuve n'a pas vraiment
répondu à la question de david assouline
s'il allait retirer sa plainte envers
audrey pulvar
le ministre l'intérieur évoqué leur
rencontre leur rendez-vous qu'il qu'il a
donné en tout cas audrey pulvar françois
patriat est ce que le nist de
l'intérieur le miz élection doit retirer
sa plainte envers cette candidate aux
élections régionales
mais d'abord je trouve que cet
épiphénomène de la campagne électorale
qui n'ont rien à voir avec mérite t'il
une question d'actualité
moi je ne le pense pas il ya ceux qui
essayent de faire le buzz tous les jours
david en l'occurrence david assouline
soit être monté en épingle dramatiser la
situation
juste au moment où le ministre
dédramatise dédramatise et apaise le
débat plutôt d'apaiser le débat au
moment où la violence est partout autour
de nous certains continuent et vouloir
la nuit le ministre a dit qu'il croit
qu'il n'a pas déposé la plainte qu'elle
ait pas été posée et je pense que à
l'issue de la rencontre avec audrey
pulvar où elle aurait pu dire j'espère
exactement ce qu'elle pense de la police
et parce que j'ai vu ou entendu par
ailleurs parce que j'ai lu las en
marchant sur la l'assemblée le ministre
dans son rôle
les policiers sont dix femmes et ils le
défendent il les soutient les défend pas
il est soutien ils manifestent pas avec
il va les rencontrer pour entendre leurs
doléances
il n'accepte pas le fait que l'on
compare condamne la justice à côté donc
ce que je crois c'est que cette affaire
donc on ne l'entendra plus et que le
ministre n'aura pas déposé sa salle sa
plainte et qu' ils se sont rencontrés
avec audrey pulvar est la compagne
continuera donc il ne faut pas qu'il
dépose sa plainte je vous rappelle je
pense alors un mot quand même sur
justement parce que fait gérald darmanin
ces dernières semaines avec quand même
beaucoup d'agitation vous évoquez la
manifestation à laquelle il a participé
la semaine dernière il ya cette plainte
auprès d'audrey pulvar est ce que
justement ce n'est pas le ministre de
l'intérieur qui crée ce buzz qui crée
toute cette agitation autour de ce thème
de la sécurité
non c'est l'actualité gris l'agitation
s'est pas laissée par le ministre le
ministre est dans son rôle et dans sa
fonction et les seuils de réagir au
mieux c'est la chair des policiers tués
un avignon c'est la faire
des deux personnes tuées par le patron
c'est laisser la sphère de chemini side
qui sont là aujourd'hui qui comme
d'habitude arrive en paquet et en haut
pour aujourd'hui qui fait qu'il ya ya
pas la ressentir violence une violence
c'est vrai ni violence qui s'exerce
est-ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui plus de
policiers tués 84 ans je ne pense pas
d'ailleurs par là mais non c'est pas
cette actualité que le ministre est là
parce que les parce que les policiers
ont raison d'être inquiet quand ils
disent on est payé pour protéger pas
pour rapport pour mourir non qu'il est
là pour mener donc à un moment où ses
soldats de la république sont les
policiers les gendarmes et pompiers
tchèques leur a besoin d'être soutenu il
le fait avec
avec son ton avec sa méthode ça peut
déranger quelques-uns mais en
l'occurrence il est dans son dans son
rôle bientôt un peu là nicolas sarkozy à
une hyper primant et présence médiatique
vous aimez ce ton social ans je trouve
que le terme est beaucoup plus posé et
les mots beaucoup plus choisis et une
dernière question sur le fait quand même
de légiférer à chaque fait divers on a
l'impression que à chaque fait divers il
annonce une loi est ce que c'est pas
dangereux pour la démocratie
je pense qu'il y a dans les lois que
nous examinons aujourd'hui au parlement
un paquet de lois qui concerne la
sécurité
elles me paraissent aujourd'hui
nécessaire je pense qu'ils ont fait
aujourd'hui notamment dans séparatisme
qui sont faits les lois aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il faut profiter du débat de
ses doigts qui n'est pas terminée que
terminera à l'automne
certaines pour justement de d'en ajuster
le prodiss le processus de processus de
protection et de punitions dans ces
domaines-là faire notre loi chaque jour
je suis d'accord avec vous chers une loi
firent une loi à chaque fait divers
ça n'a jamais fait vraiment avancer les
choses merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
françois patriat d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup alexandre on va parler un
petit peu de cette hyper ministre de
l'intérieur patrick kanner gérald
darmanin son offensive sur la candidate
de la gauche audrey pulvar aux
régionales en île de france est presque
du pain béni pour vous ça a permis de
rassembler ça a presque permis de
relancer sa campagne aux régionales
c'est un effet contre-productif pour le
ministre de l'intérieur vous savez je
rentre pas dans cette logique purement
politiciennes mois
je regrette c'est camille de l'intérieur
puisse se permettre ce type de dérapage
parce que d'abord sa présence dans la
dans la fameuse manifestation me paraît
c'est vraiment très problématique les
manifestations de la semaine dernière
devant l'assemblée nationale pour
paraphraser un livre célèbre j'irai je
suis pas sûr que ce soit qu'un ministre
puisse dire et faire cela il doit être
au dessus de la mêlée il doit pas être
dans la mêlée surtout que des propos ont
été tenus dans cette manifestation que
je conteste notamment sur la place de la
justice dans notre de notre laxisme ne
doit pas être le vecteur des plus
extrêmes de ceux des troupes
il a la responsabilité de 250 mille
fonctionnaires de police et gendarmes
c'est énorme
il a été chef de cabinet dans un
gouvernement qui a réduit de 13 mille
postes le nombre de
gendarmes et de policiers dans ce pays
aujourd'hui monsieur
darmanin passé est-ce qu'il a un passif
il est le troisième locataire de beauvau
il doit apaiser les choses chez moi j'ai
travaillé j'ai eu la chance l'honneur de
travailler avec un ministre comme
bernard cazeneuve mise de l'intérieur
sont ils très grands sujets et une
époque terrible pour la france au moment
de l'attentât
attentat terroriste dans laquelle
mobiliser mes amis de l'intérieur doit
peser chaque mot avant de s'exprimer
et là on a l'impression que monsieur da
manha sort son compte twitter comment
sur un flingue pour balancer comme cela
des des propos qu'il remet en cause lui
même quelques jours après donc la
question de la crédibilité de la parole
publique se pose aujourd'hui avec
monsieur gérald darmanin trop de baisse
de la part de gérald darmanin pour vous
valérie boyer et puis que penser de 2,2
et bien de cette plainte qu'il a annoncé
déposé que finalement à priori il ne
devrait pas déposer ce que ça mélange la
politique et le judiciaire
d'abord le ministre de l'intérieur la
manifestation des policiers pour
manifester contre lui même et se
désolidariser de son collègue de la
justice qui est quand même totalement
aberrant alors qu'on sait que le
problème c'est le continuum police
justice bon c'est plus attention et
pénitentiaires pénitentiaire un échec
total et une promesse non tenue pourtant
emmanuel macron il n'a pas fait beaucoup
de promesses pendant la campagne mais
l'avait fait celle-ci la tient par a
donc qui ne sont pas construites elles
sont tellement pas construite que madame
belloubet avait sorti quand même 17 % de
la population carcérale au motif qu'ils
n'avaient pas de place et qui risquez
d'attraper le coville c'est quand même
énorme comme sujet et je rappelle quand
même que ces deux femmes leur conjoint
serait toujours en prison comme la
justice les avait condamnés elle sera
encore vivante
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point monsieur darmanin fait ce qu'il
sait faire de mieux c'est à dire
relancer la campagne de madame pulvar
donc voilà maintenant aujourd'hui il
relance d'un côté la campagne de marine
le pen de l'autre il relance sa campagne
de madame pulvar c'est le ministre des
élections effectivement puisque de toute
façon même les élections sont faites en
conseil des ministres ce concert on se
préoccupe des listes ont construit
au mr c'est au niveau des enjeux à
monsieur darmanin je rappelle quand même
de ma région ministre de l'intérieur il
est candidat aux élections
départementales sur tourcoing candidats
aux élections
oui départementale ce sont les cinq
ministres qui vont au combat dans ma
région il ya dix autres dans d'autres
régions
très honnêtement je pense qu'aujourd'hui
le ministre devrait être complètement à
sa tâche le pays a besoin d'amis de
l'intérieur encore une fois apaisés
apaisants capable de comprendre des
préoccupations des français sont
fatigués avec le fait d'être candidat
pour nom nous mots j'ai été candidat aux
élections départementales que communiste
simplement il est ministre de
l'intérieur et donc il ne doit pas
montrer le mauvais exemple
il est en train de montrer l'exemple et
j'ai bien entendu comme dans les propos
de monsieur patriat notre collègue
président du groupe
l'arrêt mer des pays au sein du samaa
risque manifestement il était un petit
peu gêné par la situation elle est on va
terminer sur un bien dernier flammes
ce thème est celui de l'irresponsabilité
pénale
deux textes ont été adoptés hier au
sénat sur ce sujet nathalie goulet
auteur de l'une des propositions de loi
d'ailleurs interrogé le gouvernement sur
ce thème steve en vous retrouve dans
l'hémicycle du sénat pour nous parler
bien de ce moment de la séance
ouais l'émotion est toujours là après
que le meurtrier de sa halimi a été
considérée comme pénalement
irresponsable on s'en souvient emmanuel
macron avait promis une réforme du code
pénal le sénat vous l'avez dit i'm a
adopté ici même hier soir sa propre
réforme du code pénal son propre texte
mais ce texte ne convient pas vraiment
au gouvernement du coup et bien nathalie
goulet à l'origine de ce texte avait une
question à poser au ministre de la
justice monsieur le ministre la question
que je vous pose c'est mon et vous de la
mise en place du système de remplacement
de la collecte et du suivi des
personnes irresponsables comment
comptez-vous censé donner assurer la
sécurité des français
la situation des personnes
irresponsables au pénal c'est une
situation qui ne relèvent pas du
ministère de la justice selon eric
dupond moretti c'est une situation qui
relève du ministère de la santé
écoutez leur raconter dumont a nommé
déclaré irresponsable
il n'est pas détenu madame il est soigné
pour le reste la décision du 14 avril
nous a beaucoup émus certains nos
compatriotes n'ont pas compris cette
décision c'est une décision qui a été
rendue en droit et les juges ont pris
soin de préciser en réalité qu'il ne
pouvait pas distinguer là où la loi ne
le permettait pas j'ai souhaité
soumettre ce texte à l'avis du conseil
d'état
une réforme du code pénal qui est très
attendu très très attendue par les
familles des victimes une réforme qui
est aussi il faut le lire politiquement
et juridiquement très complexe très
sensible il faudra donc comme le dit le
ministre de la justice garde un oeil sur
cet avis que le conseil d'état doit
rendre dans les jours qui viennent
merci merci beaucoup stif pour toutes
ces explications valais les voyez donc
ses textes ses propositions de loi ont
été adoptés hier au sénat textes qui
sont beaucoup plus prudents qu est-ce qu
avec ce que ce qui avait été proposé au
départ et qui demandait vraiment une
modification du code pénal on voit qu'il
est nécessaire de légiférer après
laffaire sara lee mi mai avec précaution
bien sûr toute façon c'est une demande
de la population mais c'est aussi une
demande de la justice puisque les juges
l'avait précisé dans leur jugement
et cette incompréhension elle est tout à
fait enfin je la partage et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le sénat s'est
emparé du sujet maintenant on aimerait
quand même connaître le gouvernement
s'en empare aussi enfin la hausse il a
dénoncé un projet de loi qui est dit
après domaine je rappelle quand même
réalisé aux parlementaires de légiférer
au cas où ça échapperait à certains il a
prévu un projet de loi eric dupond
moretti
il indique qu'il est devant le conseil
d'état
eric dupond moretti qui d'ailleurs
explique que son texte pourrait limiter
les responsabilités pénales lorsque
l'abolition du discernement résulte
d'une intoxication volontaire
on sent qu'il veut mettre peut-être
d'ailleurs il a été hésitant sur l'un
des amendements que qu'à proposer
d'autres collègues jean pierre sueur
justement pour évoquer cette notion de
discernement et surtout faire que
l'irresponsabilité ne soit pas
automatique
ce que demande la famille de madame
halimi qui était l'objet d'un crime
abominable
c'est de pouvoir finalement faire son
deuil
oui faire son deuil aboutir à un procès
juste et équitable
une reconnaissance y la chambre la
chambre d'instruction a fait son travail
sept ou huit heures de débats qui ont
abouti à l'irresponsabilité pénale de
monsieur traoré je considère aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas suffisant et le sénat a
fait son travail en proposant une loi
qui peut-être n'est pas parfaite nous
dit monsieur dupont moretti
mais qu'il avance il dit que c'est un
texte au conseil d'état très bien on le
croit sur sur parole mais il faut aller
vite
ce qui est arrivé dans cette affaire
montre que notre code pénal aujourd'hui
comporte un article qui est le sens
vannes 2-1
il ne sera pas modifié et on a eu des
débats au sein de la commission des lois
sur le sujet il ne lâche pas les fous ne
juge pas les fous et il n'a pas été
modifié et c'est tant mieux mais en
amont la question du discernement doit
être traité beaucoup plus une manière
sérieuse qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
dans le code du prochain open
pour conclure sur un amendement que vous
également présenté qui a été adoptée
autour du syndrome de la femme battue en
quoi consiste-t-il exactement valérie
boyer on en vit un petit peu à ce qu'on
évoquait au début de ce débat et c'est à
dire la question des féminicides oui la
question des violences conjugales
effectivement se poser moi je me réjouis
que mes collègues et voté cet amendement
contre la vie malheureusement du
gouvernement c'est un amendement que je
porte depuis bien longtemps depuis
plusieurs années je l'avait porté à
l'assemblée nationale et puis
aujourd'hui au sénat qui permet de
reconnaître le syndrome de la femme
battue le syndrome de la femme battue a
été reconnue dans une affaire valérie
bako où l'expert psychiatre a précisé
que valérie bako qui est défendu par
maître nathalie tommasini avec laquelle
j'ai travaillé justement sur cette
question et bien avait son jugement qui
était altéré parce qu'elle était mise en
danger de mort permanent qu'elle était
en fait soumises à une autoroute urbaine
puis des années parce que c'est une
véritable torture mentale et physique
qu'a subie valérie back home et que
subissent aussi d'autres femmes
et qu'est ce qui se passe dans la
plupart des cas c'est que le niveau de
violence est elle pour ces personnes ces
femmes en général mais ça peut exister
aussi pour d'autres sexe pour il est tel
que généralement cette violence se
retourne contre elle souvent elle se
suicide où elle tombe malade ou elle
abandonne est là valérie bako s'est
retourné contre son bourreau et l'a donc
ce que démontre le syndrome de la femme
battue qui existe depuis 1990 au canada
c'est que le jugement de la personne
peut être altérée du fait des violences
du stress de la mise en danger
permanente la mise en danger de mort
permanente dont cette femme est victime
et moi je me réjouis que c était voté je
pense que c'est une grande avancée sur
la question des violences conjugales et
je regrette vraiment que le gouvernement
est née poule n'est pas approuvé cette
demande qui existe depuis longtemps et
qui est porté par beaucoup
d'associations et qui a fait ses preuves
aussi à l'étranger on parle du bracelet
électronique espagnol
là c'est le syndrome de la femme battue
canadien qui peut totalement être
transposée dans notre droit pour des cas
exceptionnels s'est en aucun cas permis
de tuer mais c'est c'est prendre en
compte la souffrance
de ses victimes qui sont victimes avant
d'être bourreau merci merci beaucoup et
valérie bako qui je le rappelle donc à
publier un livre récemment cette femme
qui a donc tué son mari après avoir été
violée par battut et prostituée par son
compagnon qui était même auparavant
le compagnon de sa mère merci beaucoup
d'avoir assisté et bien à ce débris feu
mon dernier débrief pour cette saison je
m'absente quelques mois l'excellent
alexandre poussa pendant toute cette
période merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à mon dernier débrief
pour cette saison tout de suite bien
j'en parlais à l'instant on va revenir à
la séance d'hier autour de ses
propositions de loi adopté par le sénat
sur l'irresponsabilité pénale
la décision de la convocation du 14
avril 2021 qui a confirmé
l'irresponsabilité pénale du meurtrier
de madame sarah halimi attal n'a pas été
comprise elle a suscité une très forte
et très légitime émotion
les pouvoirs publics doivent y répondre
sur la base d'une analyse claire et
partagée
les améliorations souhaitables est
possible de notre droit à cet égard deux
éléments doivent d'emblée me semble-t-il
être soulignée d'une part l'abolition du
discernement d'un auteur d'un homicide
peut aujourd'hui résulter de son
intoxication volontaire notamment après
avoir absorbé des substances
stupéfiantes et d'autre part la haute
juridiction de l'ordre judiciaire n'a
fait qu'appliquer dans ce dossier
douloureux le le droite actuelle en
faisant le constat par les mots de son
avocat général que les dispositions de
l'article 122
tirer un alinéa 1er du code pénal ne
distingue pas selon l'origine du trouble
psychique ayant conduit à l'abolition de
cheveux lissés rnement et je voudrais
même la rapporteure me joindre à votre
hommage
madame l'avocat général zandt a
effectivement effectué un travail
absolument remarquable et je ne peux
qu'inviter comme vous d'ailleurs tout le
monde à lire ce ce texte parce qu'il est
d'une grande précision il est
extrêmement intéressant et il est
éclairant sur la position de notre droit
le moment me semble venu de faire
évoluer notre droit comme la cour de
cassation et invite d'ailleurs elle même
le législateur est en effet si si je
l'avais indiqué ma prédécesseure ici
même lors d'un débat organisé à
l'initiative de votre goût madame la
rapporteure il était nécessaire
d'attendre l'énoncé de la cour de
cassation
celle ci a désormais dit les choses
clairement le juge ne peut distinguer là
où le législateur ne le fait pas
comme je lai annoncé quelques semaines
et à la suite de la prise de parole du
président de la république j'ai mené une
large consultation sur la modification
du régime de l'irresponsabilité j'ai
reçu les représentants des cultes des
magistrats des experts psychiatres des
professeurs de droit
il s'agit d'un sujet éminemment
complexes et vous même madame la
rapporteur avait pu évoluer dans votre
appréhension de la réponse à y apporter
dans un sens que je salue d'ailleurs de
ses consultations et des avis qui en
sont issus je vous rejoins sur un pont
de l'article 122-1 du code pénal ne doit
pas être modifié
article fondamental de notre droit
positif
il est et doit rester le garant du
principe essentielle posée par l'article
121-3 du code pénal il nie
à point de crime ou de délit sans
intention de le commettre
dans notre pays comme dans toutes les
démocraties dignes de ce nom on ne juge
pas les fous et revenir sur ce principe
serait une régression insupportable une
ligne rouge qui ne doit pas et bien sûr
ne sera pas franchie cette cause
traditionnel d'irresponsabilité pénale
répond pas une existence juridique
constitutionnelles et conventionnelles
qui est essentiel dans tout état de
droit respectueux des libertés
individuelles et de la personne humaine
et qu'il n'est nullement question de
remettre en cause
je le dis et je le redis il n'est pas
envisageable de condamner une personne
pour un acte commis alors qu'elles ne
disposaient pas de sens libre arbitre
nous débat nous permettront néanmoins
d'échangés sur le contenu de l'article
premier de votre texte qui propose
l'organisation systématique d'un débat
devant la juridiction de jugement
lorsque l'abolition temporaire du
discernement de la personne mise en
cause résulte au moins partiellement de
son fait fautif mais du fait de la
sensibilité toute particulière du sujet
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui il me semble
indispensable de bénéficier des
éclairages du conseil d'état j'ai donc
souhaité disposer de son avis éclairé
avant toute modification éventuelle du
régime d'irresponsabilité pénale et
c'est pourquoi comme je m'y étais engagé
le gouvernement vient de soumettre à
l'examen du conseil d'état un projet de
loi qui permettra de limiter les
responsabilités pénales lorsque
l'abolition du discernement résulte
d'une intoxication volontaire
vous comprendrez donc dans la tente de
l'avis du conseil d'état je me borne
aujourd'hui aux quelques observations
suivantes sur le texte proposé par votre
commission
je tiens d'abord à saluer l'important
travail qu'elle a réalisé et les
modifications apportées au projet
initial
nous nous rejoignons désormais pour
considérer qu'il ne faut pas modifier
les règles posées par l'article 122-1 du
code pénal et maintenir les
responsabilités pénales en cas de
disparition de libre arbitre
mais pourquoi alors comme le propose la
proposition de loi saisir la juridiction
de jugement et notamment la cour
d'assises est ce pour permettre aux
jurés d'écarter l'article 122-1 parce
qu'ils estimeraient que le discernement
de la personne était simplement altéré
et non aboli mais si les experts et le
juge d'instruction ont conclu à
l'absence de doute sur l'abolition du
discernement se rangent war ne me semble
pas justifiée est ce pour permettre aux
jurés de considérer que les dispositions
de l'article 122-1 ne devrait pas
s'appliquer au motif que la disparition
du libre arbitre résulte d'une
consommation illicite et donc fautif de
stupéfiants mais il faudrait alors que
cette exception chouette explicitement
prévu par la loi
je pars ailleurs très réservé sur les
dispositions de l'article 2 de cette
proposition de loi qui insère une
disposition générale d'aggravation des
peines en cas d'infractions commises en
état d'ivresse manifeste ou selon au
soul empire manifeste de stupéfiants
cette aggravation existe déjà bon nombre
qu'un comme les violences le violon et
agression sexuelle elle pourrait sans
doute être prévus pour d'autres
infractions comme le meurtre mais la
généralisation souhaité ne va-t-elle pas
à l'encontre de l'objectif souhaité en
bas
lisant pour toutes les infractions même
les moins graves les consommations de
substances psychotropes
s'agissant des dispositions des articles
3 à 9 de la proposition de loi relative
aux expertises
elle résulte d'un important travail des
sénateurs jean seul et jean yves roux
que je tiens ici à saluer
après analyse certaines ne me semble pas
enlevé de la loi et peuvent susciter des
interrogations
s'il est évident qu'une expertise
psychiatrique doit intervenir aussi
rapidement que possible
faut-il impérativement prévoir sa
réalisation dans les deux mois du
placement en détention provisoire de la
personne car si ce délai n'est pas
respecté
quelles en sont les conséquences la
nullité de l'expertisé réalisée au-delà
de ce délai
l'impossibilité de procéder hors délai à
cette expertise
et si la personne est arrêtée que
plusieurs ont avoir plusieurs années
après les faits ce délai de deux mois at
il encore le sens
s'agissant des dispositions de l'article
10 relatif aux obligations
déontologiques des experts je tiens à
préciser qu'elle rejoigne pleinement les
projets d'amélioration sur lesquels j'ai
demandé aux services de la chancellerie
de travail
il importe en effet d'éviter des
conflits d'intérêts lorsqu'une personne
est chargé d'une expertise
cette question dépasse évidemment la
seule hypothèse d expertise
psychiatrique
l'expert doit donc faire connaître ses
activités professionnelles ou bénévoles
ainsi que ses fonctions ou mandats
électifs passés ou en cours susceptible
de faire naître un conflit d'intérêts
mais il ne me semble pas pertinent comme
le propose cet article d'imposer à
l'expert des déclarations avant chacune
de ces expertises
pas plus qu'on ne demande une
déclaration d'intérêts aux magistrats
vont chaque décision ou parlementaire
avant chaque
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs comme
le texte précédent sur les sortants de
prison
nous travaillons sur des projets
parallèles est en réalité très
complémentaires la discussion générale
est close nous passons à la discussion
du texte de la commission
avec l'article 1er nous commençons avec
deux amendements identiques de
suppression l'amendement numéro 5
présenté par madame à ça si oui merci
madame la présidente très rapidement
parce que je crois que j'ai dit
l'essentiel dans mon intervention dans
la discussion générale mais en fait sur
le fond ma crainte dans la rédaction de
cet article 1er c'est alors qu'une
majorité semble se dégager pour ne pas
être que nous touchons à l'article 122-1
du code pénal tout conte fée avec cet
article
on pourrait effectivement enfin cet
article pourrait conduire à faire tomber
juste que cet article premier qui
pourrait conduire à faire tomber
l'article 122-1 du code pénal et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons la suppression de cet article
1er merci chers collègues la maman
numéro 7 monsieur le président sur merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai
présenté cet amendement lors du débat
général
nous pensons véritablement que la
solution imaginée par la commission des
lois
in fine et n'est pas réaliste parce que
premièrement la chambre de l'accusation
a procédé et procèdent à de vrais
audiences avec contradictoires et
publicité mais deuxièmement nous
considérons que ce n'est pas
fondamentalement le rôle même si le
droit ne permet
2 du tribunal correctionnel et surtout
d'une cour d'assises que de déclarer les
responsabilités ou l'hospitalier
l'hospitalise pour contrainte elle est
beaucoup plus habitués
tout simplement et par conséquent on
change tout à fait l' équilibre de notre
processus judiciaire il faut que la
chambre de l'accusation fasse son
travail et ce n'est pas du tout exclusif
des amendements que nous présenterons
pour justement prendre en compte les cas
et nous les présenterons tout à l'heure
où est organisé par l'auteur en quelque
sorte en toute responsabilité son
irresponsabilité
merci monsieur madame rapporteur votre
avis s'il vous plaît vous ne serez pas
étonnés maxime sociale et l'avis de la
commission est défavorable pour des
raisons différentes d'ailleurs madame
assez si j'ai bien entendu ce que vous
avez dit
lors de la discussion générale mais en
réalité il n'ya pas de contournement la
procédure de l'article 122-1 va rester
intégralement en l'état il y aura
seulement un renvoi devant les
juridictions du fond en cas de faits
fautifs ayant causé l'abolition temporal
du discernement donc absolument pas de
volonté de contourner les dispositions
de l'article 122 par ces dispositions
l'ensemble du bloc de l'instruction des
expertises tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
sera maintenue y compris le débat de la
loi dati dans le cadre de la procédure
d'instruction s'il y a un problème et
notamment à ces fautifs c'est dans ces
cas là et dans ces cas là seulement
qu'il y aura un renvoi devant la
juridiction de jugement c'est la raison
pour laquelle la commission a pris a
donné un avis défavorable à ventre
amendements en ce qui concerne
l'amendement de suppression déposée par
monsieur sueur c'est les mêmes motifs
j'ajoute que la chambre de l'instruction
n'est pas une juridiction de jugement
elle ne prononce pas de peine elle peut
très bien se réunir en l'absence de la
personne responsable de la mise en
examen est en tous les cas elle propose
un sursis à statuer lorsque les
personnes ne sont pas en état d'être
jugé donc il ne s'agit pas déjà d'une
juridiction de jugement et en
conséquence de quoi la commission a
donné un avis défavorable à vos deux
amendements
merci monsieur le ministre mamadou sylla
même la présidente s'étonne à vis de
sagesse sur ces deux amendements
parce qu'en réalité je veux exprimer la
nécessité de débattre de ces questions
je suis évidemment défavorable à
l'article 1er dans sa rédaction
je suis défavorable au texte je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure mais je pense qu'il
est important que nous puissions
débattre et personnellement je suis
toujours très attaché à mon richir du
débat lorsque lorsqu'il est constructif
merci je mets donc on voit ces deux
amendements identiques avec un avis
défavorable de la commission un avis de
sagesse du gouvernement qui votent pour
qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas adoptées nous passons à
l'amendement de cap rectifié bis
présenté par madame eustache brinio
merci madame la présidente nous avons
effectivement souhaité déposer deux
amendements afin de préciser davantage
la portela de l'article 1 élaboré par
madame la rapporteure alors en effet
l'article 1er ne fait référence qu'à
l'hypothèse dans laquelle le lien causal
entre comportements et abolition n'a
conduit qu'à une abolition seulement
temporaire du discernement
nous souhaitons donc par cet article
permettre aux juges du fond lorsque
l'origine de l'absence de discernement
résulte du comportement du mis-en-cause
qu'un procès ait lieu que cette absence
du 6 de discernement soit définitive ou
temporaire donc l'objet du présent
amendement est donc de renvoyer aux
juges du fond
le soin de statuer sur le caractère
temporaire ou non de l'abolition du
discernement
merci cher collègue madame le rapporteur
madame moustache brignolais la
commission a donné un avis défavorable
parce que votre amendement est
totalement contraire à l'esprit du texte
que nous avons voté en commission et
précisément l'idée n'est pas de
transférer toutes les personnes
responsables devant la juridiction de
jugement mais celle seulement dans le
cas d'un fait fautif dont l'abolition
est temporaire donc si vous enlevez
le temporaire du dispositif il devient
totalement déséquilibrée autant
supprimer l'article 122-1 alors
franchement je pense que la commission a
fort bien fait donné un avis défavorable
à votre votre amendement qui
déséquilibre complètement le texte je
vous propose de le retirer
merci madame rapporteur monsieur
ministre oui merci mme la présidente
madame la sénatrice je suis évidemment
sur la même ligne que madame le
rapporteur on les dit et si nous sommes
sur une abolition du discernement qui
n'est pas temporaire et qui est encore
en cours si vous permettez ce raccourci
dans la phase de jugement ça veut dire
qu'on juge un fou et c'est quand même
contrairement à ce que ce que nous
souhaitons il faut quand même que enfin
pardonnez moi que l'accusé soit à même
de comprendre le procès et si nous ne
sommes pas dans cette hypothèse est dans
cette situation alors nous sommes me
semble-t-il au regard vers et qui sont
les nôtres et tout le monde est d'accord
là dessus dans une forme de régression
voilà donc je suis je suis évidemment
défavorable à cet amendement
madame ashton parfait nous passons à
votre amendement numéro trois si si vous
pouvez nous le présenter chers collègues
alors cet amendement concerne concerne
pardon la notion de faits fautifs
effectivement la notion de fait faute il
nous semble parfaitement complexe à
circonscrire est susceptible d'ouvrir la
voie à de multiples interprétations
juridiques non dépourvue de conséquence
d'important pour nous de préciser un
certain nombre de choses
en effet la formulation fait fautif
pourrait être entendu comme renvoyant
nécessairement une infraction pénale
la loi pénale étant d'interprétation
stricte
cela risque de poser quelques
difficultés quelques exemples juste pour
illustrer nos propos mes propos une
consommation excessive d'alcool à son
domicile ne constitue pas en soi une
infraction pénale
pas plus que la non prise d'un
traitement médicamenteux consécutif à
une pathologie psychiatrique qui ne
serait pas imposé par l'autorité
judiciaire aux ti d'une obligation de
soins donc pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons il nous paraît indispensable de
supprimer
l'adjectif fautif de l'article 1er afin
de ne pas limiter la caractérisation des
cas dans lequel le comportement du
mis-en-cause a contribué à l'abolition
de son discernement quand bien même ce
comportement n'est pas constitutif en
soi d'une infraction pénale voilà
l'objet de cet amendement qui nous
semble essentiel pour conforter cet
article merci
si cher collègue madame le rapporteur
votre à vis à vis de sagesse merci
président monsieur le ministre le thème
la présidente mme hasina triche contenu
de mes réserves sur l'article promis je
ne faisais trop favorable à un
amendement qui on élargit que encore le
domaine d'application je suis
défavorable c'était mon âme
merci je mets donc on voit monsieur le
président retailleau oui madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre un mot
d'explication pour le vote qui sera un
vote de soutien de cet amendement on l'a
vu lors de nos différents échanges je
pense qu'on s'accorde tous sur deux
points le principe sacro-saint principe
selon lequel on ne peut pas juger les
fous c'est la raison pour laquelle
jackie de salle vrignaud il ya quelques
instants à retirer après les
explications de la rapporteure et du
garde des sceaux
son amendement là il s'agit d'autre
chose puisque si nous ne voulons pas
juger les fous nous voulons apporter une
un remède un texte je crois qu'ils
nécessitent un peu d'explication comme
l'a dit d'ailleurs jean pierre sueur le
statu quo n'est pas possible nous avons
rejoint d'ailleurs l'analyse de la
commission des lois et du rapporteur
pour que les familles des victimes
voir les victimes si elles sont encore
en vie puisse bénéficier d'un procès le
procès est quelque chose d'important
tous deux n'ont de cesse pour la victime
qui est encore vivante ou alors pour ça
en famille ou pour ses proches je pense
que la ligne de crête dégagée par la
commission elle est bonne c'est cette
idée lorsque il y à une sorte de
causalité de volontariat pour lequel
donc celui qui a commis le délit ou le
crime l'a fait volontairement bien il a
donc aboli son discernement de valeureux
volontaire là cet amendement souhaite
qu' on puisse enlever retirée du texte
le fait fautif parce que qu'est ce que
nous recherchons ce que nous recherchons
c'est que le fait générateur soit la
volonté de celui qui justement par la
prise d'alcool immodéré ou de
stupéfiants aboli son discernement
peu importe la cause qui est fautif ou
non fautif que ce soit sa volonté ou est
que cette volonté soit lié à une
infraction or le fait fautif renvoie
directement à une infraction pénale
c'est ce que nous ne voulons pas
jacqueline salle vrignaud a donné deux
exemples qui sont je trouve probants
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que la notion de faits fautifs atténue
en réalité le dispositif que nous
propose madame le rapporteur et la
commission des lois c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous soutiendrons cet
amendement merci président je mets donc
on voit cet amendement avec un avis de
sagesse de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui vote
pour qui votre compte qui s'abstient il
est adopté
nous en venons à l'amendement numéro 8
présenté par madame de la gontrie pardon
merci madame la présidente
nous l'avons dit nous sommes
défavorables à l'article 1 mais pour
autant nous proposons ici une précision
procédurale c'est que
l'examen de la de l'irresponsabilité
éventuels soient examinées par la
juridiction de jugement avant l'examen
de la sphère au fond parce que c'est
toujours le cas pour d exception de
procédure mais je pense que c'est très
important de le rappeler de le préciser
parce que nous l'avons évoqué tout à
l'heure jean pierre sueur l'a précisé
lorsqu'une course d'assises va être
saisie de ce type de situation il faut
traiter
d'emblée la question de
l'irresponsabilité avant que ne s'ouvre
le débat sur les faits parce que vous
comprenez bien que notre crainte qui est
que finalement des jurés populaires ne
pourraient pas décidé de prononcer
l'irresponsabilité serait alors renforcé
et donc en toute logique nous souhaitons
que donc l'examen de cette
irresponsabilité pénale éventuels soient
examinés et trancher avant l'examen de
l'affairé au fond
merci cher collègue madame le rapporteur
votre avis s'il vous plaît la commission
a donné un avis de sagesse ce même de la
gontrie sur cet amendement pour une
raison essentielle c'est que vous avez
parfaitement compris le dispositif
donc à partir du moment où vous avez
compris le dispositif qui a un garde le
blog de l'article 122 1 et 2 on ne
défère que les gens dont
le comportement a été abolie
temporairement à partir de ce moment là
il n'y a aucune difficulté même la vie
de sagesse provient du fait qu'on a pas
pu évaluer le dispositif mais mais c'est
un avis de sagesse parce
qu'effectivement hockey in limine litis
sur la sur la responsabilité me semble
pas ne me semble pas un problème c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons rendu
un avis de sagesse positive mathieu
ministre s'il vous plaît votre avis
merci madame la présidente je suis
défavorable à cet amendement je vois pas
trop comment on peut dissocier l'examen
de l'irresponsabilité pour cause de
trouble mental et l'examen du fond du
dossier ont pas trop comment on peut
faire ça non pratiquement j'ai du mal à
le concevoir
je suis défavorable à cet amendement
merci de vos précisions
madame de la conterie pour explication
de vote
peut-être pour indiquer au garde des
sceaux que c'est précisément ce que fait
la chambre de l'instruction
donc je suis intrigué de votre argument
la chambre de l'instruction examine la
question de l'irresponsabilité pénale
alors même qu' elle ne va pas statuer
sur le fond
donc je pense que votre argument n'est
pas recevable est donc cet amendement
est maintenu merci je mets donc qu'on
voit monsieur richard la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
désolé j'étais moi la réponse de madame
de la gontrie ne satisfait pas je suis
totalement de l'opinion du garde des
sceaux je sais pas comment on va pouvoir
juger de l'irresponsabilité sans parler
du fond alors vous dites madame de la
gontrie la chambre d'instruction fait
bien cela oui mais là on est en et en
jugement donc on est en jugement alors
en vertu de quoi non mais sérieusement
c'est le but on renvoi en jugement
tendez la solution proposée par la
commission saison assez justement pour
régler le problème de l'
irresponsabilité pénale dans un cadre
déterminé un contexte déterministe et de
renvoyer en audience du jean et vous
êtes en train de dire mais non et
finalement il faut séparer
d'abord se préoccuper de la question de
la responsabilité
je comprends pas partir du moment où on
renvoie en audience de jugement
c'est juste impossible de séparer la
question du respect de la responsabilité
avec celles du fonds enfin voyons
merci je mets donc on voit cet
amendement avec un avis de sagesse de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui votent pour
six sept huit ans
et
qui va de contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté je mets aux
voix l'article 1er ainsi modifié qui
votent pour contre l'abstention il était
adopté
nous passons à une série d'articles
additionnel après l'article 1er
l'amendement numéro 10 présentée par
monsieur sur madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre le discernement est
nécessaire à l'établissement de
l'imputabilité élément indispensable
pour répondre pénalement des
conséquences de ses actes il est en
fuite une composante essentielle de la
capacité l'aptitude à la sanction
fut présente en comprendre le sens
c'est pourquoi il nous est apparu utile
et opportun d'inscrire dans le code
pénal
une définition du discernement merci
madame la rapporteure votre avis s'il
vous plaît alors il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de effectivement de définition
du discernement c'est pourquoi je
voudrais la ville gouvernement sur cet
amendement
monsieur le ministre un oui madame la
présidente le discernement quand
quelqu'un à son discernement c'est qu'il
sait ce qu'il fait un peu plus compliqué
que ça alors vous allez rajouter une
définition qui va complexifier encore on
peut faire la définition de la
définition je vais vous dire d'ailleurs
que ce qui est compliqué c'est savoir si
à une abolition totale du discernement
ou simplement une altération et alors
dans le code de justice pénale des
mineurs qui a été votée il ya peu de
tout on est défini le discernement et on
modifie parce que cette notion
n'existait pas dans lordonnance de 45 et
voilà comment la définit est capable de
discernement de majeur qui a le mineur
pardonnez moi et l'acsi c'est révélateur
le mineur qui a compris évolue son acte
et qui est apte à comprendre le sens de
la procédure pénale dont il fait l'objet
et puis je rappelle pour le risque la
notion discernement résulte
a été utilisé depuis une loi de juillet
92 et n'a strictement poser à ma
connaissance aucun problème
on s'est jamais posé la question de ce
qu'est quel discernement en fait tout le
monde le le sens de ce qu'est le
discernement voilà pourquoi je suis
défavorable à cet amendement monsieur le
sénateur merci monsieur le ministre
maintenant que vous êtes et éclairé
madame la rapporteure le rapporteur
suivre évidemment l'avis du gouvernement
l'avis de la commission est donc
défavorable défavorable
madame de la gontrie pour explication de
vote je pense que des tours de cet
amendement on aborde un point qui est
fondamental dans la précision que nous
voulons instaurer désormais dans le
traitement de ce type d'affaires la
notion de discernement c'est une notion
à laquelle on a beaucoup recours en en
droit pénal mais qui effectivement
n'était pas défini jusqu'à présent et le
rappel de garde est utile nous avons
éprouvé le besoin de le déterminer pour
les mineurs et nous ne le ferions pas
pour les majeurs c'est étrange et ce qui
a été proposé ici est une adaptation au
fait qu'on parle d'un majeur de la
définition qui a été développé pour les
mineurs et je pense que là où nous avons
vu des appréciations variées sur l'état
des personnes qui devaient être jugés
c'est peut-être aussi parce que ces
définitions n'était pas précisément
défini donc nous cherchons la
clarification et c'est le sens de cette
proposition
merci monsieur spurs avaient demandé la
parole pour explication de vote non
celle de votre collègue suffit très bien
j'enregistre je mets donc aux voix cet
amendement avec deux avis défavorables
qui vautours contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté l'amendement numéro 9
de ceux sur merci madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des sceaux
cet amendement prévoit donc comme je
l'expliquais dans la discussion générale
la possibilité d'imputer la
responsabilité de l'auteur d'une
infraction dont l'abolition du
discernement serait la cause exclusive
de la prise volontaire de toxiques
je rappelle qu'elle s'inspire de
l'article 20 de la loi organique 23
novembre du code pénal espagnol qui
prévoit ainsi l'établissement de la
responsabilité pénale
dès lors que l'intoxication est
volontairement recherché en vue de se
mettre soi même dans un état dans lequel
il n'y a plus de responsabilités ni de
discernement il nous paraît que dès lors
que nous ne voulons pas rester au statu
quo des formulations comme celles ci
sont absolument nécessaires
merci cher collègue madame le rapporteur
votre avis c'est alors le service de
droit comparé et du sénat a donné une
explication exhaustive de l'ensemble des
codes européens y compris le code
espagnol que vous citez qui constitue
une exception à l'article 122-1
évidemment et donc c'est précisément ce
que nous souhaitons pas mais c'est
surtout que le cas que qui est souligné
dans cet amendement est déjà largement
appliquée par la jurisprudence et ne
posent régulièrement et qui est qui est
vraiment tout à fait constante sur le
sujet que ce soit la personne qui
s'intoxiquent pour se donner du courage
pour commettre un acte il ya absolument
unoca aucun problème jurisprudentielle
en ce qui concerne ce cas qui
consisterait évidemment si on adoptait à
amender l'article 122 inscrits
précisément ce que la commission ne
souhaite pas faire c'est la raison pour
laquelle la commission a donné un avis
défavorable
en fait monsieur de manière ma vie
monsieur le député monsieur le sénateur
sur votre votre amendement pose une
vraie question à laquelle je ne suis pas
insensible
il ya la folie endogène au fond il ya la
folie qui aurait des causes exogènes
notamment la prise de psychotropes
d'alcool et vous suggérer de pénaliser
ceux là c'est à dire celui qui
volontairement absorbe des produits
psychotropes l'alcool en très ou trop
grande quantité et qui perd la raison de
ce fait et qui commet une infraction
c'est une piste à laquelle je travaille
elle a nourri ma réflexion
j'ai préparé un texte qui vient d'être
soumis au conseil d'état et je suis à
cet instant je vous demande à cet
instant de retirer cet amendement
et s'il n'y a pas de retrait c'est
défavorable donc par ce monsieur sûr je
fis sensible à l'intérêt que porte
monsieur le garde des sceaux à notre
rédaction
mais vous comprendrez que nous ne
retirerons pas l'amendement
car l'amendement car l'argument en vertu
duquel le gouvernement a préparé de son
côté un texte et l'a soumis au conseil
d'état ne saurait être un argument en
vertu duquel en discutant du présent
texte
nous devrions retirer notre opposition
voilà
merci je mets donc je vois cet
amendement numéro 9 avec deux avis
défavorables qui votent pour ou contre
qui s'abstient d'y faire adopter nos
passions à l'amendement numéro 2
présenté par monsieur benachenhou la
présidente
les personnes déclarées irresponsables
peuvent au titre des mesures prévues à
l'article 706 135 par décision motivée
être admis aux soins psychiatriques sous
la forme d'une hospitalisation complète
sur le modèle des soins sans
consentement
le présent amendement prévoit la
possibilité nouvelle pour le juge du
fond comme indiqué dans la
recommandation du rapport sur la mission
sur les responsabilités pénales
roduit en février 2021 de prononcer en
complément de cette hospitalisation
une mesure de sûreté d'obligation de
soins pour aller jusqu'à 20 en nombre
des mesures essentielles pour le bon
déroulement de notre système judiciaire
notamment celle sur la revalorisation du
travail des experts sur d'ordre
règlementaire et ne pourront faire
l'objet que d'une action du gouvernement
toutefois un des poids qu'il m'a paru
essentiel d'intégrer dans notre arsenal
législatives est une des propositions
concernant l'obligation de soins comme
mesure de sûreté
en effet plus en plus de la décision
d'admission en hôpital de soins
psychiatriques lors de la décision des
responsabilités le rapport commandé au
dock par madame belloubet suggère de
manière judicieuse de permettre au juge
de prononcer une peine de sûreté
li a l'obligation de soins il est
logique de vouloir éviter ce qui
pourrait s'assimiler à des sorties
sèches et de soumettre les personnes
dans le discernement était aboli de
manière temporaire ou non un suivi post
hospitalisation
merci madame la reporter votre avis ils
vont claire en la commission a donné un
avis favorable de cet amendement
monsieur le ministre
le juge chez le juge le médecin c'est le
médecin
enfin pardon il faut être clair
là-dessus pour moi c'est une ligne rouge
infranchissable
je suis totalement défavorable à ça on
va judiciariser quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre de la psychiatrie ça c'est
curieux et je trouve ça plutôt va même
pas j'enlève le mot plutôt je trouve ça
inquiétant
pas d'explications de vote je mets donc
aux voix cet amendement numéro deux avec
un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui votent
pour
m
quelques
qu'ils votent contre
m
qui s'abstient il était adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 6 présentée
par la présidente a ceci merci madame la
présidente cet article crée une
aggravation des peines pour les crimes
et délits commis en étant en état
d'intoxication les questions de prise de
stupéfiants de consommation d'alcool
devrait d'abord être mieux traités d'un
point de vue sanitaire plutôt que d'être
plutôt qu'être sans cesse ramener sur le
plan pénal en outils chum me réfère au
rapport de la commission je lis je cite
qu'elle a constaté qu une part
prédominante des cas d' irresponsabilité
pénale comporte la consommation de
stupéfiants et d'alcool et que la
commission je continue à inciter a en
conséquence estimé nécessaire d'agir sur
les facteurs déterminants de les
responsabilités en faisant de l'état
d'ivresse alcoolique ou sous l'emprise
de stupéfiants une circonstance
aggravante pour l'ensemble des crimes et
délits fin de citation donc je le répète
encore une fois légiférer en ce sens ce
serait oublier que les comportements de
prise de drogue ou d'alcool ne sont pas
nécessairement fautif mais qu'ils
peuvent être non pas la cause de
l'abolition du discernement mais la
conséquence de cette abolition une
mauvaise observance des soins un arrêt
du traitement une consommation excessive
d'alcool ou de stupéfiants peuvent faire
partie de la maladie et non être la
cause de cette maladie
ces situations sont d'ailleurs très
fréquentes dans le cas des psychoses des
traitements administrés pouvant avoir
des effets inhibiteurs inhibiteur qui
met qui mine toute activité quotidienne
et ce faisant être substituée à tort
pour nous mais à raison pour eux par des
toxiques qui soulage sur le moment quoi
qu'il en soit il n'apparaît pas
concevable de revoir d'autres chaînes
notre échelle des peines au détour d'une
proposition de loi que je qualifie
encore de circonstance merci madame la
reporter votre avis s'il vous plaît oui
madame a6 et a7 un avis défavorable chez
vous
pourquoi d'abord en étudiant très
attentivement l'ensemble de la de la
jurisprudence sur le sujet de
l'irresponsabilité l'alcool et les
stupéfiants sont très très souvent au
milieu du dispositif
mais c'est surtout qu'on a examiné avec
beaucoup d'attention les dispositions du
code pénal et on s'est rendu compte en
faisant un examen assez attentif qui
avait au moins 7 des lycées pelle et
crime qui n'était pas dans la peine
n'était pas aggravée en cas de prise
d'alcool et de stupéfiants parmi
lesquels les actes de barbarie et de
torture
le meurtre là les coups et blessures
ayant entraîné la mort
les violences volontaires ayant entraîné
une mutilation et infirmité permanente
un homicide involontaire et des
blessures involontaires
donc cette disposition globale puisque
on a eu un peu de temps pour faire le
point complet du dispositif cette
disposition globale permet à la fois
pour les articles qui ne comporte pas de
clause d'augmentation de peine
l'aggravation et ceux à venir donc
l'ensemble des délits et des peines de
pouvoir proposer une aggravation en cas
de prise d'alcool et de stupéfiants
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission était défavorable de votre
amendement merci monsieur le ministre
parfait jamais donc on voit cet
amendement mais c'est le prix monsieur
le questeur soeur pardon merci madame la
présidente
nous allons soutenir cet amendement
numéro 6 de madame assassi parce que
d'abord j'ai souvent dit que
l'application de l'article 45 dans notre
assemblée comme dans l'autre a semblé
relever souvent de l'aléatoire nous en
avons quelques exemples ici ça va tout à
fait au delà de l'objet du texte premier
point et deuxièmement attention à ne pas
mélanger ce qui relève de la médecine de
la santé et ce qui relève du tout
judiciaire ou ce qui relèverait
tout judiciaire il y a là une double
confusion
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
soutiendrons l'article 2 est par
conséquent s'il n'était pas adoptée nous
voterons contre nous nous soutenons
amendement 6 et nous voterons contre
l'article 2 merci de vos précisions
chers collègues je mets donc cet
amendement aux voix avec deux avis
défavorables qui vautours qui va te
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adoptée je mets aux voix l'article 2 qui
votent pour qu'ils votent contre qui
s'abstient l'article 2 est adoptée d
article additionnel après l'article de
le premier rectifiée présentée par
madame boyer merci madame la présidente
mes chers collègues je vous remercie
d'avoir donné un avis favorable pendant
la commission à cet amendement qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte
particulièrement dramatique dans notre
pays puisque je voudrais évoquer le cas
de stéphanie qui a été assassiné à
hayange à 22 ans abattu lâchement en
pleine rue par son conjoint violent
la victime avait pourtant porté plainte
et j'ajoute que ce sont 43 femmes qui
sont assassinés par leur conjoint depuis
le début de l'année la lutte contre les
violences conjugales est un combat qui
concerne toute la société c'est un
combat universel un certain nombre
d'associations de parlementaires
juristes mène ce combat depuis plusieurs
années mais il n'avance jamais assez
vite
permettez moi de saluer l'engagement de
maître nathalie tommasini avec qui je
travaille depuis plusieurs années
maintenant
elle est notamment l'avocate de valérie
bako valérie bako est accusé d'avoir tué
en 2016 son mari au terme de plusieurs
années d'horreur des horreurs sur
lesquelles je ne vais pas revenir là
mais surtout ce qui est important
aujourd'hui et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je présente cet amendement
c'est qu'elle encourt aujourd'hui après
avoir tué son conjoint d'une peine de
prison à perpétuité
aussi mes cercles
il ne s'agit pas de s'ériger en juges
mais de poser la question suivante est
elle une meurtrière où une victime sur
cette question l'expert spica a reconnu
la preuve pour la première fois dans une
expertise sont requises par le parquet
en france que l'accusé était atteinte au
moment des faits du syndrome de la femme
battue
je rappelle que le canada reconnaît le
syndrome de la femme battue depuis 1990
concrètement la personne atteinte de ce
syndrome ne peut plus prendre de
décisions raisonnables et raisonnées
toutes les attaques du conjoint violent
touche l'intégrité psychique de la
victime qui devient alors prisonnière de
la situation qu'elle subit cet état de
soumission de danger de mort permanent
vécu pendant des années peut entraîner
un comportement extrême
cela aboutit malheureusement dans la
plupart des cas au suicide de la victime
de violence dans les cas extrêmement
rare la victime se retourne contre le
conjoint car il n'y a pas d'autre issue
que de le tuer pour ne pas mourir c'est
lui ou moi aussi mes chers collègues à
travers l'amendement que je vous propose
de voter
il ne s'agit pas de délivrer un permis
de tuer mais de reconnaître l'impact des
violences conjugales sur l'état
psychique de la personne victime de
violences et de prévoir une ride et
responsabilité pénale est tendue merci
cher collègue madame leurs rapporteurs
bon la commission a donné un avis
favorable après la modification
de cet amendement depuis la première
depuis son passage en commission
donc l'avis est favorable mais si elle
garde des sceaux totalement défavorable
à cet amendement non pas que j'ignore ce
que vous portez
non pas que ce que vous portez soit
illégitime mais endroit ça pose un
véritable problème
je ne comprends pas la rédaction cet
amendement endroit ça me paraît
totalement thierry cheval ça me paraît
un peu dangereux pardonnez-moi est tel
qu'il est rédigé votre amendement s'il
était retenu
c'est une disposition qui n'étaient en
effet pas normative et qui n'a pas à
s'inscrire comme vous le souhaitez dans
la loi je comprend l'objectif mais
j'avoue que le droit et en particulier
le droit pénal ce n'est pas c'est
quelque chose d'infiniment précis le
rappelait tout à l'heure l'une de vos
collègues merci je mets donc aux voix ce
marie pierre de la gontrie pour
explication de vote
oui merci madame la présidente
cet amendement est quelque part un peu
gênant parce que il pile pause et
l'exposé des motifs de valérie boyer
le développent de manière très très
efficaces et nous sommes tous je
l'espère mais j'en suis sûr convaincu
ici de la nécessité de la lutte contre
les violences conjugales mais ici nous
sommes en train effectivement de faire
la loi
est ce que vous décrivez c'est le
principe même de l'appréciation
d'éventuelles circonstances atténuantes
lorsqu'on juge une affaire
potentiellement criminel évidemment les
circonstances la personnalité de la
victime de l'auteur était à terrasson
sont développées et étudiées examiner et
là vous restreignez finalement le champ
de cette possibilité à un seul type
d'infraction donc là je trouve que ces
problématiques et où je suis un peu mal
à l'aise c'est que de la même manière
que vous l'avez fait tout à l'heure nous
traitons d'un sujet lourd au détour d'un
texte qui ne portent pas là dessus
qu'ils portent sur l'irresponsabilité
pénale et qui du coup de manière un
petit peu rapide il faut bien le dire ne
peut pas être travaillés de manière
complète donc de la même manière tout à
l'heure vous allez vous avez voulu d'un
trait de plume revoir
l'échelle dès peines ici vous voulez
sans que gens comprennent très bien
comme le garde des sceaux la rédaction
précisé indiqué une forme de
circonstance je ne sais pas donc je
pense que cet amendement n'est pas
aboutie et pour ma part et pour notre
part ne voteront pas merci madame boyer
pour expliquer son vote
madame moyenne mandela rebollal par la
main par nous merci madame la présidente
je dois dire que je crois que tout le
monde on comprend l'objectif et si il
est dans ce texte de loi c'est parce que
justement nous parlons des difficultés
que peuvent rencontrer certaines
personnes lorsqu'ils sont dans des
situations extrêmes et notamment les
violences conjugales
l altération du jugement compte tenu du
caractère de violence qui qui met la
personne victime de violences en état de
danger de mort permanent
ce stress il est décrit je vais pas
revenir sur ce que j'ai dit dans
l'exposé des motifs qui reprend une
partie d'experts mandaté par les
tribunaux ce qui se passe pour ces
femmes victimes de violence sont des
faits de torture mentale qui font
qu'elles sont dans un état de stress
total est aujourd'hui j'ai revu cet
amendement bien évidemment à la demande
de la commission je pense que c'est pas
quelque chose qui a été étudié dans la
précipitation parce que ça fait de
nombreuses années qui effectivement j'ai
travaillé sur cette question que ce soit
l'assemblée nationale où ici et
justement puisque nous parlions de
l'altération du jugement là ce n'est pas
lié au fait que la personne prennent des
drogues soient très alcoolisé et sait
c'est qu'elle est dans un état de stress
total c'est à dire qu'elle a après être
s'être fait battre
elle attend la prochaine fois où son
conjoint va continuer à la torturer et à
faire en sorte que son jugement soit
altérée donc je ne vois pas pourquoi il
ne pourrait pas s'inscrire dans ce texte
d'autant que je les retravailler à la
demande de la commission qu'il a reçu un
avis favorable et que je crois que ce
n'est qu'il n'est pas un précis et que
là et qu il me semble qu'aujourd'hui
cette situation est attendu depuis de
nombreuses années madame la présidente
billon il faudra que je remercie madame
la présidente
les violences intrafamiliales les
violences faites aux femmes elles
alimentent régulièrement l'actualité
hélas de féminicide encore ces derniers
jours l'emprise c'est véritablement une
stratégie implacable qui est mise en
oeuvre par les agresseurs par les
prédateurs sexuels
l'emprise c'est le moyen 10
et sa victime et ainsi ça donne la
possibilité à l'agresseur de poursuivre
de manière d'un impunément ses actes de
barbarie cet amendement déposé par notre
collègue valérie boyer permettent
d'apporter enfin une réponse à cette
situation
enfin prendre en compte la réalité des
victimes qui ont traversé des années de
violence en silence souvent d'agression
sexuelle de viol de torture
psychologique des victimes qui n'ont
jamais eu le statut de victime
donc grâce à cet amendement on leur
reconnaît enfin le statut de victime
donc bien entendu je soutiens cet
amendement et je remercie
valérie boyer de l'avoir déposé cela ne
me fait rien pour explication de vote
merci madame et présidente en fait je
pense que il est peut-être un problème
de rédaction de cet amendement parce que
si on le lit on parle de l'impact de ces
violences sur la victime est pris en
compte alors qu'on parle bien de
l'auteur qui préalablement aurait été
victime de violences c'est hier que
l'article 122-1 il s'applique à des
hauteurs pas des victimes
oui donc mais c'est pas ce qui est écrit
c'est à dire que là on parle de la
victime on s'interroge sur la
responsabilité pénale de la victime
alors que l'on parle bien là en
l'occurrence d'un auteur une hauteur
souvent qui aurait été préalablement
victime de celui qu'elle a tué par
exemple donc voilà donc je pense que il
ya peut-être une incompréhension c'est
dire que on s'interroge bien sûr la
responsabilité pénale d'une personne qui
aurait agi alors qu'elle était sous
emprise et préalablement victimes même
très bien
nous passons donc au vote pour cet
amendement numéro 30 numéro un pardon
avec un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui votent
pour
nous
5 qui votent contre
il était adopté derniers amendements
numéro 11 présentée par monsieur chère
si madame la présidente vous laisser une
aire de dessau mes chers collègues
une des raisons des divergences entre
les experts ou les collèges d'experts
dans les situations de passage à l'acte
pénalement a incriminé a lieu dans les
situations où le passage à l'acte
pénalement incriminé a eu lieu sont
toxiques
si internet que certains experts
tiennent compte de la position ses
filles du sujet au moment de la prise la
substance psychoactive pour rejeter la
teinte discernement alors que d'autres
se limitent strictement la question
posée et à la caractérisation de l'état
psychique au moment de l'acte dont dans
l'hypothèse où la prise de toxiques a pu
jouer un rôle dans le passage à l'acte
les experts pourrait poser la question
suivante qui ferait partie de la
nomenclature décrire les conditions les
motivations et les conséquences
dans l'hypothèse où des conséquences
telles que la prise de toxiques et où un
arrêt d'un traitement médical peuvent
avoir provoquer ou accentuer un état
pathologique altérant ou un bol hissant
le discernement entre avant ou
abolissant le contrôle des actes
tel est l'objet de cet amendement merci
monsieur soir madame le rapporteur votre
avis écoutez en regardant l'amendement
on avait
compris la nécessité pour les experts de
se prononcer sur la participation active
à la paire du discernement
c'était une
une sagesse négative parce que c'est un
avis c'est la décision et réglementaires
elle relève définitivement du pouvoir
réglementaire
donc je pense que cette on va attendre
l'avis du gouvernement mais ça me semble
être d'une mesure totalement
réglementaire mais chez ministre votre
avis est requis donc porter le
gouvernement il pense que c'est
effectivement du réglementaire et donc
il est défavorable à votre amendement
donc la commission est défavorable
madame le rapporteur parfait jamais donc
on voit l'amendement numéro 11
avec deux avis défavorables qui votent
pour qu'ils votent contre qui s'abstient
qui m'est fait adopter jeu mais se voit
l'article 3 qui votent tour contre
abstentions il est adopté sur les
articles 4 à 10 puisque considéré que le
vote sera le même c'est à dire qu'il est
adapté
alors madame ceci si vous avez merlin
président je voudrais faire quand même
une explication de vote sur cet article
car j'en ai dit deux mots dans ma dans
l'intervention général mais je voulais
re préciser ici que cet article 4 en
fait vise à compléter plusieurs articles
du code de procédure pénale afin de
restreindre le champ de l'examen
clinique de garde à vue au seul examen
de compatibilité n'ont pas de
comptabilité de l'état de santé de la
personne avec la mesure en excluant
expressément les expertises les
expertises psychiatriques ou
psychologiques requise par l'instruction
judiciaire
nous pensons parce que nous y avons
beaucoup travaillé que cet article à
l'instar des articles 3 à 10 vont dans
le bon sens et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voterai pour cet article 4
même si pour être tout à fait honnête et
sincère
les deux premiers articles de la ppl qui
représente quand même le coeur de la
raison pour l'heure pour laquelle nous
légiférons aujourd'hui ne nous
conviennent pas de je voulais simplement
précisé que nous voterons cet article
qui ne donne pas ce qui ne veut pas dire
que nous voterons l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi je mets donc aux voix
l'article 4 qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté
je me vois l'article 5 qui votent pour
contre abstentions il est adopté je
considère que les votes seront
identiques jusqu'au 10 dans cette même
configuration
parfait donc les articles 5 à 10 sont
eux aussi adopté je mets aux voix
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
relative aux cause de l'irresponsabilité
pénale et aux conditions de réalisation
de l' expertise en matière pénale qui
votent pour qu'ils votent contre qui
s'abstient cette proposition de loi est
votée voilà le sénat n'a donc finalement
adopté cette proposition de loi qui veut
réformer la question de
l'irresponsabilité pénale et cela après
laffaire sarah halimi noter que le texte
finalement adopté était beaucoup plus
prudent que la version initiale
il ne touche pas au code pénal et laisse
le soin aux juges de juger est justement
de la responsabilité pénale d'un prévenu
on ne touche pas à ce principe qui veut
qu'on ne juge pas les fous noter qu'en
parallèle le garde des sceaux eric
dupond-moretti prépare son propre projet
de loi déjà transmis au conseil d'état
dans un instant vous avez rendez vous
avec allons plus loin et rebecca
fitoussi très bonne soirée sur public
sénat
[Musique]